ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today we are
discussing fertility.
We will discuss male fertility
and female fertility.
And I should mention that
today's discussion is not just
for people who are seeking
to conceive children
or who want to know how their
children were conceived,
but it's really for everybody.
And I say that because it
is the story of all of us.
All of us are here
because a specialized set
of cells, called germ cells--
that is the sperm and the egg.
And I'll make it very
clear why they're called
germ cells a little bit later.
It has nothing to
do with infection.
But it's because a sperm cell
and an egg cell arrived at one
another, either in vivo-- inside
of our mother-- or in vitro--
so-called in vitro
fertilization-- and then
we're implanted into our
mother and became us.
And so understanding
the process of how
the egg cell and the
sperm cell came to be
is really the key
to understanding
how that fertilization
process came to be.
Now, I know
everyone's thinking, I
know how fertilization occurs.
It occurs through sexual
intercourse and so on.
And we'll talk a
little bit about that.
But I promise you
that if you understand
the menstrual cycle--
and the menstrual cycle
in today's conversation
can best be thought of as
a biological cycle that
occurs in females that allows
the potential for fertilization
by the sperm, because
that's really what it is,
and it's a beautifully
orchestrated process
that I'll describe to you.
And I should say, all people,
males and females, should
really understand how the
menstrual cycle works,
how it impacts
fertilization, but also
how it impacts the brain and
body, behavior, psychology,
et cetera.
And we'll also talk
about spermatogenesis,
how sperm cells come to
be and how they arrive--
that is, how they
swim to the egg--
and the incredible interplay
between the biology
of the sperm and the
biology of the egg
leads to this incredible thing
that we call embryogenesis
and the birth of the
child and, of course,
the development of that child
into an infant, a toddler,
an adolescent, a
teen, and an adult.
Today's discussion,
again, is not just
for those of you that are
seeking to have children.
And I say that because
when you look at the data,
you look at the literature
on longevity and vitality,
two themes in biology that
oftentimes people lump together
but aren't always the
same-- for instance,
there are a lot
of things that we
can do to increase our
vitality that actually
can harm our longevity.
But there are a subset of
biological rules and mechanisms
that, when aligned,
allow us to maximize both
our vitality and our longevity.
And I think it's fair to say
that all of those mechanisms
and tools are housed
in the discussion
around maximizing fertility.
And that's true whether or
not you're male or female.
In other words, if
you want children
or if you don't, if you
already have children
or if you don't, understanding
how fertility and fertilization
occurs in the
brain and body will
allow you to maximize your
vitality and longevity.
And of course,
today's discussion
will provide an
understanding of the biology
and many actionable tools that
will also help you conceive
children, if that's your wish.
So of course, as is
characteristic of this podcast,
we will discuss
science-based tools,
including behavioral tools, both
the dos and the don'ts, and we
will discuss nutrition-based
tools and supplementation-based
tools and some other practices,
including things like
acupuncture, which have quite
good data to support them
in terms of improving fertility.
And we will discuss why those
certain practices can work.
And we will discuss
prescription drugs
that your doctor can prescribe
to you if, for instance, you
have a deficit at the
level of hormone production
or neurotransmitter production
at the level of the brain
or the pituitary gland--
I'll explain what all of
those things are soon--
or the gonads, the ovary and
the testes in females and males
respectively.
Again, by the end
of today's episode,
you will have a lot of knowledge
and actionable tools related
to maximizing
fertility, and you will
have a lot of knowledge and
actionable tools related
to maximizing vitality
and longevity.
Before we begin, I'd
like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to
consumer information
about science and
science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with
that theme, I'd like
to thank the sponsors
of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor
is Maui Nui Meats.
Maui Nui Meats, I
can confidently say,
are the most nutrient-dense and
delicious red meat available.
Maui Nui he spent
nearly a decade
building a USDA-certified
wild harvesting system
to help balance invasive
deer populations
on the island of Maui.
The solution they built
turns the proliferation
of an invasive species
into a wide range
of nutrient-dense products, from
fresh butcher cuts and organ
meats to bone broth,
jerky, and even pet treats.
Their bone broth has
an unmatched 25 grams
of protein per 100 calories.
I've talked before
on this podcast
and I've had several expert
guests come on this podcast
to talk about the fact
that most people should aim
to get 1 gram of quality
protein per pound
of body weight per day
in order to maximize
their health, tissue repair,
which includes brain tissue
repair, and, if you're an active
exerciser, to support recovery
from exercise.
Maui Nui Meats have an
incredible quality protein
to calorie ratio.
And I mentioned the bone broth.
I should also mention that their
ground meats and their venison
steaks are absolutely
delicious, and their jerky
is absolutely terrific.
In fact, it's the only jerky
that I've eaten consistently
that I happen to like
consistently over time.
If you'd like to try
Maui Nui Venison,
go to
mauinuivenison.com/huberman
to get 20% off your first order.
Again, that's
mauinuivenison.com/huberman
to get 20% off your first order.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress
covers with cooling, heating,
and sleep tracking capacity.
I've talked many times
before on this podcast
about the fact that sleep
is the fundamental layer
of mental health, physical
health, and performance.
Now, one of the key things for
getting a great night's sleep
every single night is to
optimize the temperature
of your sleeping environment.
Put simply, in order to fall
asleep and stay deeply asleep,
your body temperature needs to
drop by about 1 to 3 degrees.
And waking up, on
the other hand,
involves a heating of your
body by about 1 to 3 degrees.
With Eight Sleep, you
can tune the temperature
of your mattress
cover or mattress
to be cooler or
hotter, depending on
whether or not you tend to
run too hot or too cold,
and you can even vary
it across the night
so that you can access
the best deep sleep early
in the night, the so-called
REM sleep, rapid eye movement
sleep, that's more pronounced
in the later half of the night
and in doing so really
get your sleep optimized,
not just in terms of duration
but in terms of quality
and the overall
architecture of your sleep.
This has a profound influence
on your alertness, focus, mood,
and many other important
factors throughout the day.
If you'd like to
try Eight Sleep,
you can go to
eightsleep.com/huberman to save
up to $150 off
their Pod 3 cover.
Today's episode is also brought
to us by Momentous Supplements.
I want to acknowledge that not
everybody needs supplements,
and yet many, many people
derive tremendous benefit
from proper supplementation.
I would count myself
in that group.
There are excellent supplements
for improving the depth
and quality of sleep,
for improving focus,
and for improving energy
and for hormone optimization
and many other factors related
to our mental health, physical
health, and performance.
We've partnered with
Momentous Supplements
for three important reasons.
First of all,
Momentous supplements
are of the very highest quality.
Second of all, they
ship internationally,
and we know that
many of you reside
outside of the United States.
And third, they focus on
single ingredient formulations.
This is very important.
There is a place for blends.
But in most cases, if you're
going to develop a supplement
protocol, you want it to be
single-ingredient formulations
so that you can adjust the
dosages of different things
according to what works and
doesn't work for you, which
is essentially impossible
to do if you are using
multi-ingredient formulations.
If you'd like to see the
supplements that I take
and that we've discussed here
on the Huberman Lab podcast,
you can go to livemomentous--
spelled O-U-S--
so livemomentous.com/huberman
and get 20% off any
supplements.
Again, that's
livemomentous.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
Let's talk about fertility.
And in doing so, let's take
a step back from this word
"fertility" and ask, what is
fertility and fertilization
really all about?
Well, the obvious answer is that
it's about producing offspring.
But more importantly, it's
about producing offspring
that contain the genetic
components of both parents
and indeed contain half of
the genes from one parent
and half of the genes
from another parent.
Now, there are two general
types of cells in the body.
The most common types
of cells in the body
are called somatic cells.
So these would be all
the cells in your body
except the egg in females
and the sperm in males.
The egg in females
and the sperm males
are part of what's
called the germline.
And again, it has nothing
to do with infection.
It's just that the cells of the
germline have genes that cannot
be modified by the behavior
of the individual that houses
those genes.
What do I mean by that?
Well, if I were to tell you that
by exercising you can improve
mitochondrial function,
you can change hormones
by reducing stress,
you can reduce cortisol
by hitting puberty,
for instance, you
will have the secretion of
hormones that then change
gene expression in
other cells, leading
to the development of
body hair, facial hair,
deepening the voice,
breast growth, et cetera,
you'd say, OK, great.
Yeah, that all
makes perfect sense.
But that's all occurring in
the so-called somatic cells.
The germ cells or
the germline cells--
that is, the egg and the sperm--
are a very unique
and protected set
of cells that are generated
in a particular way
and whose genetic components are
not modifiable by experience.
And when you take a step
back and you think about it,
you say, oh, that's right.
There's no reason to
think that exercising
will make the children that
you have not yet had stronger.
And you say, of course not.
Well, why is that?
Well, that's because
there is a barrier
between the genes of the
germline cells and behaviors.
They cannot be modified by
behaviors and the various
things that you do
in your lifetime.
Now, I suppose
there's an exception
in the negative direction.
And what I'm referring to
here is if you were to, say,
be exposed to a chemical
that could mutate the DNA
of your egg or sperm or if you
were to fertilize an embryo
in a certain way or at a certain
stage of life that it got
an extra chromosome,
for instance--
we'll talk about this
a little bit later--
well, then, of course,
you could end up
with offspring
that have modified
DNA that don't faithfully
represent half of the genes
from mom and half of
the genes from dad.
But that's not the same
as specific behaviors
modifying the genes
of those cells--
the sperm and the egg cells--
in a way that improves
the offspring.
So the key first thing
to understand today
is that there's a distinction
between somatic cells, which
is the vast majority
of cells in your body,
and the so-called
germline cells, which
are the egg and the sperm.
The egg and the sperm are these
highly protected populations
of cells that, in
females, actually come
to be during embryogenesis.
So for all females
out there, you
generate what today I'm going
to refer to as a vault of cells.
You have a vault of eggs
that are your germline.
Those eggs all contain all
the chromosomes of your DNA.
So it's going to
be-- as most of you
know, there are 23 chromosomes,
and chromosomes exist in pairs.
So the way to think about this
is each pair is one strand,
and you have 22
so-called autosomes,
and then you have
one sex chromosome.
The sex chromosome will be
either X or Y. So in a female,
they have two X chromosomes.
So in each one of the
eggs that a woman has
and that she's had
since she was an embryo
and that's contained
in this vault,
those eggs are, of course, going
to be very immature at birth.
She hasn't undergone
puberty yet.
And certainly, as an embryo,
she hasn't undergone puberty.
And those cells are
going to contain
23 pairs of chromosomes.
This is very important--
The chromosomes are
essentially the wrapped-up DNA
that contains all the
genetic information
to create any cell
type in the body
and actually to create an
entirely new individual.
Now, there are 23 pairs of
chromosomes, 22 of which
are called autosomes.
If that doesn't
make sense to you,
just remember, autosome,
OK, there's 22 of them.
And then there's one
so-called sex chromosome.
The sex chromosomes are either
X or Y. But this is a female,
so she's going to have
23 pairs of chromosomes,
and she's going to have two
X chromosomes for the sex
chromosomes.
If this is already confusing
to you, don't worry,
I'll make it very clear how
this all relates to fertility
and how it relates to
chromosomal segregation
and a bunch of things that I
think maybe you've heard of
and that perhaps
were opaque to you.
But I promise to
make them clear.
But just understand that,
within each of those eggs,
they have 23 pairs
of chromosomes.
And for those of you
that like nomenclature,
I'll tell you that those
cells are considered diploid.
They're called the
diploid, and that
means that they have 23
pairs of chromosomes,
as distinguished
from cells that are
haploid where there's only one
set of those 23 chromosomes.
So instead of 23 pairs,
there's only 23 chromosomes.
We'll come back to haploid
cells a little bit later.
So when a female is born,
she has all these eggs
in the reserve, in
this vault, that she'll
have for her entire life.
She's not going
to make any more.
But they are very,
very immature.
So when a woman is
in embryogenesis,
she develops these
very immature eggs.
Today we're also going
to talk about follicles,
and we will be careful
to distinguish follicles
from eggs.
They're often talked about
interchangeably, online
and elsewhere and even by
fertility docs and OB/GYNs.
But right now we're just talking
about the egg cells, the eggs
themselves, which are cells.
Now, the goal of
fertilization is
to bring that egg cell
into close enough proximity
that it can be fertilized
by a single sperm cell.
And that sperm cell will
bring 23 chromosomes, as well,
that include--
just as in the female egg, it'll
have 22 autosomes and one sex
chromosome.
And in the male,
that sex chromosome
can either be an X chromosome,
which then would give rise
to female offspring, or a
Y chromosome, which would
give rise to male offspring.
And today we're not talking
about sexual differentiation.
That's a topic of a previous
and yet another future episode.
But just to give you a sense
of how X chromosomes and Y
chromosomes can
actually accomplish
that sexual differentiation,
both of body and brain.
I'll just mention in two
sentences that, for instance,
if there's a Y chromosome as
opposed to an X chromosome,
that Y chromosome contains genes
that suppress, for instance,
the development of
female genitalia
and thereby give rise
to male genitalia.
So rather than the
formation of a clitoris,
it's the formation of a penis.
And rather than the
formation of ovaries,
the formation of a testes.
So that's more directed
towards sexual differentiation.
We're not going to get
into that right now.
We'll get into that
in a future episode.
But even if you're
only tracking about 10%
of what I'm saying right now,
I promise you're doing great.
If you're tracking
more than 10%, well,
then you're doing
terrifically well,
because the essence of fertility
and fertilization is to bring
together that haploid cell that
is the sperm that only has 23
chromosomes-- but not
pairs of chromosomes
because that's
the DNA from dad--
together with the egg,
which, as I told you already,
has 23 pairs of chromosomes.
So part of the
fertilization process
has to be to get rid of
one half of those 23 pairs
in the female.
You got to get
rid of it, and you
have to get the egg and
the sperm in proximity
so that the egg can
potentially be fertilized
by the sperm bringing
the DNA, the 23
single strands of
chromosomes from dad,
into a cell that has 23
single strands from mom.
So I realize I'm probably being
a little bit repetitive here,
but I want everyone
to understand this
because it really frames up
fertility and reproduction
in the proper way.
We've got a cell from
mom, the egg, which
has 23 pairs of chromosomes.
We need to get rid of
one set of those pairs
so that there's
only 23 chromosomes.
We need to get rid of
half of those chromosomes.
And then we need to bring
that cell together physically
with the sperm cell
that contains the 23
chromosomal strands from dad.
And we need to bring
those together so that you
get 23 chromosomal
pairs from dad
and 23 chromosomal
pairs from mom.
And in doing so, you
create a cell, which
then becomes multiple cells.
That's going to be the
developing embryo that
has half the genes from mom
and half the genes from dad.
So I hope that's clear.
That is the biological
logic, which I realize
is a bit of a tongue twister.
But forgive me.
It is the most accurate way
to describe this process.
We're trying to bring
together the 23 single strands
of chromosomes
from dad and the 23
single strands of chromosomes
from mom into the same cell.
Now, that requires a
literal physical contact
and pairing of the two cells.
But as I mentioned before,
all these eggs in mom
are sitting in a vault, and
they're very, very immature.
So the ovulatory cycle
and the menstrual cycle
are really about
first eliminating
half of the chromosomal pairs
in that 23 sets of chromosomes
and not getting rid of,
for instance, half--
just going 1 to 11 or 12 to 23.
That's not the goal.
The goal is to have
chromosomes 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, all the way up to
23, but only to have
half of the chromosomes there
and to bring that cell together
with the sperm cell,
physically, then allow
them to fuse and allow
the chromosomes from dad
and the chromosomes from mom
to fuse within a single cell
and duplicate into cells that
contain half of the chromosomes
from dad and half of the
chromosomes from mom.
That's what the ovulatory
and menstrual cycle
are really all about.
So when thinking
about it that way,
I'd like to just initiate the
discussion by focusing first
on the female component,
or the egg component,
of fertility and fertilization.
As I mentioned before, a
female has all the eggs,
albeit very immature eggs, that
she's going to have at the time
that she's born.
Now, puberty will
happen at some point
and will allow the ovulatory
and the menstrual cycle
to commence.
Now, one question that
you perhaps are asking
is, what controls
the onset of puberty?
And there are a number
of different results,
each of which could
be an entire episode
of a podcast on its own.
But I'll just
highlight a few things
that we know about the onset
of menses or menstruation,
or it's sometimes also
called a menarche.
One thing that you'll notice
about today's discussion
is that if you were to take
any number of your notes
online and put them
into a search function
that you would see a lot
of different language used
for the same thing.
So for instance,
some people will
talk about the egg and the
follicle as the same thing,
even though they are not.
I'll explain the
difference soon.
Some people will talk about
menses or menstruation
or menarche as the
exact same thing.
And in fact, they are
not the exact same thing,
but oftentimes these words
are used interchangeably.
I'll do my best today to not
overload you with nomenclature
but rather to use the
most commonly used terms
for the different aspects of
fertility and fertilization.
But when it comes to
the onset of puberty,
first of all, most
of you have probably
heard that the
onset of puberty is
happening much
earlier in females now
than it was some years ago.
And in fact, that is the case.
And I'll talk about
some statistics related
to this which are
pretty striking
but don't necessarily point
to anything detrimental.
It doesn't necessarily mean
that something bad is happening.
What do we know for sure?
Well, we know that
there are a number
of signals that come
both through the brain
and through the body--
and more likely both-- in order
to control the onset of puberty
in females.
A couple of examples-- the
first is a mechanistic one.
We know, for instance,
that the entire process
of the ovulatory menstrual cycle
is initiated from the brain.
We're going to get
into this in a lot
more detail in a few minutes.
But there's a certain number of
hormones and neurotransmitters
that are communicated
from the brain,
a structure called
the hypothalamus,
which roughly sits above
the roof of your mouth,
and that communicates
with a gland, an endocrine
or hormone-releasing gland
called the pituitary gland.
The pituitary gland looks
like a stalk that essentially
extends out of the brain.
It's also located not far
from the roof of your mouth.
And that has two
sort of small marble
or grape-sized protrusions,
the anterior pituitary
and the posterior pituitary.
And they release different
hormones into the bloodstream.
Puberty is in part
controlled by the fact
that, up until
puberty, there are
neurons in the
hypothalamus that release
a neurotransmitter called
GABA, which is inhibitory,
and that prevents the
neurons in the hypothalamus
from releasing a very
important hormone called
gonadotropin-releasing
hormone, or GnRH.
So the first thing I'd
really like everyone
to know and commit to
memory today is very easy--
GnRH stands for
gonadotropin-releasing hormone.
This comes from
the brain and will
communicate to the pituitary
to release certain hormones.
Prior to puberty, in
both males and females,
there are neurons in the brain
that are actively suppressing
the neurons that release GnRH.
It's like no puberty,
no puberty, no puberty.
You can't have puberty.
And in fact, those cells are
releasing this neurotransmitter
called GABA because
it's inhibitory.
It prevents the firing
of those neurons.
So puberty is
actively suppressed up
until a certain point.
It's also actively suppressed,
at least in some species and we
think at least partially in
humans, by the tonic release--
that means the ongoing
release, around the clock--
of a hormone called melatonin.
Later in life-- in
fact, after puberty--
melatonin will be secreted only
in the dark phase of each night
and around the time
that one goes to sleep.
But in children
and in particular
in children prior to
puberty, melatonin
is released more
or less constantly.
Now, melatonin isn't
the only source
of suppression of puberty.
It's also these neural
mechanisms involving GABA.
But it is certainly a
great candidate for one
of the reasons why
puberty doesn't generally
tend to happen at,
say, age four age five.
That would be very unusual.
Another component of
suppression of puberty
is that typically in children
they have relatively low body
fat stores.
Why is this important?
Well, we know that one of
the things that can trigger
the onset of puberty-- in
particular in females--
is that when enough
body fat accumulates,
that body fat releases
a hormone called leptin,
and that hormone leptin
travels in the bloodstream,
across the blood-brain barrier,
and goes to the hypothalamus
and can trigger the
onset of puberty
by activating the
neurons that release
gonadotropin-releasing hormone.
So many people believe that
one of the reasons that puberty
is happening earlier
and earlier in females
is because of the accumulation
of more body fat at younger
ages than was observed 30 or
40 and certainly 100 years ago.
Now, I can already imagine a
number of people are thinking,
oh, this must relate
to the obesity crisis.
And indeed, there is
a crisis of obesity.
Obesity is something that is
causing all sorts of problems
with people's health at
various levels, brain and body,
and that is far
more frequent today
than it was even 20 years ago.
So it is indeed a
crisis because it
has enormous detrimental
effects for so many aspects
of brain and body
health and longevity.
But this whole process of
thinking about body fat
signaling leptin to the
hypothalamus and the onset
of puberty doesn't
necessarily have
to do with the obesity crisis.
It might relate, but it could
also relate to, for instance,
improved nutrition,
which is allowing body
fat stores to accumulate maybe
not to the level of obesity
but to accumulate earlier
and at younger ages
in females, which
is then causing
earlier puberty in females.
To just highlight how
that might be possible,
I want to review some data that
talk about the onset of menses,
menstruation--
that is, puberty--
in females according to
country and according
to age over the last
100 or more years.
So what are the
general trends in terms
of the onset of
puberty in females?
Well, that's an
easy one to answer.
Over the last 100 years or
so, the onset of puberty
has been occurring much earlier
with each passing decade.
It's really an incredible
set of statistics.
I will provide a
link to these data
since I know a number of
you are listening and not
just watching on YouTube.
This is from a study in
which the onset of puberty
has been analyzed from
as early as the 1850s--
in certain countries,
there are data on that--
out to the 1970s and
in other countries
starting at about 1900,
extending out to about 1990.
These are ongoing
collections of data.
But just to give you a sense
of how the data are falling out
in a couple of
different countries,
just to give you a flavor--
but for those of you listening
and for those of you watching,
the essence of all
of these findings
is that puberty is
happening much, much earlier
with each passing decade.
So for instance, in the United
States, around 1900 or 1903,
the average age of menarche,
the onset of puberty, in females
was about 14 years old, whereas
in 1990, the average age is 11.
So that's a pretty
significant, we can say,
acceleration of the
onset of puberty.
Now, of course,
these are averages.
So there will be exceptions.
There's a distribution of data.
Today, still, there will
be young females who
will undergo puberty at age
11 or 10 or maybe even 9
and others who will undergo
puberty at age 13, 14, maybe
even 16 or 17.
However, if we look
at, for instance,
the data from Norway, which
dates back quite far-- they
have excellent record-keeping--
to 1850, what we see
is that the average age of the
onset of female puberty in 1850
in Norway was 17 years
old, whereas in 1970, it's
13 years old.
So this is a
dramatic acceleration
of the onset of puberty.
And you see a similar trend
in other countries, as well.
So if we were to look,
for instance, in the UK,
they have a smaller data
set, meaning it only
extends back to about 1940.
But the average age of the onset
of puberty in the UK in 1940
was 13 and 1/2 years old.
Again, this is just for females.
And in 1970, it
was closer to 13,
with a trend towards
declining even further.
Unfortunately, they
didn't continue
to collect data out to 2022.
And as a final point, if we
were to look at, for instance,
in Germany and Finland,
the average onset
of puberty in 1870 was
16 and 1/2 years old.
By 1940, it was down to
13 and 1/2 years old.
So all of these data have
borne out over and over again,
regardless of location in the
world, which is important,
because when you start to
think about the obesity crisis,
you can say, well, that's
mainly in developed countries,
believe it or not-- or
perhaps not surprisingly.
And maybe it has to do
with the obesity crisis.
And yet I don't think we
can conclude that at all.
Something is happening, however.
It could be increased
body fat stores
due to overeating and obesity.
However, it could also
be-- unrelated to obesity,
it could be, for
instance, improved
nutrition and the availability
of quality nutrition, which
can signal the
maturation of the brain
and body mechanisms that
trigger the onset of puberty,
ovulatory cycle,
and menstruation.
So we want to be very careful
about leaping to conclusions
about what these trends mean,
but the trends themselves
are very, very apparent.
And as a final
point, I should also
mention that there are a
number of different behavioral
and psychosocial, as they're
called, interactions that
can influence puberty as well.
This has been most strikingly
observed in animals.
And so I don't want
anyone to be alarmed
or to leap to any great
conclusions about the onset
of timing of puberty in
humans, but I'd be remiss
if I didn't tell you about
a certain result which
shows that if a young female
is exposed to the odor--
not necessarily the pheromones.
There's a distinction between
odors that we perceive
and pheromones, which
are subconscious.
We don't actively perceive, but
that can impact our biology,
and pheromones effects in
humans are very controversial.
But we know, for instance, that
if you take a female animal--
and there's some
evidence from humans
that if you take a
young prepubertal female
and you expose her to the scent
of a reproductively-competent
male for a series of days,
but maybe even as short
as a few hours,
and she is also not
regularly being exposed to
the scent of her father,
that she can undergo
puberty earlier.
That's right.
There is something
about the odor
and/or pheromones, or
perhaps something else, that
occurs when a young prepubertal
female has a father that she's
in regular contact with.
He wouldn't necessarily have
to live at home but that
is around a lot that
his smell is registered
by her biological systems.
That-- I don't want
to say protects
because it kind of skews the
valence of the conversation,
but that offsets or buffers
the otherwise observed effect,
which is that the scent of a
reproductively-competent male,
if it's present often enough
or perhaps intensely enough,
that it can trigger the onset
of puberty in that female.
In other words, the scent of
a male that is not the father
and we think also that is not
biologically related to her
can trigger earlier
onset of puberty.
And that effect can at
least be partially buffered
by her being in the
presence of the scent
from her biological father.
Now, some of you are
probably already leaping
to conclusions about
what this means.
Should you not
allow your daughter
to be exposed to
any males who are
of reproductive age, et cetera?
That's certainly
not what I'm saying.
There's a huge number
of considerations
that go into that
calculation for everybody
and circumstances, et cetera.
But the point is that the odors
of individuals, both related--
in particular, closely related--
and non-related individuals,
can shape the neural systems
and the hormone systems that
can trigger the onset
of puberty or suppress
the onset of puberty.
So whether or not we're
talking about onset
of puberty at this
age or that age
and whether or not
biologically-related male
or non-biologically-related
male scents around,
et cetera, the thing I
want everyone to know
is that at some point
during development,
typically nowadays between
the ages of 11 and 15
or so-- again, there's
variability there.
The suppression of
gonadotropin-releasing hormone
released from the
hypothalamus is removed,
and then
gonadotropin-releasing hormone
can activate cells
within the pituitary.
And if you really
want to know, it's
the anterior pituitary
in particular.
And then the anterior
pituitary gland,
which sits at and kind of
bridges the brain and the body
because it allows the release of
hormones into the bloodstream,
that anterior pituitary
is going to release
two key hormones that everyone
should know the name of
and what they do.
And when I say everyone,
I mean males and females
need to know about
these hormones
because they have an active
role in both males and females.
And of course, you
should want to know
and should know about
the biology of everyone
on the planet, in my
opinion, because it tells you
a lot more about
humans than if you just
focus on your own biology.
But those two
hormones are called
luteinizing hormone,
which is abbreviated LH,
and follicle-stimulating
hormone, which
is abbreviated FSH.
So the simple picture that
you need to have in your mind
is gonadotropin-releasing
hormone from the brain,
from the hypothalamus
in particular,
is causing the
release of luteinizing
hormone and follicle-stimulating
hormone, GnRH stimulates
LH, luteinizing hormone, and
follicle-stimulating hormone,
FSH.
LH and FSH travel in the blood
and can access all the cells
and tissues of the body.
This is one of the incredible
things about hormones is that
many hormones-- and LH and FSH
are included in this group--
can travel into cells,
and they can actually
change the genetic
expression of those cells.
They can change which
genes are turned on
and which genes are turned off.
And they can also attach to
the surface of those cells
and make those cells take
on different properties.
So they can mature those cells.
So for instance, a good
example of this outside
of the context we've
been talking about
is the hormone testosterone
can travel to the hair follicle
and can stimulate changes in the
genes of the cells of the hair
follicle that can
make hair grow.
A different hormone,
estrogen, can
travel to the cells
of the breast tissue
and activate genes that control
enlargement of the cells
of the breast tissue.
Prolactin, a different hormone,
can travel to the mammary ducts
and control the production
and the secretion of milk.
And in males, that can actually
happen, in certain cases,
although it's rare.
But prolactin can also
travel to areas of the brain
that control libido,
for instance.
And just so you'll
never forget it,
males' elevated
levels of prolactin
are actually what set
the refractory period
after ejaculation
and prevent erection
for some period of time.
So you'll never
forget prolactin.
The point being that
different hormones
have different effects
on different cells,
depending on what
cells those are.
Estrogen or estradiol is going
to have different effects
on the breast tissue
than it would on skin,
although as effects on both.
Similarly, when LH and
FSH, luteinizing hormone
and follicle-stimulating
hormone, travel in the blood
to the gonad and the
gonad is an ovary,
it will have a certain
set of consequences.
And when luteinizing hormone
and follicle-stimulating hormone
travel in the blood to
a gonad and that gonad
happens to be a teste, then
it will have a different set
of biological implications.
So let's focus now
on what happens when
LH and FSH arrive at the ovary.
And let's assume now that we're
talking about a female who
has already undergone
puberty, or perhaps we
could even frame this in
the context of a female who
is about to undergo puberty.
FSH and LH are now able to
be released because she's
undergoing puberty.
But the same set of
processes, essentially,
would occur for any point from
puberty onward until menopause,
which is the depletion of that
vault, that ovarian reserve
of all those immature eggs.
I'd like to take a brief
break and acknowledge
our sponsor, Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens is an all-in-one
vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that also contains
digestive enzymes
and adaptogens.
I started taking Athletic
Greens way back in 2012,
so that's 10 years
now of taking Athletic
Greens every single day.
So I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring this podcast.
The reason I started taking
Athletic Greens and the reason
I still take Athletic
Greens is that it
covers all of my foundational
nutritional needs.
So whether or not
I'm eating well
or enough or not, I'm sure that
I'm covering all of my needs
for vitamins,
minerals, probiotics,
adaptogens to combat stress,
and the digestive enzymes really
help my digestion.
I just feel much better when
I'm drinking Athletic Greens.
If you'd like to
try Athletic Greens,
you can go to
athleticgreens.com/huberman,
and for the month of January,
they have a special offer where
they'll give you 10 free
travel packs plus a year supply
of vitamin D3/K2.
Vitamin D3 and K2 are
vital for immune function,
metabolic function,
hormone health,
but also calcium regulation
and heart health.
Again, that's
athleticgreens.com/huberman
to claim their special offer in
the month of January of 10 free
travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3/K2.
OK, so we're now going
to talk about ovulation
and menstruation, and
let's just remember
what this is all about.
This is all about creating
the potential for an egg
to be fertilized,
and that egg needs
to have half of the
chromosomal pairs, so no pairs,
but it's got to have 23
chromosomes just from mom.
And we need to
position that egg so
that the egg can
be met by the sperm
and that sperm can
penetrate that egg
and donate its 23 individual
strands of chromosomes
to that egg so that you can
bring together the DNA of dad
and the DNA of mom.
So the obligatory
menstrual cycle
occurs when luteinizing hormone
and follicle-stimulating
hormone have been released.
And the
ovulatory/menstrual cycle--
and here I have to kind of
pick what I want to call it.
I guess to be really accurate,
we would just call it
the female reproductive cycle,
but that includes underneath it
both the menstrual cycle,
as it's sometimes called,
and the ovulatory cycle.
So you decide.
I'm going to interchangeably
discuss the ovulatory cycle
and the menstrual cycle.
The problem is, when
you say menstruation,
people often think about
just the period, the shedding
of the uterine lining when
fertilization has not occurred.
So if I start saying
ovulatory cycle,
just keep in mind I'm
referring to the entire thing.
Now, this is probably
also a good opportunity
to say that if you heard that
the ovulatory/menstrual cycle
is 28 days long, that's
true in some cases,
but that's not always true.
It's, on average, 28 days long.
There are some females for which
the ovulatory cycle will be
shorter-- it can be
as short as 21 days--
and other females for which
it will be 35 days long.
Shorter than 21 days
and longer than 35
days is rare, although
it does occur.
One of the key things when
thinking about fertility
is if you talk to OB/GYNs who
are focused on fertility, which
I have in anticipation
of this episode,
they'll tell you
that whether or not
your cycle is 21 days
long or 35 days long
is not as much of an issue
necessarily unless it's
happening to become much
shorter or much longer
in a kind of erratic way.
So if you're somebody
who's consistently
had 23 day long cycles
and all of a sudden
you're having 30 day long
cycles, that's not necessarily
an indication of anything bad.
But if it's 21 days one month
and it's 30 days the next month
and it's 17 days the next
month or even if it's always
falling within that 21
to 35 day long cycle
but it's very variable from
each month or every other month
or so, you probably want
to talk to your OB/GYN
because that could indicate
a number of different things.
Which things could it indicate?
Well, that will become
clear as I spell out
the biology in a
bit more detail.
But this idea that the
menstrual cycle/ovulatory cycle
is always 28 days,
that's just false.
That's just not true.
I should also mention that there
is a common misconception that
because the average menstrual
cycle is 28 days-- indeed,
the average is 28 days--
and the lunar cycle is 28 days--
and of course, there
is a real biology
to support the
fact that the lunar
cycle can't, in fact,
impact certain aspects
of human behavior.
It does, and we'll
talk about lunar cycles
in a future episode.
But there is zero data
to support the idea
that the menstrual cycle
and the lunar cycle
are linked in any
kind of causal way.
Sorry to break it to you.
The lunar cycle and the
tidal cycles at the ocean
are definitely linked in ways
that are super interesting
related to the tilt of the
Earth and the pull of gravity
of different planets, and
it's an incredible story
into itself.
But the lunar cycle and
the menstrual cycle,
despite having some weak
correlation in terms
of their duration or their
so-called periodicity--
no pun intended--
well, there's no causal
relationship whatsoever
between the lunar cycle
and the menstrual cycle.
If any of you are
aware of any real data
that conflicts with
what I just said,
please put that in the
comment section on YouTube.
But this is pretty well
established as far as I know.
OK, so we need to bring together
the so-called haploid contents,
the 23 individual strands
of chromosomes from the egg,
to a place and a position
where it could potentially
be fertilized by the male.
So what happens?
Luteinizing hormone and
follicle-stimulating hormone
travel to the ovary.
These hormones are able
to access the ovary.
There's a lot of blood
supply to the ovary.
And FSH and LH
arrive at the ovary.
The ovary has this vault,
this ovarian reserve
of immature cells.
They reside within what
are called follicles.
The follicles are little
spherical packages
that can potentially provide a
nice environment for those eggs
to mature.
And when FSH, in particular,
arrives at the ovary,
a small number of
those follicles
will split off from the reserve,
they will exit the vault,
and they will
undergo maturation.
And the key player here is
follicle-stimulating hormone.
And the first 14 days of the
menstrual/ovulatory cycle
is referred to as the
follicular phase because
of this relationship between
FSH triggering the maturation
of a subset of follicles.
Now, typically in the
context of a 28 day or so
ovulatory/menstrual
cycle, day one
is designated as the
first day of the period,
of the shedding of
the uterine lining
from the previous ovulatory
menstrual cycle in which
fertilization did not occur.
So day one is when
the period initiates.
It is days 1 through
14, approximately--
because here we're
just considering
the average of a 28-day
cycle, but it could be longer.
It could be shorter.
But the first half of that cycle
is the so-called follicular
phase, FSH, has
triggered the departure
of a subset of these follicles
that contain immature eggs.
And it is triggering the
maturation of those eggs.
Luteinizing hormone is
also present, but also
at relatively low levels.
And it's during the first half
of this ovulatory menstrual
cycle that the main goal is to
get those follicles to mature.
So inside of those follicles,
the egg is developing.
It's growing.
It's maturing.
And in doing so, it's also
making its own hormones.
This, I think, is one of
the most elegant aspects
of the ovulatory menstrual
cycle that, in a few minutes,
you'll learn about something
which still to this day,
even though I've known about
this stuff for decades now
because of my training, still
just blows my mind that you
have one hormone,
follicle-stimulating hormone,
triggering the
maturation of some eggs
inside of some follicles and
then those follicles themselves
making another hormone
that furthers the process
and then soon, as you'll learn,
create a hormone to trigger
the second half of the process.
Just a beautiful symphony of
expression of different genes
and different hormones
to make everything
work as optimally as possible.
So as these different
follicles mature, somehow--
and we still don't
know exactly how--
one of those follicles
containing an egg
gets selected.
It's either because
it matures the fastest
or there's something
about it that
is still not
completely understood
that allows it to be selected.
And all the other
follicles that are maturing
degenerate and die.
And they're gone.
They don't go back into
the ovarian reserve.
They are now depleted
from that bank account
that is the ovarian reserve.
They die off.
But that single egg
that, keep in mind,
contains 23 pairs
of chromosomes--
we haven't gotten rid
of one half of those 23
sets of chromosomes yet.
But that one will
continue to mature.
And then, at some
point, that egg
will start to undergo a process
in which those chromosomes are
pulled apart by
little components
within the egg called spindles.
They literally have
a physical pulling
of the chromosomes apart.
So now those 23 pairs are no
longer attached to one another
at the middle like
they were before,
like two beads of strings--
or I should say,
23 short strands
of beads that were at once
connected to one another
now are pulled apart
so that you have
23 chromosomes on
each side, but they're
pulled apart from one another.
So that diploid
cell is now starting
to become a cell in which
half of the chromosomes,
half of those 23
pairs, are physically
pulled away from the others.
And then the egg actually
starts to form its own
what we call an
involution of membrane
around those 23 pairs, one set
of them, and encapsulates them.
So you sort of got
an egg with two parts
where the two sets
of chromosomes,
two sets of 23 chromosomes,
are now separate
from one another
inside of the egg.
And then one of those actually
gets ejected from the egg,
and the name of that
thing that gets ejected--
it's sort of like a little
Hubble pod is how I imagine it,
you know, from Star Wars or from
any kind of Space Odyssey movie
where some thing
is ready to happen.
A little Hubble pod
shoots out of the ship.
Well, that 23 pairs is
now ejected from the egg.
It's called the polar body.
And that's going to degenerate.
It's going to go away.
And in doing so, take the
egg cell, which was once
diploid-- it had 23 pairs
of chromosomes-- and making
it haploid.
And now what you've got,
in ideal circumstances,
is a beautifully pristine
egg that was selected for
and has 23 single strands
of chromosomes, 22 autosomes
and one sex chromosome.
And that sex chromosome is
going to be an X chromosome
almost with certainty,
because female--
mother-- is creating that egg.
So then the egg that contains
just the appropriate 23
single-stranded
chromosomes is going
to fuse with the wall of
the ovary, and that egg
will be released and will
travel into the Fallopian tube.
Now, we'll get back to
that egg in a few moments.
But that process, which
represents the first half
of the ovulatory
menstrual cycle, again,
was triggered by FSH and to
some extent luteinizing hormone.
But it is the ongoing maturation
of that egg which also causes
the production of estrogen,
which allows that whole process
to occur.
And you could say, why?
Well, the answer to the
why is a very important
biological principle
that we are going
to return to in a number of
different contexts today,
both as reference to
female and male fertility.
And the principle is a
so-called negative feedback.
So when estrogen is present
at relatively low levels
in females in the
ovary, as it is
during the development of these
eggs, some of that estrogen,
of course, is going
to exit the ovary.
It's going to go
into the bloodstream.
And it's going to travel
back to the pituitary.
Now, the pituitary
can release things
like follicle-stimulating
hormone and luteinizing
hormone.
But the way I'd
like you to think
about the pituitary for
sake of feedback loops
is that it's sort of
like a thermometer
that you would put into a pool,
like a backyard pool, that
is attached to the heater.
And for instance, if you were
to put a thermometer into a pool
that you would like
to keep at 70 degrees
and the temperature of
that pool is 60 degrees,
well, then that
thermometer ought
to trigger some
sort of mechanism
where the pool would heat
up until the temperature
of the pool hit 70
degrees, and then it
should trigger that thermometer
to turn off the heating system.
That's kind of a
negative feedback
system that would keep
the temperature more
or less correct.
That's a lot of the way that
the system's related to estrogen
and also testosterone and
these different things
like luteinizing hormone and
follicle-stimulating hormone
work as well.
Typically, when the level
of a hormone is too high,
then it shuts down
the production
of the hormones that would
trigger further production
of that hormone.
I know that's a mouthful.
It's a lot to think about.
And some of you are
probably thinking, whoa,
I'm getting dizzy
now with biology.
But I promise you, you
can understand this.
In females, when estrogen
is relatively low--
but not zero but
is relatively low
during that first follicular
half of the ovulatory cycle--
it actually triggers negative
feedback on LH and FSH
so that not too
much is produced.
But then just
prior to ovulation,
the levels of estrogen and the
levels of some other hormones
from those eggs--
you have the eggs producing
estrogen themselves--
gets high enough
that it actually
triggers a positive feedback
loop on the pituitary.
So the pituitary is
essentially observing
the amount of estrogen in
the bloodstream produced
by the ovary, and the
amount of estrogen
towards the end of the second
half of the menstrual cycle
has increased and triggers
a positive feedback loop.
It triggers the pituitary
to release more FSH and LH,
and that helps trigger
ovulation, that deployment
or the release of that
one mature proper selected
egg that's haploid with the 23
individual pairs of chromosomes
into the Fallopian tube.
So let's just back up
really quickly and just
kind of summarize
what's happened.
Gonadotropin-releasing
hormone from the hypothalamus
triggers the release of
follicle-stimulating hormone
and luteinizing hormone.
That travels to the
ovary-- triggers
the release of a subset
of immature follicles
with immature eggs.
Those immature follicles
and immature eggs
start to mature,
start to grow because
of the presence of
follicle-stimulating hormone.
The growth of those eggs
themselves increases estrogen.
As the estrogen starts to
accumulate in the environment,
some of that travels
back to the pituitary.
And when levels of estrogen
arriving at the pituitary
are relatively
low, the pituitary
says, oh, we don't
need to release
any more follicle-stimulating
and luteinizing hormone.
However, at some point
just prior to ovulation,
enough estrogen has been
produced by that one
single selected
mature egg and some
of the other follicles around
it that were maturing but then
since died off that the estrogen
triggers a positive feedback
loop.
The pituitary says,
OK, and releases
more follicle-stimulating
hormone
and luteinizing hormone.
And bam, the egg, which has
the proper genetic components,
sets off out of the ovary
and into the Fallopian tube.
So-called ovulation has begun.
That itself, what
I just described,
constitutes the first half of
the ovulatory/menstrual cycle,
which we call the
follicular phase.
And it's marked by the presence
of FSH and some other things,
but we can really think
about it as marked by FSH
from the pituitary and by
estrogen, or estradiol, made
within the ovary.
Then comes the second half of
the ovulatory/menstrual cycle,
which I personally think is
one of the coolest mechanisms
in all of biology,
which is that--
remember the
follicle that housed
that one egg that
was the selected
egg that became the mature egg?
And that follicle, which
no longer contains the egg
because the egg took
off and ovulated,
is called the corpus luteum.
And the corpus luteum starts
making three hormones, which
include estradiol, I
think called inhibin,
but the most important hormone,
the one that you really
need to know about,
is that it starts
producing very high
levels of progesterone.
Progesterone levels
start to increase
about the time of
ovulation, although just
prior to ovulation.
And over the next second
half of the ovulatory cycle--
so about 14 days if
it's a 28-day cycle,
a little bit longer or
a little bit shorter,
depending on the
length of cycle.
Levels of progesterone
in the second half
of the ovulatory cycle are
going to increase by 1,400 fold
compared to what they
were in the first half
of the ovulatory cycle.
So again, if we
were to characterize
the menstrual/ovulatory cycle
in broad strokes, what we would
say is that FSH
and estrogen mark
the initial part the first half,
the so-called follicular phase,
and that the estrogen and
FSH set in motion ovulation,
and they prime the
system for the production
of a corpus luteum, which
produces progesterone.
And the second
half of all of this
is called the luteal phase.
The second half of the
ovulatory/menstrual cycle
is the luteal phase
because of corpus luteum,
this otherwise discarded tissue
that produces progesterone.
What does progesterone do?
Well, progesterone impacts
the uterine lining,
so-called endometrium
or the lining,
the mucous lining of the uterus
where that egg that's ovulated
is potentially going to
implant if it's fertilized.
And so in a kind of
perfect way-- or I
should say, in a
seemingly perfect way--
the egg is off on its way.
It might get fertilized.
The remnants of the compartment
that let go of that egg
produce a hormone that then
prepares the endometrial lining
of the uterus for the potential
implantation of that egg.
It's basically making the
bed for the fertilized egg
to potentially embed in,
to implant in, and then
achieve all the nourishment that
it needs to grow, eventually,
into a healthy embryo and child.
Just an amazing set of
biological mechanisms,
if you ask me, because
what you're observing here
is an incredible
economy of function
whereby the same
cellular components that
are producing the egg,
well, some of them
are being discarded,
but they're not being
discarded without purpose.
They're being
discarded in a way that
triggers the onset of
hormonal expression
that then prepares
the fertilized
egg to be in an enriched
environment in which it
can thrive.
Now, I realize that
was a lot of detail.
But we have a couple
of key themes.
We've got the
hypothalamus, GnRH.
We've got the pituitary
with LH and FSH,
and those hormones
travel to the ovary.
The ovary has eggs in a
vault, basically immature eggs
in a vault. Some of those
are activated by the presence
of FSH and LH each month.
And one of those eggs will
be selected and will ovulate.
The remnants of the
follicle and egg
that are not selected, the
chromosomes that you don't need
disappear in the polar body.
And the corpus luteum gives
rise to progesterone and sets
in motion the second half of
the ovulatory menstrual cycle,
which is the luteal phase,
which is essentially
the potential for
that fertilized egg
to embed in a nice,
nourishing environment.
And of course, we
should all be thinking,
if the egg is fertilized
and then it lays down
in the nice, comfy
uterine lining
that's been prepared
by progesterone
in the corpus luteum, well,
then everything's fine and good.
But what if fertilization
doesn't occur?
Well, we all know what happens
if fertilization doesn't occur.
If fertilization does not
occur for whatever reason,
that uterine lining
is going to shed.
And that's actually what's
referred to as the period.
It's the actual removal--
or the departure, rather--
of the thickened
endometrium lining
of the uterus when
fertilization has not occurred.
And of course, if
that happens, we
need another ovulatory
menstrual cycle.
So how does that happen?
Well, the hormone inhibin is
also made by the corpus luteum
and doesn't go quite as high
as the hormone progesterone.
But it kind of tracks that
increase in progesterone
that occurs in the second
half of the ovulatory cycle.
But then, if fertilization
does not occur,
inhibin levels start to drop.
And what I haven't told
you is what inhibin does.
Inhibin, in concert with
other hormones like estrogen,
feed back to the hypothalamus
and prevent the further release
of follicle-stimulating hormone
and luteinizing hormone.
If you have an egg that gets
fertilized and can implant,
well, then you don't
want more eggs to mature.
You want to hold on to
the ones in the vault.
You don't want them to mature.
And hormones like
inhibin and, again,
working with other
hormones are going
to prevent the secretion
of things like FSH and LH.
Now, typically, people are not
getting pregnant every month.
In fact, that's not possible.
And part of the reason
it's not possible
is that if the
fertilized egg implants,
there are a number of
different hormone cascades
that shut down the production
of things like GnRH, FSH, and LH
in ways that prevent further
maturation of follicles
and a follicular phase.
But in the instance where
fertilization doesn't occur
and menstruation occurs--
and I should mention that
the duration of menstruation,
the actual bleeding,
typically is anywhere from one
to five days.
The, quote, unquote,
"heaviness,"
the lightness or heaviness of
that bleeding will depend on--
you guessed it-- the amount of
progesterone that is secreted
from the corpus luteum.
That's one of the
key players there.
And if menstruation occurs,
well, then inhibin levels
also drop.
Progesterone levels also drop.
And when that occurs,
there's a positive feedback
signal up at the level
of the pituitary.
The pituitary
literally can register
how much inhibin and
progesterone and estrogen
is present in the bloodstream.
And if those levels are
sufficiently low, well,
then GnRH gets secreted again,
FSH gets secreted again,
and LH gets secreted again.
And the first half
the follicular phase
of the menstrual cycle
initiates all over again.
It's hard to overstate how
beautifully orchestrated
this entire system is--
The number of feedback loops
and feed-forward loops.
I think if you can just
generally understand
that the first half of the
menstrual/ovulatory cycle
is marked by the maturation
of the follicles and FSH
and that the second
half is marked
by the accumulation
of progesterone
and the thickening
of the uterine lining
should fertilization
and implantation occur,
I think that you will
certainly understand
the female reproductive
cycle better than most people
out there.
It will also help you
understand a number of things
that are sometimes associated
with the female reproductive
cycle.
For instance, there
are data showing
that, in many, not all, but
in many women, in the four
to five days prior to
ovulation, there is
a dramatic increase in libido.
That dramatic
increase in libido is
triggered by a number of
things, but some of those things
include the spike
in FSH that occurs,
the spike in LH that occurs,
and some associated increases
in androgens, things like
DHEA and testosterone,
which, just as in males
can be related to libido,
in females trigger libido.
You can imagine why this would
be an effective mechanism
to have in place in females if
the goal, as it were, certainly
of the egg, perhaps not
of the woman as a whole,
but if the goal is to
fertilize the egg--
so increases in
libido just prior
to the onset of ovulation.
There's also been a lot
of discussion and interest
and, frankly, data
exploring the malaise
that it can occur
at certain portions
of the menstrual cycle.
And there's a lot of
misconception about this.
A lot of people have focused
on the malaise that can occur
around the time of bleeding.
But there are
actually stronger data
to support the fact that some,
again, some, not all women
experience a kind of
malaise sometimes associated
with anxiety, sometimes not,
that's associated with the mid
to second half of
the luteal phase
of the
ovulatory/menstrual cycle.
And that, despite what
people commonly think,
is not associated with
elevated levels of estrogen.
It's actually associated with
the depletion in estrogen
levels that can occur
during certain portions
of that second half
of the luteal phase
of the menstrual cycle.
So again, this is
highly variable.
For some people, they
might not experience
any malaise at any point
during their menstrual cycle.
Other individuals
also, for instance,
might not experience any
variation in their libido
at any point during
their menstrual cycle.
Again, highly
variable, and yet there
are some statistically
significant trends
that have been
observed that tracked
very specific
hormonal components
within the menstrual cycle.
Again, this will all
be very contextual.
And of course, this can play out
in a number of different ways.
So for instance, some women
experience very heightened
levels of sensitivity
to caffeine
at certain portions of
their menstrual cycle.
Other women experience
more cramping than others
at different portions of
their menstrual cycle.
Tremendous variation from
individual to individual.
One of the--
I view it as an advantage.
But one of the things that
many females can really do
and experience because they have
cycles that occur every month
that are fairly dramatic
in terms of their levels
of hormones-- so for instance,
a more than 1,000-fold increase
in progesterone during the
luteal phase of the menstrual
cycle and, I should
also mention,
a 200-fold increase in estrogen
during the period just prior
to ovulation.
That's why they always say
estrogen primes progesterone.
That's what you learn in
kind of basic endocrinology
when you're learning
the menstrual cycle.
Estrogen in the first half
of the menstrual cycle
primes progesterone
in the second half
of the
ovulatory/menstrual cycle.
Well, those estrogen increases
just prior to ovulation
are in part responsible for
the increases in libido.
But it's also the presence of
increased androgen just prior
to ovulation.
So there's a lot of
complex interplay.
I think what we will
do is we will reserve
the discussion about
libido, per se,
and some of the
other aspects related
to sexual
differentiation that we
were talking about earlier
for a future episode.
But hopefully now
you have in mind
what the ovulatory/menstrual
cycle is.
It is a signal from the
brain, from the hypothalamus,
which then triggers a
signal from the pituitary,
an endocrine gland, which then
signals the release of hormones
that travel to the
ovary and that control
two things, maturation of eggs
and the identification of one
egg in particular and then
preparation of the milieu,
the environment in which
that fertilized egg could
potentially land and mature
into a healthy embryo and child.
So if you have that
framed up in your mind
and even if you just
extracted maybe 10% to 15%
of the hormones and
different aspects
that I described up until now,
I would consider you far more
knowledgeable about this entire
process than 99% of people
out there, certainly not
the OB/GYNs and urologists,
but the 99% of
individuals out there.
It also frames up for
us the second half
of this whole story about
fertility and fertilization,
which is the generation of sperm
and how the sperm eventually
arrive at the egg and how
certain sperm are selected
to potentially
fertilize that egg,
whereas others never
really stand a chance.
So next we're going
to talk about sperm.
We're going to talk
about what sperm are,
where they are generated,
and how they are generated,
and how they need to
travel both within the male
and within the female in
order to allow fertilization
to potentially occur.
I'd like to take a
brief break and thank
our sponsor, InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA
to help you better
understand your body
and help you reach
your health goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done
for the simple reason that
many of the factors that impact
your immediate and
long-term health
can only be analyzed from
a quality blood test.
The problem with a
lot of blood and DNA
tests out there, however,
is that you get data
back about metabolic
factors, lipids, and hormones
and so forth, but you don't
know what to do with those data.
InsideTracker
solves that problem
and makes it very easy
for you to understand
what sorts of nutritional,
behavioral, maybe even
supplementation-based
interventions
you might want to
take on in order
to adjust the numbers of those
metabolic factors, hormones,
lipids, and other
things that impact
your immediate and
long-term health to bring
those numbers into the
ranges that are appropriate
and indeed optimal for you.
If you'd like to
try InsideTracker,
you can visit
insidetracker.com/huberman
and get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans.
That's
insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
So we've covered the
ovulatory cycle in females.
And I confess, it was
a lot of information
with a lot of
biological nomenclature.
But I promise you that
many of those same themes
and indeed the same
names and nomenclature
will show up in the
discussion that we're
going to have now, which is
about the generation of sperm.
Now, sperm are similar
to eggs in the sense
that they are part
of the germline.
They are these protected
cells, protected in the sense
that the activities
of an individual
are not going to change the
genetic makeup of those cells.
Now, again, there are
instances in which
mutagens, such as
chemicals, could disrupt
the genomes of the germ
cells in males, just
as it could in females.
But in general, the
activities, the things
that we do, the
experiences we have,
doesn't tend to change
the genome of those cells.
However, there are a lot
of lifestyle factors--
dos and don'ts, nutrition and
supplements and prescription
drugs, et cetera-- that can
indeed modify the quality
of the sperm.
And we'll talk about
what sperm quality means.
But the point is that the sperm
cell, much like the egg cell,
are both germline cells.
They are not like somatic cells.
They are unique populations.
And let's just remember what
the job of the sperm cell is.
The job of the sperm cell is
to deliver the genetic material
from the father and to do that
in the form of a haploid cell.
So that means 23
chromosomes, 22 autosomes,
one so-called sex chromosome--
again, not sex the verb,
at least not in this case.
Sex, the verb, is
a discussion we're
going to have in a few
minutes, but sex the noun.
The sex chromosome can either
be an X chromosome or a Y
chromosome.
So 22 autosomes and
then one sex chromosome
is going to be contained
within the sperm
because it's a haploid
cell, not a diploid cell.
Remember, the egg was diploid,
then it became haploid.
The sperm cells
are cells that are
created through the
division of other cells.
But after that division occurs
through a process called
meiosis, the sperm cell is
going to contain 23 chromosomes,
consisting of 22 autosomes
and one sex chromosome.
And the sperm that manages
to deposit its DNA contents
into the egg, to
fertilize the egg,
will either have an X
sex chromosome or a Y sex
chromosome.
And the Y sex
chromosome has a number
of different genes on
that chromosome that
will suppress, for
instance, the development
of the female reproductive axis.
One good example would be the
Müllerian-inhibiting hormone,
or MIH.
The gene for
Müllerian-inhibiting hormone,
which is a hormone that prevents
the formation of the Müllerian
ducts, which is part of the
female reproductive structure,
well, that gene controls the
prevention of the development
of the female genitalia
and in doing so promotes
the development of
the male genitalia.
And there are other
examples of genes
that are on the Y
chromosome that give you
a what we call male phenotype.
You have genotype and phenotype.
By the way, in case you
haven't heard this in a while
from your high school biology--
or if you never heard
it, no big deal--
karyotype is the
complement of chromosome--
XX or XY.
And there are
individuals out there
that are XXY or XYY, a
discussion for our episode
on sex differentiation.
That's karyotype with a K.
Then there's genotype, which
are the genes that you have.
And then there's phenotype,
spelled P-H-E-N-O-T-Y-P-E,
phenotype.
And the phenotype
is how the genes,
which then code for RNA,
which code for protein,
how those are expressed in
terms of things like eye color.
So eye color is a phenotype.
Height is a phenotype.
Hair color is a phenotype.
So you have karyotype,
genotype, and phenotype.
Well, what we need to do is
we need to bring together
that sperm, which is
haploidd it contains those 23
chromosomal strandes--
with either an X or
a Y. Sex chromosome
is the 23rd chromosome.
We need to get that
cell to the egg.
And so when we talk about
spermatogenesis, of course,
we are talking about the
generation of sperm cells.
But what we're really talking
about is the generation
of cells whose job is to deliver
the genetic material from dad
to the egg within the female
in a way that increases
the probability that not only
will that egg be fertilized
but that it will progress in
a healthy way with each set
of chromosomes from
mom and from dad--
each set of 23
chromosomes, that is--
will progress in a healthy way,
will implant in a healthy way,
and will maintain and grow in a
healthy way to a healthy embryo
and child and eventually adult.
That's the job of the sperm.
So as we talk about
spermatogenesis,
let's just remember that
and why they're there
in the first place.
Now, a few things about
sperm that are interesting,
besides the fact
that they're haploid
and besides the fact that,
as you all know, they swim.
They have a head and a tail.
They actually have a head,
a mid region, and a tail,
and that mid region turns
out to be very important.
It's something we'll come
back to again and again.
That mid region is really
key for the ability for sperm
to engage in forward
progression to swim forward.
It involves the activity
of mitochondria,
which are involved in
generation of ATP, which
is involved in all aspects
of energy and all cells.
But let's just remember that
the sperm are swimming cells.
And in order to create
a really good swimmer
or set of swimmers, you
need a couple of things.
First of all, within the testes
is where the sperm develop.
And unlike in females
and unlike in the ovary,
there's no vault of sperm.
The sperm are continually
being generated.
It takes about 60
days for sperm to be
born from their parent cells--
because cells actually
give rise to other cells,
that's the it works-- to be
born from their parent cells
and then matured to
the point where they
can be a really good swimmer.
Now, that doesn't mean
that a bunch of sperm
are made on day one, and then
60 days later, all those sperm
are deployed in the
form of ejaculate,
and then the cycle
starts over again.
So it's a little different than
the ovulatory menstrual cycle.
Rather, at any given point
in time-- like right now,
if you have testes, you have
some sperm in your testes that
are immature and cannot swim,
cannot deliver those contents
to--
those genetic contents,
rather-- to the female egg.
And you have some
sperm that are mature,
and you very likely have
some sperm that are so mature
that they are dying off
or that they're dead.
Almost certainly, also,
regardless of your age,
you have some sperm that are
healthier than others, that are
better swimmers than others.
This is just the way
the system works.
Now, the process
of spermatogenesis
involves a couple of things,
but a lot of the players
are the same as the
process of developing
the so-called oocyte,
the immature egg.
We've got GnRH from
the hypothalamus.
That's going to be a player.
We have FSH,
follicle-stimulating hormone,
although the name's a little
bit of a misnomer in the context
of spermatogenesis, because in
the context of spermatogenesis,
there is no follicle.
What we're really
talking about is
FSH for stimulating the
maturation of the sperm cell,
so not egg follicle
but sperm cell.
But we still have GnRH,
FSH, LH, and rather
than the ovary being the
target of those hormones,
it's going to be the testes.
So most everybody should know
that the testes and the ovaries
are the so-called gonads.
The testes, of course,
reside outside of the body.
There are instances
where the testes fail
to descend during development.
Certainly, if the
testes don't descend
on time, that's something that
doctors need to be made aware
of, the pediatrician
should be made aware of,
because that can
prevent fertility.
Why would that be?
Well, it turns out
that the testes
reside outside the
body in the scrotum
because the
temperature conditions
under which
spermatogenesis can occur
and under which healthy
sperm can be maintained
are very restricted and is
approximately 2 degrees cooler
than the rest of the body.
This is very important.
I think this is something that
used to be discussed a lot more
but isn't discussed
so much these days.
But keeping the
testes cool enough--
doesn't necessarily mean keeping
them cold, although there
is a place for
using cold exposure,
deliberate cold
exposure, to improve
sperm quality and
number and perhaps even
testosterone levels.
We'll talk about that
a little bit later.
But keeping the
testes about 2 degrees
cooler than the rest of
the body is absolutely key.
If sperm get too hot, they die.
And if spermatocytes, the
cells that give rise to sperm,
get too warm, well, then
oftentimes the sperm
that develop are not
healthy, not healthy
in a number of ways.
Either they can't engage in
fast forward progression--
that is, swimming-- or
they will lack the ability
to deposit their DNA
contents within the egg.
So again, whatever is
contained in the ejaculate
is going to be a mixture of
different sperm qualities.
And sperm of different ages will
impact the quality, but also
the temperature under which
those sperm developed is
going to impact their quality.
And so we're going to get
into tools a little bit
later, as I mentioned, but just
to give you a simple takeaway.
If you are hoping to conceive
in the next 90 days--
the spermatogenesis
cycle take 60 days,
but then the sperm actually have
to migrate from the testicle
into the so-called epididymis,
which is a related structure,
and then into the
vas deferens and then
into the urethra, where it
can be part of the ejaculate.
In order for sperm to
do all that properly,
undergo that maturation and
then exit in ejaculate in a way
that's healthy or that
the sperm is healthy,
if you plan to conceive children
or to try and conceive children
in the next 90 days, you
definitely want to avoid
exposing your testicles--
that is, your scrotum--
to elevated temperatures.
So that means definitely
avoiding hot tubs,
definitely avoiding hot baths.
Now, a brief hot bath
or hot tub or hot shower
isn't going to be a
problem, although if you're
really interested in conceiving,
I would avoid hot tubs
and hot baths as
much as possible.
Hot showers are probably fine.
But if you're going to go
into a sauna, for instance,
you might want to
rethink that decision.
And if you do decide
to, you almost certainly
would want to bring a cold
pack in that you could-- well,
hopefully put some material
between the cold pack
and the scrotum so you
don't get a cold burn.
But put something there, but
keep the scrotal tissue cool.
Keep it cold to cool because
heat exposure can really
mutate and disrupt
the developing sperm,
and it can kill sperm.
And so, again, that would
be for an entire 90 days
leading up to your
attempts to conceive.
Again, we'll get into more tools
later, but a number of people
also have probably heard
of the boxers versus briefs
controversy, I guess it is,
or whether or not people call
it going commando with no
underwear of any kind-- boxers,
briefs, briefs, or
otherwise rather.
It turns out that the data
on that point to the fact
that there isn't really a big
difference in terms of sperm
quality if people
wear boxers or briefs
or don't wear anything under
their jeans or shorts at all.
The scrotum has the ability to
move the testicles far enough
away from the body in
order to achieve lower
temperatures if it needs to.
It achieves that
through a muscle
called the cremaster
muscle, which
is a really interesting
muscle, believe it or not.
I was reading up on the
biology of the cremaster
muscle, something
I never thought
I'd spend too much time on but
that I ended up spending far
too much time reading up about.
And it's really fascinating.
What you have is a muscle
that is a smooth muscle
tissue, unlike skeletal muscle,
which is striated muscle,
that is temperature dependent.
So it has certain nerve endings,
and it has certain receptors
on it that allow it to
respond to local temperature
and then to relax in
order to essentially let
the testicles to descend further
from the body or to contract
and bring the testicles
closer to the body
in order to try and maintain
the optimal temperature range.
And it turns out the cremaster
muscle can achieve that
whether or not people are
wearing boxers or briefs.
Although it stands to
reason that any kind of--
there's no other name for
it-- undergarments-- you know,
I don't know why that word
just seems kind of antiquated--
but undergarment that allows
some movement of the scrotum
and the testicles should
be sufficient to allow
these temperature variations to
occur and keep things in range.
That said, a little bit later,
we'll go into some detail,
really--
because it's
important-- as to why,
for instance, if you are
somebody who has big thighs,
believe it or not,
that it actually
can lower sperm count
substantially, whether or not
the big thighs occur
because you're very muscular
or the big thighs occur
because you are overweight.
It can increase the temperature.
If you're sitting
a lot, increases
scrotal temperature, for sure.
And there are some other things
that can increase scrotal
temperature, seat heaters
in cars, for instance--
terrible idea, just terrible
idea if you're hoping
to conceive in the near future--
and again, hot tub,
things of that sort.
So temperature modulation
of spermatogenesis and sperm
quality and function is key.
That relates a little
bit more to tools.
But what happens?
How does the actual
sperm develop?
Well, contained
within the testicle,
you have the cells, the
so-called spermatogonia,
which differentiate into
so-called spermatocytes.
You don't have to
remember all this.
And the spermatocytes undergo
this process of meiosis.
Meiosis is a form of
cell division, which
reduces the chromosome number to
those 23 individual strands as
opposed to pairs.
So it makes them haploid
as opposed to diploid.
Very, very important for reasons
that we talked about earlier.
And the meiosis process in
these primordial sperm cells,
these immature sperm cells, is
similar to the meiosis process
that occurs in eggs when
the chromosomes segregate in
that it involves these
spindle-like structures
within the cell.
Now, why do I keep
bringing up the spindles?
Well, it turns out
that the function
of the spindle in
the egg and the sperm
is heavily dependent on
mitochondrial function.
And later when we get into tools
for improving egg and sperm
quality, you're going to
hear about a lot of tools
for improving mitochondria.
And it's not just
because the mitochondria
are involved in energy-demanding
aspects of cell biology.
But it's also because the
mitochondria in this context
are very, very important for
the removal of or the separation
of one set of
chromosomes to give you
these two sets of haploid
cells, the egg and the sperm.
And this is so important because
many failures at fertilization,
many failures at implantation,
many, many miscarriages,
and many birth defects that
do survive after birth that
are very detrimental, such as
trisomies and things like that,
occur because the spindles
don't effectively pull apart
the chromosomes in
typically the egg,
but it can also
occur in the sperm.
So the spindles and the
fact that mitochondria
are rich on the spindle are
very important for generating
these haploid sperm--
again, 23 individual strands
of chromosomes.
That's occurring
inside of the testes.
So there's not as much
long-distance migration
of the spermatocytes
and the sperm cells
as there is the
egg just when you
think about the overall
architecture of the uterus
and the Fallopian tubes
compared to the testicles,
but there's still
a lot of movement.
So within the
testicle, if you were
to look at the testicle
in cross-section--
and I prefer to call
it that rather than cut
the testicle in half.
Any time you talk about
anatomy, you actually
talk about slicing things.
That's what you would do with
a cadaver is what I teach
and we do in my
laboratory and, frankly,
in biological laboratories
all over the place.
But when you talk about it, you
talk about if you were to take
a visual cross-section
through the testicle,
what you would find is that
there are a lot of different
little tubes, a lot of
ducts, D-U-C-T-S, ducts.
Those are pathways.
And the main ducts that are
important for this discussion
are called the
seminiferous tubules.
So it's a mesh-like
or network structure
of tubes in the testicle.
And the immature sperm sit
on a little compartment
along the edge of those tubes.
And as they mature, they
move towards the center
of those tubes.
And then when they
are mature enough,
those sperm cells actually drop
into the hollow of the tube,
and then can travel
through those tubes
to a structure that's along
the side of the testicle called
the epididymis.
The epididymis, again,
is a series of ducts.
And then the epididymis
converges with something
called the vas deferens.
I think in high school,
we all remember this
by thinking about it's
the vast difference.
I don't know who
came up with that.
I think it was a
young girl sitting
to the left of me that
was like, oh, it's
like the vast difference.
I never forgot that.
I don't know.
Maybe it was the topic matter.
Maybe it was her.
Maybe it was some
combination of the two.
But in any case, the sperm
go from the seminiferous
tubules to the
epididymis and then
to the vas deferens and then
are contained in the ejaculate,
along with seminal fluid.
Now, the seminal fluid
is the carrier fluid
for the sperm themselves.
This is important
because it turns out
that a lot of things that can
both negatively or positively
impact the quality of the
sperm relates not just
to the sperm cells themselves
and the temperature
of the environment that
they were matured in,
but also to the semen quality.
For instance, if you are a heavy
drinker, if you are a smoker,
or if you are a regular
user of cannabis,
especially if you smoke
cannabis or vape cannabis,
you create a lot of
reactive oxygen species
that disrupt the chemistry
of the seminal fluid, which
disrupts the sperm cells.
So it's not a direct action
always on the sperm cell
itself, although it can be.
So for instance, in the form
of smoked tobacco or cannabis,
there are a lot of
carcinogens and mutagens
that actually mutate the DNA,
can cause DNA fragmentation,
and debilitate sperm.
But there are also a lot of
things created by smoking
in particular, regardless
of what's being smoked,
that can create elevated
reactive oxygen species
and disrupt the seminal fluid
that the sperm are contained
in in the so-called
ejaculate, the semen.
Now, this will also become a
relevant conversation later
when we briefly talk
about vasectomies.
Vasectomies are
literally a cutting
of the vas deferens, which
leads to a situation,
provided the surgery
was done correctly,
where men can still achieve
all the other aspects
of intercourse.
They can still achieve erection.
They can still achieve orgasm.
They can still ejaculate.
But when they ejaculate, the
seminal fluid is released,
but there are no sperm contained
within the seminal fluid.
And it turns out
that vasectomies
are a very effective
form of birth control.
And they always check
to see if zero sperm
and confirm that
zero sperm are being
released in the ejaculate.
They are reversible.
And that is, vasectomies are
reversible, but not always.
There are a subset of cases
where it's not reversible,
in which case if people
still want to have children,
you have to go in and actually
surgically extract sperm
from the testicles.
But it's a process in which
the vas deferens is altered
or severed in a way that
the sperm can't actually
exit the testicle.
They can get into the
epididymis, usually,
but not into the vas deferens
and so on and so forth.
So if you've ever wondered
what a vasectomy is,
that's what a vasectomy is.
And I mentioned vasectomy
now because it illustrates
the difference between the
seminal fluid, the semen,
and the sperm that
the semen contain.
So 60 days to generate the
sperm, another two weeks
or so for the sperm to travel
through the various ducts
to the point where they can
be contained in the ejaculate.
Let's talk about the
sperm cells themselves.
The sperm cells, again,
have these 23 pairs
of single-strand chromosomes.
They're haploid.
They have either an X
or a Y sex chromosome
as the 23rd so-called
sex chromosome.
And as we all know,
they have a head.
The head tends to be
oval in most cases.
The head contains very
important enzymes and proteins
that are designed to fuse
with the much larger egg
and to actually take the
membrane of the sperm cell
and combine to actually mesh
with the egg cell's membrane
and then deliver the genetic
contents to the egg cell,
in other words, to
fertilize the egg cell.
Now, just behind the head is a
region called the mid region.
That mid region is a
slightly thickened region.
And here, of course, I'm
talking about healthy sperm cell
morphology.
Morphology simply means shape.
A mid region-- that
mid region has a bunch
of things related
to cell motility
and to the forward
progression of the cells.
First of all, it is chock a
block full of mitochondria.
In fact, if you
were to look just
behind the head of the
sperm, what you'd see
is that it is completely
surrounded by mitochondria.
There are mitochondria elsewhere
in the cell, but most of them
are contained in this
mid region compartment
just behind the
head of the sperm.
And that thick region is where
the tail movement of the sperm,
the flagellation back and forth,
is actually generated from.
Much like if you were to
hold a rope, like a battle
rope in the gym, and you
were to whip the battle rope,
the whip at the
one end of the rope
is what allows for the sort
of-- let's just call it
what it is-- the
curves in the rope,
the oscillations, the
rising and falling
of the rope all the
way out to the end.
It is the force of the whip
right at that end that with
the battle rope you're
doing with your hand--
and with the sperm, that is
occurring just behind the head
of the sperm--
that is actually going
to dictate how fast
and how well that
sperm can swim.
And indeed, the sperm
has to swim very far.
How far?
Well, on a relative scale--
and again, these are estimations
because they're going to be--
how should we say?
There will be differences
in the distance
from the head of the penis and
where the ejaculation occurs
to the cervix, depending
on the relative size
of the vaginal canal
and the penis that
delivers the ejaculate
to the vaginal canal.
But once the sperm arrive
at the cervix, which
is at the back of
the vaginal canal
just at the opening
to the uterus,
once the sperm arrive
there, the distance
from the cervix to
the egg, of course,
will vary depending
on where that egg is
in its ovulatory
trajectory, its pathway.
But it is akin, if
you scale for size,
to the distance between Los
Angeles and San Francisco,
which is many, many
hundreds of miles.
So those sperm have
to swim very far.
Now, of course, if the sperm are
delivered in the vaginal canal
somewhat further away, they
will have further to go.
If they're delivered right
at the cervical opening,
they will have less far to go.
The very effective swimming
sperm swim very fast.
So they are able to
accomplish that distance
in just a few days.
And this relates to
a discussion that we
will get into in
a lot more detail
later as to how often couples
should have intercourse
if they're trying to conceive.
Many people might think,
well, it's every day.
However, the more frequent
the ejaculation, the lower
the concentration of
sperm in each ejaculate.
So this is not a
discussion about how often
to have intercourse depending
to your preferences,
for pleasure or bonding
or whatever reason.
This is a discussion about
how often to have intercourse
in order to optimize the
probability of fertilization
of the egg.
There's some general rules
that, of course, come to mind,
which is ejaculations close
to ovulation-- both before,
during, or sometimes after--
are obviously advantageous.
But you will also hear
OB/GYNs and urologist
suggesting intercourse
every other day
leading up to the
day of ovulation,
starting about three
to four days out
from the day of ovulation.
So we got a little
bit sidetracked,
albeit I think appropriately so,
in focusing on fertilization.
But what we were talking
about right up until the point
of that is the anatomy
of the sperm itself,
which is the head,
the mid region that
contains all those
mitochondria, and then the tail.
Now, what we haven't discussed
is the actual generation
of the sperm.
So if you're a male
or if you're a female,
I think it's really
important to understand
how spermatogenesis works.
Spermatogenesis works
in much in the same way
that the generation and
maturation of eggs work,
although, as I
mentioned before, it's
going to occur ongoing
throughout the cycle
of the male's life
after puberty.
We already talked about
puberty, and I'll just
cover this in two
or three sentences
as it relates to males.
And it's essentially
the same thing.
The hypothalamus, up until
the point of puberty,
is providing suppression
of the release
of gonadotropin-releasing
hormone.
Then some biological clock,
which is still not clearly
understood-- it's probably not
leptin coming from body fat.
Again, unlike in the female,
it's probably not leptin
coming from body fat.
But some other signal
arrives to the hypothalamus,
removes that
inhibition, and GnRH,
gonadotropin-releasing
hormone, is now
released onto the pituitary.
A bunch of hormones are
deployed from the pituitary
as a consequence.
The two most important ones for
the context of this discussion
are follicle-stimulating
hormone and luteinizing hormone.
Follicle-stimulating hormone
and luteinizing hormone
travel to the
testes, and they're
going to do two main things.
One, they're going to trigger
the production of testosterone.
And they're going to
trigger the production
of the sperm themselves.
They're going to set in
motion, for essentially
the rest of the life of the
male, the production of sperm.
They're going to initiate
the spermatogenesis cycle,
and that cycle is
going to be ongoing
at various stages
for different sperm
for the rest of the man's life.
This is very different than
the triggering of development
of oocytes and eggs in females,
where there's an existing
vault. That vault can be
depleted to the point of zero
where it can't occur again.
Men can generate sperm
their entire lifetime.
Of course, there's
a diminishment
of sperm production in
very, very late age,
say, 80s and 90s or 100s.
But believe it or not, there
are still sperm being produced.
The quality of those
sperm is another question.
So everything we're
going to talk about now
is essentially puberty onward.
Prior to that,
testicles are present,
but they're not
generating sperm.
Ejaculation isn't possible,
or if it is possible,
it's very unlikely and
unusual, and it's not
going to contain sperm.
Everything we're going
to talk about now
is puberty forward, so puberty
onward to the rest of life.
And luteinizing hormone
secreted from the pituitary acts
on the testes and on a
very specific cell type
in the testes called the Leydig
egg cells, or Leydig cells,
L-E-Y-D-I-G, the Leydig cells.
The Leydig cells of the testes
are what produce testosterone.
Testosterone is going to
have two major effects.
And here I mean really
major because it
has many, many hundreds of
effects on different tissues
of the body.
In fact, that's the definition
of a hormone, really.
It's a substance that acts
in an endocrine fashion.
It can act on the very
tissue that generated it.
So for instance, testosterone
made by the Leydig cells
within the testes will
act on the testes,
as we'll talk about in a moment.
But it can also act
on other tissues.
It can act on the
pharynx and larynx
and deepen the voice, as
it does during puberty.
It can act on the hair follicles
and generate facial hair.
It can act on the musculature
and generate protein synthesis
and development of
muscle, bone, et
cetera, all the
things we associate
with puberty and with
testosterone typically.
Restricting the conversation
to the effects of testosterone
on the testicle itself
and on spermatogenesis,
the Leydig cells
make testosterone.
And keep in mind that
some of that testosterone
will travel
elsewhere in the body
and do its thing
for gene expression
and the more acute effects
of testosterone on the brain
included.
But the testosterone
within the testes
is at extremely
high concentration.
In fact, the concentration of
intratesticular testosterone
is at least 100 times higher
than the concentration
of testosterone anywhere
else in the body,
even though it's being secreted
into the rest of the body.
And that's because
there are a number
of different so-called
binding proteins and enzymes
that sequester the
testosterone within the testes.
So the Leydig cells are
making testosterone,
and a lot of that
testosterone is acting on
and is restricted to the testes.
And that turns out to be very
important because testosterone
within the testes
acts in concert
with a different biological
program that starts with FSH,
follicle-stimulating hormone,
that also travels to the testes
and acts on a very specific
set of cells that are called
supporting cells or,
more specifically,
the Sertoli cells.
The Sertoli cells
are the cells that
generate something called ABP,
or androgen-binding protein.
And it is the combination of
testosterone from the Leydig
cells and ABP from
the Sertoli cells
that is necessary
for spermatogenesis.
It's necessary for
those spermatocytes
to become what will eventually
be healthy, mature sperm that
have really nice shaped oval
heads, have a mid region,
chock a block
through mitochondria,
and can generate a fast
whipping motion of the tail
to swim from the cervix, or
up the vagina into the cervix,
and from the cervix to the
egg to fertilize the egg.
So it's really a basic set
of chemical players that are
involved here and
so basic, in fact,
that if you were to disrupt any
one of these chemical players--
either the luteinizing
hormone, the FSH,
the testosterone from
the Leydig cells,
or androgen-binding protein--
you would observe
pretty marked disruption
in spermatogenesis or the
elimination of sperm entirely.
We'll get into a few
deficits in sperm development
and sperm number and sperm
function a little bit later.
But just keep in mind--
or I should say, maybe
sit back and just
appreciate that the exact
same players generate
from the hypothalamus,
which causes luteinizing
hormone and follicle-stimulating
hormone released
from the pituitary, which
travels to the gonad, which
in this case is the
testicle, which triggers
the release of
testosterone from Leydig
cells, which triggers the
action of the supporting cells,
the Sertoli cells, which make
androgen-binding protein.
Testosterone and
androgen-binding protein
combine and create a
chemical and actually
a structural milieu in which
those little spermatocytes
can go from the
walls, from literally
the walls of the tubes of
the seminiferous tubules,
can mature into healthy,
well-developed sperm,
and can hop into those
ducts, those little tubes,
and then head off to the
epididymis, where they will
reside-- the epididymis is the
tissue nearby the testicles
or surrounding one
portion of the testicle--
and then eventually fuse
with the vas deferens,
can combine with or be
contained with, rather,
the seminal fluid, and then can
be ejaculated via the urethra
into the female,
where then they can
swim very quickly, effectively
the distance, for them anyway,
from Los Angeles
to San Francisco,
over the course of a very
short period of time,
and fertilize the egg.
So that's the process of
spermatogenesis, the maturation
of sperm, which is ongoing
throughout the lifespan
from puberty onward.
And in doing so, we talked about
some of the hormonal elements--
coming from the hypothalamus
and coming from the pituitary,
and within the testes themselves
the Leydig cells, which
produce testosterone,
the Sertoli cells,
which are the support cells that
allow spermatogenesis to occur.
With that in mind,
next I'd like to think
about what's actually contained
in the ejaculate in terms
of numbers of sperm and
what's really being selected
for in terms of the sperm
that actually successfully
fertilizes the egg and
what sorts of elements
come into play in dictating
whether or not fertilization
will or won't occur.
And the major themes that
we're going to discuss
are frequency of
ejaculation, but really
that's just kind of a proxy
for talking about maximizing
sperm concentration and quality
of sperm arriving at the egg--
because, remember, ovulation
and the menstrual cycle
are really about creating the
opportunity for fertilization.
And we are also going
to talk about how
the vaginal duct,
the vagina, and
the milieu around the cervix
and some other elements
within the female
herself contribute to
and support the sperm in
their journey to the egg
and in the likelihood that
they will fertilize the egg.
So really what we need to talk
about first is sperm quality.
And we should also probably
talk about ejaculate quality,
because, as odd as
that theme might seem,
really the ejaculate
quality, which
has a number of
different parameters,
including the number
of mature sperm
that are not so mature that
they're swimming slower
or are dead, but also
quality of sperm.
They have, for
instance, one tail.
It's not entirely
uncommon to see sperm
with two tails because they
just didn't form properly
or sperm that are
not moving very much.
In fact, sperm motility is
scored along a scale of 0,
1, 2, or 3, 3 being the best,
fast forward progressing.
0 is not moving at all.
1, they're actually
called twitchers.
Twitchers are sperm that
sort of just twitch in place
but don't undergo
forward progression.
2 is somewhere in between
1 and 3, not surprisingly.
Different clinics, different
OB/GYNs, different urologists
will throw out
different numbers.
But in general, it is hoped
that more than 50% of the sperm
should be motile in some way
or another, so not scoring a 0,
but a 1, or 2, or ideally a 3.
The concentration of sperm--
of course, if it's higher within
the ejaculate, the total number
of sperm per milliliter of
ejaculate, if that's higher,
then there's a
higher probability
that one of those sperm
will fertilize the egg.
One thing I didn't
mention before when
discussing the production
of eggs and ovulation--
and I probably should
have, so I will
now-- is that most
often only one
ovary gives rise to
an ovulating egg.
It happens, but it's somewhat
rare for two mature eggs, one
from each ovary, to be deployed
during a single ovulation.
There's a name for that when it
occurs and both are fertilized.
It's called fraternal twins.
If a single egg--
that, of course, comes
from a single ovary--
is fertilized and
the egg splits--
and that's something that
happens further along
in the process of fertilization
and differentiation
of the embryo--
well, then what you get
are identical twins.
There are other instances that
are quite uncommon in which
you can get fraternal twins
through other circumstances.
But in general, that's
the way it works.
But essentially what
happens is one egg
from one ovary-- that's
the most common occurrence.
The sperm, once ejaculated
into the vaginal duct,
are going to pass
through the cervix
and then are going to
swim toward the egg.
The egg could be at
varying locations
along the female
reproductive axis.
Now, this is actually
a very important thing
and actually gets right down
to the safety of both the
potentially developing
embryo and the mother.
There is something referred
to as ectopic pregnancy,
and that's when the
pregnancy actually occurs
within the Fallopian tubes.
So the precise location
in which fertilization
between the sperm and the
egg occurs can vary somewhat.
But ideally, the fertilized egg
implants into the endometrium
or the endometrial
lining of the uterus
and develops there as opposed
to within the Fallopian tubes,
which is so-called
ectopic pregnancy.
Now, where the sperm
and the egg meet exactly
can vary, as I mentioned before.
But in general, the
faster swimming sperm
and the more far along the
ovulatory trajectory the egg
are, the higher the probability
of a successful fertilization
because of the proximity
to the implantation zone
of the uterus.
So basically it's all
a probabilities game.
It's a probabilities
game related
to the number of sperm
cells that encounter the egg
and where the egg is in
terms of its ovulatory cycle
and also its position where
it is in the ovulatory cycle.
The sperm parameters--
or I should
say the semen parameters--
and ejaculate parameters
that most clinicians
want to see,
if you were to give
a sperm sample,
would be somewhere in excess of
15 million sperm per milliliter
of ejaculate.
Now, there's a lot of
discussion nowadays.
It seems to be a very
popular news theme
to talk about diminishing
sperm counts, the idea that 100
years ago or maybe even 35 years
ago, the typical male ejaculate
contained 100 million
sperm per milliliter,
and nowadays it's down
to 15 to 20 or 50.
And indeed, sperm counts
do seem to be declining.
And the exact reasons
for that are not clear.
I confess I'm a little bit
reluctant to talk about this
because there have been a lot
of back and forth discussions
about the safety of EMFs,
of electromagnetic fields,
and it's not exactly what
we're talking about here.
But there are some
excellent data
contained in
meta-analyses and reviews
that I will provide links
to and that we'll talk about
in more detail in a
minute that correlate
the advent of smartphones
and in particular caring
of smartphones in the pocket
with diminishing sperm counts.
Although there are certain
to be other factors that
can explain diminishing
sperm counts as well.
Dr. Shanna Swan, for instance,
has done beautiful work
describing how the
phthalates and the BPAs
and so-called
endocrine disruptors
might be disrupting
some of the milieu
of the seminiferous tubules.
So this would be reductions in
testosterone and/or disruptions
to the Sertoli cells and
androgen-binding protein
brought about by endocrine
disruptors such as phthalates
contained in pesticides and
contained on printed receipts
and things of that sort.
There are some data
that that is negatively
impacting sperm counts.
How much so is still debatable.
There are also quite
good data pointing
to the fact that
both the heat-related
and the non-heat-related impact
of smartphones and laptops
contained on the lap are
impacting sperm count
and in a negative way.
Again, there's going to
be tremendous variation
in the concentration
of sperm from one
individual to the next.
It will vary according to age
and a number of other factors
that we'll talk about
a little bit later.
But in general, if somebody
is wishing to conceive,
then clinicians like to
see a ejaculate volume
of more than 2 milliliters.
So ejaculate volume
can be anywhere
from 1.5 to 5 milliliters.
And that will
strongly be determined
by how frequent
ejaculation is occurring.
There's a lot that goes
into evaluating the quality
of ejaculate and sperm.
But basically these huge
variations that are observed
of anywhere from 15 million
sperm per milliliter
or, in some males who are not
producing sperm for whatever
reason-- we'll talk about
those reasons in a little bit--
as low as 5 million
sperm per milliliter,
all the way up to
100 or maybe even
200 million sperm
per milliliter.
Huge variation-- the cause
of which is not always clear
but is certainly
determined in part
by the frequency of ejaculation.
So because there are
so many variables
impacting why one male
versus another male or even
the same male
across the lifespan
might have variations in
his concentration of sperm
within the ejaculate, let's talk
for a second about frequency
of ejaculation as it relates
to the goal of fertility,
per se, because that's really
what today's episode is all
about.
So what I'd like
to talk about next
is how people can
increase the probability
of a successful
fertilization, focusing
both on the components
from the male side
and from the female side.
And I'm mainly going to couch
this discussion in the context
of the so-called natural
method of sexual intercourse
and ejaculation in
vivo, within the female.
But I will also touch
on some parallel themes
as it relates to
in-vitro fertilization
and intrauterine insemination.
So the idea here is that
we want the maximum number
of high-quality sperm--
that is, rapidly forward,
motile sperm that are of
the correct morphology--
that is, shape.
That's going to require
a lot of mitochondria
in the mid region,
a well-shaped head--
so it's going to be
an oval-shaped head.
The tail is going to be a
single tail, not multiple tails.
These aren't going to be
the twitcher type of--
or immotile type of sperm that
are either twitching in place
or aren't moving forward.
All of those
components are going
to be essential for
increasing the probability
of fertilization.
But of course, there's
the female side of it,
too, which is that
ovulation occurs
on just one day during the
menstrual ovulatory cycle.
And that egg will be
available for fertilization
for approximately 24 hours.
Now, keep in mind that
the sperm can survive
within the vaginal duct
and within the area
around the cervix
and within the uterus
and along the female
reproductive tract for anywhere
from three to five
or it's even been
described as up to seven days.
But generally, it's going to
be about three to five days.
Now, most women can figure
out the day of their ovulation
by counting the total number
of days of their typical cycle.
And this is where
it's really useful
to have a cycle that's of
more or less regular duration
or, rather, of more or
less regular length.
So as we talked about
earlier, if somebody's cycle
is 21 days or 25 days and it's
21 or 25 days consistently
or even 30 days
consistently, that's
going to be a far better
scenario to favor fertilization
than if it's 20 days
one month and then 21
days the next month, but then
suddenly 30 days and then
suddenly 35 days.
Those varying durations
of the ovulatory cycle
make it very hard,
obviously, to time
and understand when
ovulation is going to occur.
So regular duration
ovulatory cycles
are the ideal circumstance, and
they're the ideal circumstance,
because even though
the egg is only
available for fertilization
for a few days,
those sperm can survive for
some period of time, which
leads to the issue of
how often should couples
be having intercourse.
And here, I'm
referring specifically
to intercourse with ejaculation.
How often should couples
be having intercourse
around the time of ovulation
if the specific goal is
successful fertilization of the
egg and the creation of a baby?
This is leaving aside all
issues, which, of course, are
interesting issues, related
to how often people are having
intercourse, whether or
not there's ejaculation
every time they have intercourse
or not, for sake of pleasure
or for sake of pair
bonding and pleasure
or for sake of any number
of other potential goals
of intercourse.
Here I'm only referring
to intercourse
as it relates to the goal
of fertilization of the egg.
So knowing what we know about
spermatogenesis and the fact
that ejaculate is going to
contain a certain concentration
of sperm but that within that
ejaculate some of the sperm
will be older and less healthy
and some will be optimally
mature and some might
even be a little bit
immature-- although there's a
tendency for the immature sperm
to not have yet exited the
seminiferous tubules, gone
into the epididymis
and vas deferens.
But given that the
ejaculate contains
sperm of varying ages and
therefore varying quality
and given that with each
successive ejaculation
in a short period
of time there's
going to be a decrease in
the concentration of sperm
per milliliter of
semen, of ejaculate,
we can make some
good arguments as
to how often couples
should have intercourse
with ejaculation around
the time of ovulation
if the goal is to fertilize.
If ovulation occurs
on, for instance,
day 14 of a cycle--
and here we're
using the kind of
standard average
of 28 days of the cycle.
But for some people
with a 30-day cycle,
it could be day 15, or
with a shorter cycle,
it could be day
12, for instance.
But given a 28-day
average cycle,
let's say ovulation occurs
on day 13 or on day 14.
And typically, it would occur
on day 14 of a 28-day cycle.
Well, then, given how long
sperm can survive inside
of the woman, you might think
that the optimal strategy would
be to have as much intercourse
with ejaculation in the three
or four days leading
up to ovulation, hope
that those sperm have swam
as far as they possibly
can and will encounter the
egg just as soon as possible
after it ovulates.
It turns out that's not
the optimal strategy.
The optimal strategy is really
to maximize the concentration
of healthy sperm
within each ejaculate
and to really center that
around the day of ovulation.
So what this involves
generally and what
the typical recommendation is
is to abstain from intercourse
with ejaculation
about two or three
days out from ovulation
and then, on the day
prior to ovulation and
on the day of ovulation,
to essentially
introduce as much semen
and ejaculate into the
reproductive pathway
of the female as possible.
Now, that's the
general recommendation
that the OB/GYNs and the
urologists that I spoke to
gave.
But you will also hear
a different strategy.
It's only slightly different.
But the different
strategy involves
trying to maximize the
concentration of healthy sperm
within each ejaculate with
the understanding that,
with each subsequent ejaculation
over about a 24-hour period,
that there's going to
be a dramatic reduction
in the concentration of sperm.
What that means is that
if a couple, for instance,
were to have intercourse
with ejaculation many times
on the day prior
to ovulation, yes,
that will introduce
a lot of sperm
into the reproductive pathway
of the female, but what it means
is that, on the day of
ovulation if they were
to have intercourse, the
number of high quality sperm
that will be available to the
egg will be greatly diminished.
And if none of the sperm
that were introduced
in the day prior managed
to fertilize that egg,
well, then essentially
chances are off
that there will be fertilization
or they're greatly diminished.
Rather, if they're having
intercourse with ejaculation
once or twice on the
day prior to ovulation
and then a maximal number
of times with ejaculation
on the day of
ovulation, that itself
can maximize the probability
of fertilization.
So which strategy is optimal?
Should couples have
as much intercourse
with ejaculation on the
day prior to ovulation
and on the day of ovulation?
Or should they have intercourse
on the day prior to ovulation
but not so frequently that it
diminishes the concentration
of sperm and then
allows for intercourse
with the maximum
number of ejaculations
on the day of ovulation?
You really hear it both ways.
And what this really
boils down to is,
frankly, that nobody knows.
And the reason nobody
knows is that there's
tremendous variation
among males in terms
of the absolute concentration
of sperm per milliliter
of ejaculate and the amount
of ejaculate within
a given time frame.
But what everyone agrees on
is that a period of abstinence
ranging from 48 to 72 hours
prior to an ejaculation
increases the concentration
of high-quality sperm
within that first ejaculation
to occur after the abstinence
period.
So again, to reiterate, if one's
goal is to fertilize the egg,
you want to take
into consideration
that most often
there is going to be
a dramatic decline in the
concentration of sperm
per ejaculate any time those
ejaculations are occurring
within a short
period of time, say,
within 12 to 24
hours of one another.
Now, all of this,
of course, also
relates to the female
biology and the extent
to which the woman can
precisely identify the day
and timing of her ovulation.
Some women feel as if and
indeed are very accurate
at estimating their
time of ovulation
to within a couple of
hours or some women even
report being able to feel
their actual ovulation,
whether or not they are
feeling the ovulation
itself, the deployment of
the egg or not, isn't clear.
I certainly wouldn't know.
I've never produced eggs,
nor have I ovulated,
and I'm certainly not
going to contest the idea
that women can do that.
I mean, it makes
sense that some people
have a very keen
so-called interoceptive
awareness, an awareness
of the sensory events
within their body.
And while, of course,
the ovaries are not
thought of as an
organ that we want
to be able to sense what's going
on in there in terms of feel,
there are sensory
endings within the ovary.
And so the notion that one
could literally sense changes
within their ovary, including
the deployment of the egg,
is not outside the bounds
of reason and, in fact,
could likely be the case.
Now, that said, there are
a number of different ways
that women will track
their ovulation.
One is the temperature method.
So they'll actually measure
intravaginal temperature.
They're looking for
changes in temperature
that are consistent around
the time of ovulation.
We're going to have an expert
guest on, an OB/GYN, who
can tell us a lot more about
the details and nuances
of the temperature method.
You'll see a lot of
information about this online,
but there's a lot of
misunderstanding about it,
as well.
Other women will use apps
that take into account
either the temperature
information
if they're acquiring
temperature information--
that'll be entered
into the app--
as well as marking the
onset of menstruation,
the onset of
bleeding, therefore,
the start of the
ovulatory cycle,
because, of course, as
we mentioned earlier,
that marks day one
of their cycle.
And then, again
and again, you can
see how regularity
of cycle duration
or relative regularity
really favors this whole
process of being able to predict
when one ovulates.
And fortunately, if the
goal is fertilization,
there are some margins for error
that are introduced by the fact
that the sperm can survive
within the female reproductive
tract for some period of
days, thereby reducing
the need for absolute certainty
about the time of ovulation
and so on.
In fact, it's pretty well
known that around the time
of ovulation a couple
of things happen.
Earlier, we talked
about one thing,
which is there's an increase in
libido just prior to ovulation.
This relates to, in
part, an increase
in some of the androgens,
things like DHEA,
but also testosterone and
some related androgens
that can increase libido both
in males and females and changes
to the reproductive pathway,
the female in particular,
a change in the pH-- that
is, the relative acidity
versus basic nature of the
mucosal lining near the cervix
and also vaginal
secretions, such that,
around the time of ovulation,
the entire milieu of the vagina
and the cervix and the locations
in which fertilization can
occur and certainly in
which the sperm are swimming
towards the opportunity
for fertilization
is shifted to support
sperm motility and health.
In other words, one of the
best environments for sperm
to survive is going to be within
the female reproductive pathway
itself.
And as long as we're talking
about vaginal secretions
and mucus, it's
important to point out
that a number of commercially
available lubricants
can actually be detrimental
for sperm health,
even if they don't
contain spermicide.
So this is something
that you'll want
to discuss with your OB/GYN
or, certainly if you're male,
you could also discuss
this with your urologist
and your partner's OB/GYN.
A lot of the commercially
available lubricants
contain chemicals that,
while they may favorably
change the consistency
or the viscosity
of the vaginal pathway for
purposes of intercourse,
certainly may not be the most
favorable for maintaining
the health of the sperm and
the motility of the sperm.
So again, here we're talking
about intercourse only
in the context of trying
to maximize fertilization.
And I should mention
that there are
certain lubricants that are
more conducive to the sperm
environment.
But it's something
that you'll really
want to talk to
your OB/GYN about
or at least read up
about if your interest is
in trying to fertilize
and develop an embryo.
So we covered the
optimal strategies
for how often couples
should have intercourse
with ejaculation around
the time of ovulation
in order to maximize
the probability
that successful fertilization
and ultimately pregnancy will
occur.
What we haven't
covered yet, however,
is how long couples should apply
that method over time in order
to achieve successful
fertilization in pregnancy.
Now, of course, if
a couple decides
that they want to
conceive and they
apply that method or any
other method, for instance,
and they achieve fertilization
and a successful pregnancy
the very first
month that they try,
well, then there's
no other work to do,
at least until that
child is born and if
and only if they decide they
want to have more children.
However, many couples
find that they do not
conceive in the first
month of trying,
even when they apply
the optimal methods
and even if their age and every
other factor related to egg
quality and sperm
quality is optimized.
Now, I think it's
the rare instance
in which egg quality and
sperm quality are optimized.
In fact, the word "optimal" and
"optimization" and "optimized"
is a little bit
misleading in general
because no one really
knows what that is.
But of course,
there is an ideal.
There's a perfect
standard to which
everyone would like to achieve.
But of course, we all enter the
picture with genetic variables,
environmental variables,
and so forth, many of which
we'll talk about because you
can, in fact, adjust them
in the direction that you would
like to improve sperm and egg
quality.
But most people simply
will not succeed
in achieving a successful
fertilization the first month
that they try.
Now, there is a
truth that governs
how many tries it
ought to take in order
to achieve successful
fertilization and ultimately
pregnancy.
And it's very age dependent.
And in particular, it's
dependent on the age
of the mother, because the
age and quality of the egg,
while it's not the only
factor, is certainly
one of the most determining
factors in whether or not
successful fertilization occurs.
And as women age, the
quality of the eggs
tends to diminish
over time, largely
due to changes in the
mitochondrial function
and the spindle that pulls
the chromosomes apart,
although there could be other
factors involved as well.
Now, before continuing
any further,
I just want to acknowledge that
this whole language around egg
quality and sperm quality
is not the greatest
language because it's
entirely subjective.
And yet the word "quality"
in these instances
is really there to
explain a broad variety
of factors that can,
in fact, be measured,
things like the number of
follicles that are deployed
each month in a woman's
ovulation or the number
of motile sperm or the number
of morphologically-- that
is, correctly shaped sperm
in the male and so forth.
So when we talk about egg
quality or sperm quality,
we're really referring to an
amalgam of different features
related to the different
aspects of ovulation
leading to successful
fertilization
or the different aspects of
sperm related to whether or not
they can arrive and
deliver their DNA contents
and so forth.
So I will use the words "egg
quality" and "sperm quality"
just as general themes
because that's what
a lot of the clinicians use.
But I do understand that it's
a little bit of a loaded term
in both instances, and it
doesn't relate to any one
specific parameter, per se.
So getting back to this
issue of how long couples
should try according to
the age of the female
and perhaps also
the age of the male.
Well, most of the data
that have been collected
relate to the age of the
female, as I mentioned before.
And what we're
about to discuss is,
within the scientific
literature,
described as what's
called fecundability,
which is the amount of time
over which a given couple needs
to attempt to
conceive-- of course,
by having intercourse
with ejaculation--
around the time of ovulation.
It assumes that all
the other things
are being done correctly.
And what we know is that there's
a strong age-dependent effect
that largely rests on the
age of the egg-- that is,
of the female.
And what we know is that
for females 30 years old
or younger, if they have
intercourse with ejaculation
around the time of
ovulation, say, on the day
before and on the
day of ovulation--
and there could be other
intercourse with ejaculation
around that time as well--
on average, that will result
in a successful fertilization
in pregnancy about
20% of the time
on the first month
of attempting,
the first ovulation cycle.
Now, if fertilization and
pregnancy occurs, great.
There'll be at least
a nine-month lag
until they decide
whether or not they
want to try and conceive again.
However, most couples, even
if the woman is 30 years
old or younger, will
not successfully
conceive on that first attempt.
And that's because the
probability is not 100%.
It's 20%.
So 80% of the time,
they simply will not
conceive, which means that
they hopefully will try again
the very next month.
And if they successfully
conceive, great.
And if they don't,
then they ought
to try again the next month,
the next month, and so forth.
Now, the typical advice that
an OB/GYN would give you
is that, for a woman
30 years or younger--
and leaving aside
the age of the father
but still assuming that egg
quality and sperm quality
are sufficiently high to
achieve fertilization--
that the couple should--
or if the woman is trying
to have kids alone,
the woman should
attempt to conceive over
the period of six months.
Why?
Well, if you think
about it, if there's
a 20% chance in the first month
and it's unsuccessful, well,
then on the second month,
there'll also be a 20% chance.
On the third month,
also a 20% chance.
What I'm describing
here is what obviously
is independent probabilities.
That is, if you
were to flip a coin
and the probability of
getting heads is 50%,
the probability of getting
tails is 50%, of course.
You don't expect that the
previous flip had anything
to do with the
result that you'll
get on the subsequent flip.
That's what independent
probabilities are.
However, when it comes
to fecundability,
we're really talking
about something
which is called cumulative
pregnancy rate, which
is not really independent
probabilities.
Now, why would that be?
Why would it be that if
you did not successfully
conceive in the first
month of trying that,
by simply trying again and
again and again, the probability
of conceiving would increase?
Well, the reason for that
is that this whole business
of fertilization is
not just about what's
happening with the egg.
It's also about what's
happening with the sperm.
So there are a number of
different events related
to the biology of the egg and
the biology of the sperm, which
you are now very familiar
with from everything
I've talked about up until now.
And there a bunch
of chance events,
for instance, that the
sperm won't actually
arrive at the egg in time
or that the egg won't arrive
at the sperm in time,
because, of course,
it's a bidirectional
migration of those two cell
types, or that, for
whatever reason,
fertilization won't occur.
So what we're really
talking about when
we talk about the cumulative
pregnancy rate over time
is the fact that there are
multiple probabilities at work.
And yes, those are somewhat
independent in the sense
that the biology of the
sperm doesn't really strictly
depend on the
biology of the egg,
at least not until they
meet and fertilize.
But the likelihood
of pregnancy depends
on those independent
probabilities,
which makes this a
cumulative pregnancy rate.
Now, if any of that is
confusing, what it basically
means is that for
the egg and the sperm
to meet and to fertilize, a
number of different events
that carry some intentionality--
the sperm swims towards
the egg and so forth.
The egg doesn't have a
personality in there,
at least not yet.
But it, quote, unquote,
"wants" to be fertilize.
It is, in principle,
receptive to fertilization.
Well, in order for
that to happen,
there are going to be some
events related to chance
that could limit the
ability for that to happen,
and there'll be
other events dictated
by the biology of those
two cell types that
are driving that
event to happen,
that are biasing the
event to, yes, happen.
And so what we're
talking about when
we talk about cumulative
pregnancy rate
is how much of the
biology of the woman
is skewed towards fertilization
to be likely to occur.
So to make this very
simple, all we need to know
is that for women 30
years old or younger,
because the probability of
getting pregnant on any one
attempt to conceive
is 20%, well,
then if that doesn't
occur the first time,
then she should simply
repeat that at least five
and probably six times before
deciding to go to an OB/GYN
and conclude that there's
something going on either
with the egg or, of course,
it could be with the sperm
because 20 times 5 is 100.
So we're talking about
cumulative percent--
so 20, 40, 60, 80, 100.
And the six month
there would take you
to 120%, which is a
different thing altogether.
But in general,
that's why OB/GYNs
will tell their
female patients, look,
if you're setting
out to conceive,
try for about five
or six months,
and if you're not successful,
come back and see me.
Now, for women who
are age 31 to 33,
the probability of conceiving
in that first month
drops to about 18%.
So women in that age
range and their partners
should certainly try
and conceive naturally
over a period of six or
seven months in order
to get to that 100%
cumulative probability.
And then for women
who are age 34 to 37,
the probability of conceiving
in that first month
of trying and certainly every
month thereafter is about 11%.
So when the age of the
woman starts extending out
to about 34 or 35 years
old, then the typical advice
of the OB/GYN is going to be
to attempt to conceive over
a period of about
nine months to a year
before deciding to take some
sort of medical intervention.
And then, of course, as the
age of the woman increases,
so too does the quality
of the eggs go down.
Now, that's not true
for every woman.
There are many women who, in
their late 30s and 40s and even
early 50s, have successfully
conceived healthy children,
although the probability of
that-- the likelihood of it
drops substantially.
So for instance, for women
who are age 38 to 39,
the probability of a
successful conception
by natural conception--
intercourse with ejaculation--
is going to be about 5%.
So it's really dropped
to a quarter of what
it was when that woman was 30.
Again, these are averages only.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that if
you are age 38 or older,
chances are that you should
probably go to your OB/GYN
right at the outset
of your desire
to conceive and ask what you
can do to improve egg quality.
Otherwise, if you were
to extend the math out,
we know that if you're age
30 or younger, 20% chance
in any one given month.
That means about four
to six months of trying.
Well, you can simply multiply
that times four or five
for someone in their
late 30s or early 40s.
And so what you're
really talking about
is several years of trying.
And of course, what's happening
during those several years?
The woman is getting older.
And as a consequence,
the quality of the eggs
is declining even further.
So if you are 35, 36
years old, it might not
be entirely unreasonable to
talk to your OB/GYN right
at the outset of
desiring to conceive,
but you could also
just take the approach
of trying to conceive naturally
for about a year or a year
and a half before deciding
to do that, keeping in mind
that all the while
you can't stop time.
So biological time and aging is
going to occur in the backdrop.
But hopefully this description
of cumulative pregnancy rate
makes sense.
Again, the idea is
that while it's true
that every single month
there's an independent chance
of the woman getting pregnant
and that chance is dropping
from abut 20% at age 30 over
time to about, really, 1% to 3%
for women 40 or
older, there's also
this notion of cumulative
probability, which
involves multiple
biological events in both
the egg and the sperm that have
to converge in time and space
in order for successful
fertilization to occur.
As long as we're
on this topic, I
think it's only fair to address
the issue of miscarriage.
And miscarriages can arise
from a variety of sources.
They can arise from
genetic defects.
They can arise from issues in
the milieu view of the uterus.
They can arise from issues with
the sperm, for that matter.
We really don't want to
put all the weight and all
the responsibility on the egg.
This is always an
egg/sperm dynamic.
And when I say
egg/sperm dynamic, now
hopefully that calls to mind
the huge library of information
that we've been
covering up until now
about chromosomal segregation
and the coming together
of these different cell types
and their genetic information.
Any number of different
steps within the process
of fertilization
leading up to pregnancy
can lead to miscarriage.
However, the probability
of miscarriage
greatly increases as a
function of the age of the egg.
And the basic numbers
on thisare are
that for women who are 35
years or older, about 25%
of successful fertilizations
lead to miscarriages.
Now, when those miscarriages
occur during pregnancy
can be highly variable.
Sometimes it's within
the first trimester.
Sometimes it could be later.
But the probability
is about 25%.
That probability increases
greatly over time,
such that by the time women
are in their early 40s--
so 40 or older--
the probability of
miscarriage after
a successful fertilization
is going to be about 50%.
And this could be due
to a number of factors,
as I mentioned before.
But one common reason
is that there can
be chromosomal abnormalities.
And that could be
related typically
to the segregation
of the egg when
half of the
chromosomes in that egg
are removed, taking it
from diploid to haploid.
If you recall, there's
that little polar body,
which is the removal of
the chromosomes that's
ejected from the egg that
will eventually ovulate.
And sometimes not
all the chromosomes
that were supposed to be ejected
in that polar body are ejected.
And as a consequence, there
are multiple chromosomes
or duplications of chromosomes,
things like trisomies.
Sometimes too many
chromosomes move away
and there are actually
removal of entire chromosomes,
meaning both strands, so that
you have chromosomal deletions.
And in that case, typically
fertilization won't occur.
But there are instances in
which fertilization will occur.
So a woman will get a
positive pregnancy test.
Her periods will stop.
And the couple will
think that they're
advancing along the steps
to a successful pregnancy,
and then there will be,
sadly, a miscarriage.
Many, many times
those miscarriages
are the consequence
of the fact that,
when there are extra
chromosomes there or there
are too few chromosomes present,
that embryogenesis can simply
not progress in a healthy way.
There are some
instances in which
all of the chromosomes and all
the chromosomal arrangements
are perfectly normal and
miscarriages can still occur.
I'm going to do a future
episode about pregnancy
and embryonic
development where we
will get into this more deeply.
But just understand that the
frequency of miscarriages
increases dramatically
after about age 34
and then continues to
increase dramatically,
extending well
out until the 40s.
Now, a very important
consideration
in terms of understanding
and predicting
fertility and fecundability,
this word that describes
the probability of getting
pregnant on a given try
and over time, is
trying to address how,
quote, unquote,
"fertile" a woman is
and, importantly, how, quote,
unquote, "fertile" a male is.
And we'll talk about the
male side in a moment.
But when trying to address how
fertile a woman is, of course,
age is going to be one of the
major factors, but just one
factor.
We already talked about
how age determines
the likelihood of a
successful pregnancy
if the intercourse and
ejaculation is being carried
out at the correct times
and with viable sperm
capable of fertilizing eggs.
And then, of course, there's
the issue of egg quality.
But in general, most
women would like
to know how fertile they are
as a function of their age.
And I actually think this is
one of the most important topics
in this whole space
around fertility
that isn't often discussed or
at least isn't often discussed
until women are in
their late 30s or 40s,
when oftentimes
they will look back
and wish that either they
had frozen their eggs
or they had frozen fertilized
embryos, which is a whole thing
unto itself.
And we can talk
about that when we
have an episode on in-vitro
fertilization in more depth.
But there is a fairly
straightforward way
or set of ways that
women can determine
their basic level of fertility.
Leaving aside a lot
of the detailed issues
about the quality of eggs
and so forth, one thing
that you already learned
is that there's this vault,
there's this reserve that
we call the ovarian reserve,
and that each month a
certain number of follicles
leave that reserve, and
there's the opportunity, based
on the ovulation of a single
egg, to fertilize that egg
and for the woman
to get pregnant.
Now, one thing that
we know for sure
is that the size of
the population that's
released from that
vault each month
has a very strong
positive correlation
with the size of the
reserve in the vault itself.
So the way to think
about this, perhaps,
is that the vault is
like a bank account.
It has a certain
amount of money--
in this case, eggs-- in it.
And you could imagine, if
someone's reasonably logical,
that if they have more money
in their bank account, then
they're going to
withdraw a larger amount
each month than if they have
a small amount each month,
if the idea is to make
that vault, that bank,
of eggs available to them over
the longest period of time.
And indeed, biology
is pretty smart.
It doesn't deploy or release
half the follicles in one month
and then just slowly trickle
out the remainder of follicles.
No, that's not how it works.
What you find is that, of
course, in younger women--
so, say, in their late
teens, 20s, and 30s--
the ovarian reserve
in the vault is
going to have more eggs
in it, and the number
of follicles and eggs that
leave that vault each month
is going to be quite high.
So one way to evaluate
how, quote, unquote,
"fertile" you are--
again, just one way--
is to go to your OB/GYN
and say that you would like
to know how many follicles
you have in a given month.
And of course, they'll
look at them on both sides,
in both ovaries.
And for instance, if a woman
has just two or three follicles
that are out each month, well,
then the assumption-- again,
it's just an assumption-- but
the assumption that's pretty
good-- because there is this
positive correlation that
generally occurs--
is that that ovarian reserve--
that the number of
eggs in the vault
is fairly low
compared to someone
who, say, has 20 follicles
or 30 follicles each month.
And that's the typical trend.
Again, these are averages.
And it's very important to not
get attached to any one number
here.
Again, these are averages.
So for instance, there are women
who only deploy five follicles
and eggs each month out
of their ovarian vault
but who find themselves
to be very fertile.
And there could be a
number of different factors
to explain that.
Other women will
have 20 or 30 eggs
and follicles that leave that
vault, the ovarian reserve,
each month.
And they will have a
harder time getting
pregnant for any number
of different reasons.
But in general, the
more eggs and follicles
that leave the vault each
month, the higher number
of eggs that are still in
reserve, meaning the greater
amount of time over which
a given woman could still
attempt to have
successful fertilizations.
Now, this small collection
of follicles and eggs
that are released each
month actually has a name.
They're called antral follicles.
These are small follicles.
They tend to be about 2
to 9 millimeters across.
The way these are
analyzed or measured
is woman will go into the OB/GYN
office, and by ultrasound--
typically there's
some local anesthesia,
but it's not often a
general anesthesia,
but by local anesthesia or
sometimes no anesthesia--
they will essentially count
the number of follicles that
are present in each side,
on ovary on the left
and the ovary on the right, and
give a woman some sense of how
many follicles she has.
And typically this is done
over a series of months
to determine how many eggs
are leaving the ovarian
reserve each month and
therefore how many eggs
she is likely to still have
in the ovarian reserve.
now there's a noninvasive
way to do this, as well.
Although, typically, an OB/GYN
will do both what I just
described with ultrasound and
measure something called AMH,
which is anti-Müllerian hormone,
which is a hormone that is
released by that antral
follicle population,
the population of follicles
and eggs that leave the ovarian
reserve each month.
So one is a blood draw
measure of a hormone, AMH.
The other is a structural
imaging measure
of the antral
follicles directly.
again the typical trend is for
the number of antral follicles
to decline over time.
So one might expect,
for instance,
that a woman in her 20s or
30s might have 20, 30, maybe
even 40 antral
follicles that are
exiting the reserve each month.
And again, that's the
total across both ovaries.
Again, these are just averages.
These are going to
be distributions.
There will be people
with far fewer.
with far more.
But that over time, regardless
of where a woman starts out,
from one decade to the
next half decade and decade
and so on, that the number of
antral follicles will decline
and the amount of or the levels
of AMH will also decline.
So what does this all mean?
What this means
is that if you are
a woman who is in her 20s or
30s or 40s, whatever your age,
if you are interested in
conceiving in the future,
it's very likely a good
idea to go to your OB/GYN
and get either your AMH levels
measured or your follicle count
measured and to do that several
times in a given period.
And I don't mean a
menstrual period.
I mean given a period of
time across several months
to determine what is the average
number of follicles, what's
your average AMH level,
thereby giving you
some window into how many
eggs you are likely to still
have in your ovarian reserve.
I cannot tell you how many women
that I've spoken to and how
many OB/GYNs--
more importantly,
because they speak
to many more women about this
than I ever have or ever will--
wish that they had
done this earlier.
They think, oh,
well, I'm in my 20s,
so I'm likely to have
a ton of follicles,
or they got pregnant
once before,
and so they're not so concerned
about the number of follicles
or their AMH levels.
But over and over
again, I was told
in researching for this
episode that the earlier
and more frequent that women
do this procedure of measuring
AMH and measuring
their follicle count,
the higher the probability
that they will eventually
have a successful
fertilization and pregnancy
when they seek to do so.
Now, the mirror image of all
this, of course, is the sperm.
And there's a kind of
common misconception
out there that, you know,
the sperm, you only need one.
And indeed you only need one.
But actually, you
need many, and it's
only one that's able to
successfully fertilize the egg.
So this whole
concept of you only
need one is both
dismissive of the sperm
but more importantly
dismissive of the biology
of the sperm and the egg.
It only takes one successful
sperm and one successful egg,
but that's sort of
like telling a woman,
hey, you only need one egg.
You need one egg of sufficient
quality in the right time
and place, and
you need one sperm
of sufficient quality in
the right time and place
in order to get successful
fertilization and hopefully
pregnancy.
But you need a lot
of sperm in order
to get a high probability
that that one sperm will
be able to successfully
fertilize the egg.
So we have this image of
sperm as these dumb operators
that just sort of swim
mindlessly towards anything.
And if they bump into an egg,
then they fertilize the egg.
And that's really
not the way it works.
As I talked about
earlier, the sperm--
with its head, its
mid region, its tail,
chock a block with mitochondria
in the mid region--
is really an active motile
cell that indeed will just
swim forward, if it's a healthy,
forward progressing sperm.
But many males out
there just simply
do not have any knowledge
of how many quality
sperm that they happen to have.
Now, given the fact
that sperm analysis
is relatively inexpensive and
also the fact that freezing
sperm is relatively
inexpensive, I
think it stands to reason that
most men should at least get
some window into the number
and quality of their sperm.
Now, it's a fair assumption
to say that if someone
is in their late teens
or early 20s or 30s
that they probably have
high-quality sperm.
But again, as with the
egg and the importance
of measuring AMH and
follicle count across time,
men should really evaluate
the quality and number
of their sperm.
And we talked a
little bit earlier
about some of the parameters
that urologists and OB/GYNs
like to see when
evaluating sperm.
There's a minimum number
or concentration of sperm
that they'd like to see if
a couple is going to use
IVF, in-vitro fertilization.
And typically that's going
to be about 15 to 20 million
per mil of sperm or semen.
And typically they want to
see somewhere between 2 and 5
milliliters of semen,
overall, in a given
ejaculate after a 72 to 48 hour
abstinence period, because,
of course, the
more ejaculations,
the smaller the volume
of the ejaculate
in a short period of time.
But after 48 to 72
hours, you more or less
maximize the volume
of ejaculate.
And then, of course, they
want to see 50% but typically
60% or more of motile
sperm in order to get IVF,
but more is better.
And of course, there
is an enormous range,
as I mentioned before.
Some males will have anywhere
from 10 to 20 million sperm
per milliliter of
ejaculate, and some men
will have 100 to 200 million.
But just because they
have 100 to 200 million
doesn't mean that all of those
sperm are of high quality
and can fertilize eggs.
Sometimes more than
half will be twitchers,
and some will be immotile,
and so on and so forth.
So it's very
straightforward what
I believe most people
should do and what
the urologists I spoke to
in advance of this episode
said to do, which is to
simply do a sperm analysis.
Refrain from ejaculation
for 48 to 72 hours.
Give a sperm sample.
Have that sperm sample analyzed.
The cost of the sperm analysis
is not typically that much.
And considering that conception
and healthy conception
and fertilization is
an expensive process
if you have to go the
in-vitro fertilization route,
it stands to reason that the
cost is pretty well justified.
You also have the option
to freeze sperm over time.
There is evidence that
the age of the father
and therefore the
age of the sperm
can dictate whether
or not there's
a higher incidence of
problematic pregnancy
or developmental outcomes,
including autism.
That is true.
You've probably heard
that if the father is
40 years or older, the
incidence of autism
is increased significantly.
That is true.
Although the overall probability
of having an autistic offspring
if somebody-- if the father,
that is-- is 40 years or older
is still quite a bit lower
than you would imagine.
It's not as if the probability
suddenly skyrockets.
So we'll have an
episode on autism
and genetic and
non-genetic influences
on autism and other aspects
of the autism spectrum.
But the point is this.
I believe and the
urologists I spoke
to who are interested in
fertility and male health
and sexual health
suggest that men
get their sperm analyzed
at least once every five
years and certainly,
if they're going
to want to conceive children
in the distant future,
that they consider freezing
their sperm because that, too,
is fairly nominal cost in order
to freeze sperm at a younger
age.
And of course, if you
can freeze and use sperm
from the time in which you
were younger, why wouldn't you,
right?
I mean, you can still opt
to go for natural pregnancy
later if that's
what you want to do.
But having that in reserve
is generally a good idea.
And I discussed some of the
parameters that are looked for.
And perhaps most
importantly, there
is the possibility of an
underlying issue whereby,
for instance, there is very
little sperm in an ejaculate.
As I mentioned earlier, the
seminal fluid in the ejaculate
could have zero sperm in it,
but the volume of ejaculate
could appear completely normal.
So just because your ejaculate
volume is normal to you
or is in that range
of 2 to 5 milliliters,
well, then that
doesn't necessarily
mean that there
are any sperm there
or that there are very few sperm
there and the few sperm that
are there or the many sperm that
there are functionally motile.
So get this analyzed.
It's really worth doing.
And again, it's not something
you have to do every year.
It's something that you want to
do probably every five years,
at least until the
point where you've
conceived as many children
as you ever want to conceive.
So the basic takeaway here
is that, if you're a woman,
to get your egg count--
your antral follicle count,
that is--
and therefore your reserve
of eggs, indirectly measured,
and of course also get
your AMH levels measured,
and if you're a male to
have a sperm analysis
and to do that relatively early.
In fact, another
incentive for doing
that early is that
you have a comparison
point so that, for instance,
if you are in your early 20s
and you're not thinking
about having kids at all
or you're thinking that
you might someday have kids
but it's a really someday,
someday, far off in the future,
well, it's wonderful to have
a reference point from which
to compare your biology
in your early 20s
to your biology in your
mid or late 30s or 40s when
you might happen to be
interested in conceiving.
And if that doesn't
provide incentive enough,
I should mention-- and this
is important to point out
and that I think both
males and females are not
aware of-- is that one in
five couples that have issues
with fertility,
the issue ends up
falling on the biology that
is the quality of the sperm
or a lack of number of sperm.
So I think there's a
misconception that when
fertility is an issue it's
always an issue with the eggs
and this age-dependent decline
in the egg quality-- again,
it's the best language we have
available to us at the moment--
this age-dependent decline in
egg quality is often to blame,
but not always.
One in five couples that
have challenges conceiving it
turns out that it's going to
be an issue with the sperm.
And of course, there are a
number of different sperm
analyses that, should all
the other parameters of sperm
appear normal,
now, for instance,
you can get a DNA
fragmentation analysis.
You can see whether or
not the DNA of the sperm
are somehow disrupted.
Urologists these days are
excellent at figuring out,
for instance, if a male
has lots and lots of sperm,
everything looks great, but the
shape of the head of the sperm
isn't quite right-- if
it's not oval enough
and it's too rounded, that could
be a genetic defect under which
conditions there is zero
probability of the male ever
naturally conceiving, regardless
of who the female partner is.
Believe it or not, males
can have a ton of sperm,
but if they carry a
certain genetic defect,
those sperm will be incapable
of depositing those 23
chromosomes into the egg.
However, there are ways
in which that sperm can
be coaxed or forced
to fertilize the egg
and deposit its genetic contents
by in-vitro fertilization
and then implantation
into the female.
So again, lots of
reasons to have a egg
reserve analysis by
ultrasound and AMH
for females and lots
of reasons for males
to have a sperm analysis.
And of course, typically
with a sperm analysis
and a ovarian reserve analysis
will be a hormone analysis.
And I'm a very strong believer
in people getting an insight--
that is, a window--
into their hormonal
composition, not just
when they encounter
problems but starting
at a pretty early age, even if
it's only done once every five
years or so, having a
reference point to your 20s
and to your 30s and mid-30s for
when you felt a certain way.
Maybe, as in the case
for many people I know,
they actually feel
better in their 40s
than they did in their
20s because they're
doing a lot of things
to support their health.
That is possible.
But in many cases,
people start feeling
not as well or their fertility
seems to be dropping off
or any number of different
parameters that we've discussed
today were related to
vitality and longevity seem
to be dropping off
over time, and they
want to get a insight into
what could be the issue.
And hormones are
sometimes, not always,
but sometimes involved in
those underlying issues.
And there is nothing as valuable
as having a reference point
from a time in which
things were going well
to evaluate the, for
instance, levels of hormones,
not just testosterone but
also estrogen and progesterone
and so forth.
So you need a comparison
point in order
to determine what really
needs to be changed.
So all of this is a strong
push for people to use
your insurance, if you're
able to put it on insurance--
oftentimes people are--
and if not, to try and find a
reasonable or reasonably priced
way to do a sperm
and egg analysis
and to ideally do a
hormone analysis as well.
It's really going to set you
up for the maximum probability
of being able to conceive
children when you want to
and also to avoid a bunch of
other health-related issues
that involve hormones
and reproductive health
and, in general, to support
your mental health and physical
health.
So I've been talking about
a bunch of things to do.
There are a couple of things to
be mindful of to actively avoid
if your goal is to be
and remain fertile.
And that's regardless
of whether or not
you want to conceive children
in the future or not.
Now, in the context
of this discussion,
the same things that
we've heard to be
true for other
aspects of our health
turn out to also be true.
So let's just start
with the basics.
Everybody should be getting
approximately six to eight
hours of sleep every night.
That should be quality sleep.
Optimizing your sleep is
fundamental to balancing
your hormones.
Now, balancing your
hormones is kind
of a catch phrase for all
things related to proper hormone
regulation.
Sleep is the fundamental
layer of mental health,
physical health, and
performance of all kinds
and, believe it
or not, fertility.
When people are not
sleeping well or enough,
stress hormones, in
particular cortisol,
shift to peaking
later in the day,
and those elevated cortisol
levels later in the day
cause a bunch of
different problems
in both males and females,
many of which impact fertility.
So controlling cortisol starts
with controlling your sleep.
It also impacts testosterone
and estrogen levels.
So of course, the proper ratios
of testosterone and estrogen
will vary from males to females.
But in order to get
those right or as right
as they can be without
other interventions,
you want to make sure you're
getting enough quality sleep.
How much sleep?
Most people need about six to
eight hours of sleep per night.
Waking up once,
maybe twice per night
in the middle of the night
and going back to sleep
is not such a big deal, but six
to eight hours of solid sleep
would be ideal.
Some people need a
little bit less in order
to function-- five hours.
Some people need
a little bit more.
Developing teenagers and babies
and kids need a lot more.
People who are sick or
recovering from injury
need a lot more.
We've done multiple
episodes on sleep.
We have a toolkit for
sleep available free
at hubermanlab.com.
You go there.
You don't even have to
sign up for the newsletter,
although you can if you want.
Just go to a Toolkit for
Sleep under the menu,
and you'll be able
to download that,
or you can even just
view it on the screen
if you don't want
to download it.
It has lots of tools.
We've done an episode
called "Perfect Your Sleep"
that has a lot of tools.
They're all timestamped for you.
We've done a "Master Your
Sleep" episode, so lots of tools
to get your sleep right.
Get your sleep right
if you are wishing
to conceive and/or to
simply have healthy biology,
to be fertile, or otherwise.
That's just fundamental.
Now, there are other
things to not do.
And those, again, fall into the
somewhat obvious categories,
but I think a lot
of people aren't
aware of just how striking an
effect these certain behaviors
that you want to avoid can have
in diminishing your fertility
for both males and females.
So let's talk about those.
The first one is smoking.
And when we talk
about smoking here,
we're talking about
smoking nicotine
and we're talking
about smoking cannabis.
And indeed, there
are strong data--
and I will put a
reference to one
of the better larger
analyses of these data.
There are strong data
showing that cannabis
reduces fertility.
Now, I can already hear
the screams from the back,
although they're probably
fairly drawled out screams,
from the back of people
saying they smoke cannabis
and they had no
trouble conceiving.
Certainly, there
will be exceptions.
But whether or not
you're male or female,
smoking cannabis is a
bad idea if you want
to conceive a healthy child.
Can you still conceive a healthy
child while smoking cannabis?
Probably certain people can.
Many people will greatly
decrease the probability
of a healthy fertilization and
pregnancy by smoking cannabis.
There are excellent
data to support that.
As well, nicotine,
both smoked or vaped,
is going to disrupt the
process of fertilization
and can disrupt
pregnancy dramatically.
So just avoid it altogether.
How does this happen?
Well, it turns out that smoking
increases what are called
reactive oxygen species.
This greatly
disrupts the quality
of the egg at the level of
the spindle and mitochondria
and a number of other features.
And in the sperm, turns out
that smoking doesn't necessarily
disrupt the sperm
directly, although it
can cause DNA
fragmentation, which
can cause all sorts
of abnormalities,
can prevent fertilization,
can lead to birth defects
in the offspring.
But more importantly,
it increases
what are called reactive oxygen
species in the seminal fluid,
in the semen that
contain the sperm,
this very, under
normal circumstances,
under healthy
circumstances, beautifully
orchestrated chemistry of
fluid that allows the sperm
to thrive in their
trajectory and attempt
to fertilize the egg and
lead to a healthy pregnancy.
So if you are a smoker
and you want to conceive,
the best advice I can give
you is to quit smoking.
And yes, that includes
cannabis as well.
Now, I am not somebody
who believes that cannabis
across the board is not useful.
There are medical applications
and other applications.
I talk about that in an
episode all about cannabis
for health and disease.
And notice, health
was in there too.
So you cannabis smokers,
don't come after me with--
I guess, whatever it
is-- with bongs and pipes
or whatever it is that
you want-- or with vapes.
The point is that,
while it can be
beneficial for
certain populations,
it's certainly bad for others.
And if you're
trying to conceive,
it is bad for fertility and
for a healthy pregnancy.
Now, that's smoking--
and vaping, by the way.
Vaping is included there.
Now, the next category of
don'ts relates to alcohol.
Now, everyone has heard that
drinking during pregnancy
is a bad idea.
You may have heard
and some people
have talked about
the fact that there
are cultures in
which they allow,
if you will, or
even condone, sadly,
one or two drinks
while pregnant,
provided it's just champagne
or something of that sort.
That is a terrible idea.
I did an episode
all about alcohol,
both its potential
health effects,
of which there turned
out to be zero.
And yes, that includes red wine.
It is far better to
not drink at all.
And if you're going
to drink, the limit--
if you're a healthy
adult who's not
trying to conceive,
not pregnant,
and you don't have
issues with alcoholism--
is probably two
drinks per week total.
That's right, two
And that's the level
that you really
should consider if you're a
drinker if you're somebody
who's trying to conceive.
However, for a woman
who becomes pregnant,
the total number of drinks
that you should allow yourself
per week while pregnant and
breastfeeding is indeed zero.
There is absolutely no evidence
that one can, quote, unquote,
"get away" with drinking
during pregnancy.
And people say, well, I had
a perfectly healthy child.
But, of course, you don't know
what the health of that child
would have been had
you not drank at all.
Now, I'm not here with any
generally strong stance
against alcohol.
I myself am somebody who
has a drink every once
in a while, although I
don't consider myself
somebody who has a strong
proclivity for alcohol.
And of course, at
this moment, I'm
not trying to conceive children
and I'm certainly not pregnant.
So that's safe for me.
But frankly, I haven't had
a drink in a very long time.
And so I don't miss it.
And that's me.
But I do realize that a lot
of people enjoy alcohol,
and so it's that
two drinks per week
limit that really
sets the upper limit
and threshold beyond which
you start running into issues
with cellular mutation.
You start running into issues
of oxidative stress, greatly
increase cancer risk, in
particular breast cancer risk.
All of that's covered in the
alcohol episode that we did.
You can find it
at hubermanlab.com
and timestamped if you want
to navigate to specific topics
and so forth, find out all
about the data supporting
the statements that I'm
making, so on and so forth.
Now, if you're somebody who's
seeking to conceive or you fall
into this category that some
couples describe themselves
as we're not trying but
we're not not trying--
meaning they're not
using birth control,
they're kind of letting
chance run its course--
well, then you
should definitely be
aware of the data
showing that even just
one bout, one bout of
so-called binge drinking,
which is five to six drinks
in a given night or half day,
in a 12-hour period-- one
bout of five to six drinks,
if you're a woman
or you're a man,
greatly increases both the
likelihood of mutations
in the embryo that would
result from a fertilization
and at the same time, for
reasons that should be
obvious to you based on all
the biology we've talked about,
a greatly reduced
probability of fertilization.
Now, that absolutely
does not mean
that you should use the
ingestion of five or six drinks
as a method of birth control.
That is not what
I'm saying here.
What I'm saying is that, if
you go out on a given night
and you have five or six
drinks and you happen
to become pregnant,
the probability
that that pregnancy will
be disrupted in some way
is greatly increased.
What the exact consequences
are, no one can tell you.
But also, if you're somebody
who is interested in conceiving
a child, well,
then you absolutely
should abstain from ingesting
drinks more than one or two
during the time in which
you're trying to conceive,
and ideally it would be zero.
And you certainly would
want to avoid drinking
multiple drinks per night.
And so this idea of going out
and having three or four drinks
or four or five
drinks in a given
night at a time in
which you're also
trying to conceive children,
the biology tells us,
the epidemiology tells us that
this is just a terrible idea.
It's going to reduce the
likelihood of fertility
and successful pregnancy.
And if there is a
successful pregnancy,
the word "success" needs
to be in quotes, right?
I mean, I think every parent--
every species, for
that matter-- wants
to increase the probability
of having healthy offspring.
And so, to my mind anyway and to
the OB/GYNs and the urologists
that are focused on
fertility that I spoke to,
everyone will say,
try as hard as you
can to avoid these so-called
binge drinking episodes.
And again, these
episodes are one night
of consuming five to six drinks.
Now, another important thing
to remember in this context
is that the negative effects
of consuming five or six drinks
in a given night extend
over many weeks following
the ingestion of that alcohol.
If you're a male,
what that means
is that's going to impact
the quality of your sperm
and greatly decrease
the likelihood
of successful fertilization
and/or healthy pregnancy
over the period of that entire
spermatogenesis window, which
is, as we talked about before,
60 to 90 days, 60 to generate
the sperm and then some
additional time for the sperm
to be transported to the point
where they could be ejaculated.
If you're a woman and you have
five or six drinks on a given
night, well, then you are going
to disrupt the quality not
of just the egg that
eventually ovulates
but indeed the entire
pool of follicles that
leaves the ovarian
vault in reserve
and from which the one
egg will be selected.
In other words, you are reducing
the quality of all of the eggs
that you happen to
deploy that month.
Now, some of you who were really
following the biology earlier
might say, well, what if
I have those five or six
drinks during the time in which
I'm menstruating, just in which
there's bleeding present?
And therefore, I
haven't yet ovulated.
Ah!
But if you remember the
biology we talked about earlier
specifically, there is a
subset of follicles and eggs
that leave that ovarian reserve
quite a bit before that one egg
is selected for and ovulates.
And of course, there are all
the different hormonal cascades
and the general milieu
of the ovary which
are important and
are being regulated
by different hormones.
And yes, indeed, the
regulation of those hormones
is strongly impacted by
alcohol through a number
of different pathways,
through the regulation
of the neurotransmitter
GABA up in the brain--
it's actually a lot of
GABA and GABA receptors
in the hypothalamus, the
very region from which
gonadotropin-releasing hormone,
our old friend from a couple
hours ago in this
discussion, going
to disrupt GnRH secretion.
You can disrupt pituitary
function with alcohol.
Again and again,
what we're seeing
is that consuming more than
one or two drinks per week
of alcohol is really detrimental
to the entire process
of fertility and the entire
process of healthy pregnancy.
And that's true from both
the male side and the sperm,
and it's true from the
female side and the egg.
So my simple advice
on this is if you
are wishing to have a healthy
fertilization and pregnancy,
the best thing to do would
be avoid alcohol altogether
and, if you are going to
drink, to really limit
that drinking to one or two
drinks per week maximum.
So those are the major don'ts.
Really avoid excessive stress.
And I should mention,
excessive stress
is not just best avoided by
getting enough quality sleep
at night.
Although that is
the primary way.
There are other ways
to avoid stress.
We've done entire
episodes about this,
and we have a toolkit
related to reducing stress
with very simple,
zero-cost tools.
Again, you can find all
that at hubermanlab.com.
And I should
mention, if you want
to find any episode
or topic or timestamp,
that website is keyword
search available.
So you can just go
to hubermanlab.com,
put into the search
function "stress tools,"
and a bunch of different
links will pop up
related to those topics,
likewise with sleep, likewise
with any number of
different topics you
might be interested in.
So get enough quality sleep
and thereby reduce stress
and also directly buffer
stress with real-time tools
to buffer stress that I've
talked about in the episodes
that you can access.
And there are ways to greatly
reduce your overall level
of stress, to limit
any cortisol that's
released to early in the day,
which is when you want cortisol
released, and not have
it late in the day
and so on and so forth.
So reduce your stress.
And as I just told
you, by all means,
do not drink more than
two drinks per week.
And zero is better than two.
If anyone tells you,
oh, well, there's
all this resveratrol in red
wine, and that's good for us,
the data simply
tell us there's not
enough resveratrol in
red wine to really have
any positive health benefit.
The data around
resveratrol and health
benefits itself is
under question nowadays.
Zero alcohol is better
than any alcohol.
Two drinks per
week is the limit.
Also, limit or eliminate or
avoid nicotine and ideally
cannabis, smoking and vaping,
at the time in which you
are trying to get pregnant.
And certainly, if
you are pregnant,
avoid all of the things, as
best you can, that I just
described a moment ago.
Now, there are a couple of
other don'ts that are really
important.
One of the most important
don'ts relates to STIs,
or sexually-transmitted
infections.
Everyone who is sexually
active should get an STI check.
In fact, if you go
to a fertility clinic
or you go for sperm analysis
or you go for egg analysis,
almost always they
will do an STI check,
even if you happen to be in
a monogamous relationship,
even if you happen to
be not sexually active
and you're somebody
who is seeking
to use IVF with a sperm donor
or something of that sort.
Why would they do that?
Why is there so much
concern about that?
Is it about avoiding
giving birth
to a child that has something
like a herpes infection or HIV?
Well, certainly
that's one reason,
but that's a down-the-line
reason, because
at the time when someone
goes into the clinic for one
of these sperm or egg analyses,
that's well in advance
of any pregnancy, right?
The reason is there
are a number of STIs--
in particular chlamydia-- for
which it greatly increases
the probability of miscarriage.
So chlamydia is one of those
very insidious and cryptic STIs
because a lot of people,
both males and females,
don't even realize that
they have chlamydia,
and then they can
carry chlamydia
at the time in
which they conceive,
and then that can lead
to ectopic pregnancies
and/or miscarriages.
So by all means,
get an STI check
if you are somebody who's
seeking to conceive children
or evaluating your
fertility generally.
Chlamydia can also have damaging
effects on the epididymis
and on the various other aspects
of male reproductive health.
In the future, we
will do an episode
all about sexual health.
This is not the time for that.
But get an STI
check if your goal
is to conceive a healthy child.
Now, the other thing that can
have a very negative impact
on fertility and healthy
pregnancy is a viral infection.
For instance, if a male has
had a severe viral illness--
and this could be any number
of different viral illnesses,
from flu to cold or any
number of different viruses.
Pick your favorite virus--
in the previous 70
to 90 days, that
can greatly diminish the
number and/or quality of sperm.
So that's really important.
This is also important if you're
going to go in and do a sperm
analysis and you had
a viral infection
in the previous 70 to 90 days.
Well, then you need
to be aware of that
because it could greatly impact
the parameters of that sperm
analysis.
Likewise, for women, if you've
had a serious viral infection
in the previous 30 days,
does that mean you should not
try and conceive?
Not necessarily, but you should
talk to your OB/GYN about that.
There are data showing
that viral infection--
in particular of influenza--
in the mother in the first
trimester of pregnancy has some
correlation-- it's not 100%--
but some correlation with
negative mental health outcomes
of the offspring sometime
later, including schizophrenia.
This is some of
the work that was
done at Caltech a
number of years ago
and other laboratories, as well.
Those data are still
being built up over time.
Again, it's not one-for-one.
It's not causal.
So if you did get an influenza
or a cold or other kind
of viral infection during
the first trimester
or any trimester of pregnancy,
I don't want to cause alarm,
but you should talk to
your OB/GYN about this.
The goal, of course, is to
avoid viral illness at any time
when you're trying to conceive
or have a healthy pregnancy.
But of course, sometimes
people will get ill,
and the children can turn out
to be perfectly normal and fine.
But it is something
that you want to avoid.
And it will impact
your egg analysis,
and it will impact
sperm analysis.
And one thing I found
really surprising
in researching this episode
was that 1 in 25 men
carry a copy of a mutation
for cystic fibrosis.
Now, some of you are probably
familiar with cystic fibrosis
as a condition that
can cause issues
with the lungs, the
accumulation of fluid
in the lungs or other tissues.
Cystic fibrosis,
in order to express
that way of accumulation
of fluid in the lungs,
you really need two copies.
You need two mutant copies
or you need two copies
of the cystic fibrosis gene.
1 in 25 men will
carry just one copy
and therefore will not have any
symptoms of cystic fibrosis.
But those 1 in 25
men will have defects
in the architecture of
the vas deferens, the duct
through which the
ejaculate needs
to pass in order to
eventually be ejaculated out
of the urethra.
And so what that means
is that these men can
have what appears to
be normal semen volume
but that they won't have
normal numbers of sperm.
And that's not because of a
deficit in making the sperm.
The testes can
function just fine.
The brain and the
pituitary are communicating
with the testes just fine.
But that literally
the passageway
by which those sperm arrive
within the seminal fluid
and are eventually
ejaculated is disrupted
by the cystic fibrosis gene.
Luckily, if somebody has just
one copy of the cystic fibrosis
gene and they're male
and this is the issue,
the vas deferens either can be
repaired by a urologist who's
expert in the surgical
repair of vas deferens
or sperm can be extracted from
the testicle directly, which
might sound like a
painful procedure,
but I believe
nowadays, in talking
with various experts
on this, it turns out
that it can be done with
a minimum of discomfort.
And certainly, if the goal
is to have a healthy child,
you're going to
need those sperm,
so you're going to want to
get them one way or the other,
regardless of the discomfort.
Now, before getting
into some of the things
that you can do in
the positive sense
to increase your
fertility, we do
need to touch on just
a few other things
that you want to avoid
in order to avoid
diminishing your fertility.
And this mainly
relates to males,
but it will also be
relevant to females.
And of course, when I say
also relevant to females,
I'm referring to the fact that,
if it's a woman and a man who
are trying to conceive,
then she, of course,
is going to be interested in her
egg quality but also the sperm
quality.
And of course,
there are women who
are conceiving by way of sperm
donor, through IVF or IUI
or otherwise.
But in any case, the need
to understand and maximize
the quality of both the egg
and the sperm is paramount.
So in order for men to maximize
the quality of their sperm,
as I mentioned
earlier, does not seem
to be a big difference
whether or not they use boxers
or briefs or whether or not
they, quote, unquote, "go
commando," they don't wear any
boxers or briefs of any kind.
However, it is important to
keep the testicles cool enough.
They need to be about
2 degrees cooler
than the rest of the body.
And there are a number of
different ways to do that.
As I mentioned before,
avoid going in hot tubs
during the period
in which you're
trying to conceive children.
You should also
avoid going in saunas
during the period
in which you are
trying to conceive children.
And if you do go in the sauna,
you can bring an ice pack there
and you can put it
on the testicles
in order to offset
the heat of the sauna
and keep the testicles
cool while in the sauna.
The other thing that you'll
definitely want to do
is avoid putting a laptop
or any other hot device
directly onto your lap.
There are a number
of different devices
that you can put on your lap.
You could put books
or a box or there
are these devices that
are designed to dispel
the heat from the laptop.
I would say, if you're
trying to conceive,
just keep the laptop
off of your lap.
Just put it on a table or
standing desk or whatever.
Just keep it off of your lap.
Also, there are some
really interesting data
showing that the amount of
time that men spend sitting,
regardless of whether
or not they sit
with their ankle on their
opposite knee or with knees
spread, the classic man spread
stance, or any other kind
of seated stance is
going to increase
the temperature of the
scrotum for reasons that
are somewhat
obvious if you think
about the architecture
of all this.
I think both men and women, if
you put enough thought to it,
you go, oh yeah, that would
increase the temperature.
Obviously avoid seat heaters
in cars or otherwise.
But reducing the total amount
of time that you spend seated
is really important if you
want to keep the temperature
milieu of the scrotum
optimal for sperm quality
and fertilization.
And as I mentioned
earlier, it's going
to be important to make
sure that your legs are not
really big to the point
where they are creating
a hotter than is healthy
environment for the scrotum
and testicles.
So a hotter than normal
environment for the testicles
can be caused by legs
that are very large,
upper thighs that are very
large due to obesity or due
to those upper thighs
being too muscular.
So by all means,
don't skip leg day.
But be aware that if
you're somebody who's
trying to conceive,
you want to do whatever
you can to reduce the
temperature of the scrotum
or at least not let it
get too hot for too long.
So I can think of
all sorts of reasons
now that men are
going to come up with
to do the man spread
stance of their knees
really far apart, even further
if they have large legs.
That's not a discussion
we want to have here,
and that's not really what
today's discussion is about.
Really the principle is
what's most important, which
is to keep the
temperature of the scrotum
and testicles lower than
the rest of your body.
There's a direct blood flow from
the body to the testicle that
provides blood flow.
It's designed in a way
that that blood pathway
should be outside the
body and as far away
from the body as
possible in order
to get the temperature
milieu of the scrotum
and testicle correct for
healthy sperm quality.
Now, a topic that is sure
to be a bit controversial--
but it really shouldn't
be because the data,
at least to me, are very clear--
is this issue of phone
use and sperm quality.
Now, this can open up a
whole array of issues related
to things like EMFs,
and you've got people
out there who have ideas about
5G and all of this stuff.
That is not what this
discussion is about.
The discussion I'm about to have
with you relates to the fact
that the electromagnetic fields
and the heat-related effects
of smartphones can indeed
have a detrimental effect
on sperm quality and, yes,
indeed, on testosterone levels
as well.
I'm going to refer
you to a paper.
We will link it in the
show note captions.
The title of this paper is
"Effects of Mobile Phone
Usage on Sperm Quality.
No time-dependent
relationship on usage.
A systematic review and
updated meta-analysis."
This is the paper
that came out in 2021
and talks about the fact
that phones emit a radio
frequency electromagnetic
waves, which
are called RF, radio frequency,
EMWs, electromagnetic waves,
at a low level between 80
and 2,200 megahertz that
can be absorbed by the
human body-- we know this.
This is not controversial-- and
have potential adverse effects
on brain, heart,
endocrine system,
and reproductive function.
That has been established.
Keep in mind, there is
basically no controversy
that radio frequency
waves and EMFs
can have a negative impact
on biological tissues.
The question is, how intense
are those radiofrequency waves
and EMFs, and how
detrimental are those
on those biological tissues?
It's a matter of degrees.
But there is very
little controversy as to
whether or not they have an
effect on biological tissues.
And I'm aware of absolutely
zero data showing
that they can have a positive
effect on biological tissues.
Since what we're mainly talking
about now are smartphones,
we want to separate out the
heat effects of smartphones
from the EMFs
related to the fact
that they are Wi-Fi
smartphones or they're
using cellular
towers and Wi-Fi, one
or the other or a combination.
So there are a number of
different things in the phone
that could be detrimental.
We need to separate those out.
Why?
Well, because you
might have heard
that carrying your
phone in your pocket
can reduce your testosterone
levels and sperm count.
And guess what, that is true.
The data contained
within this meta-analyses
and other meta-analyses
clearly point out
that it can reduce sperm count
and maybe testosterone levels
significantly, but certainly
sperm count and motility
significantly.
It reduces sperm quality.
So should you avoid putting your
phone in your pocket, certainly
your front pocket?
I would suggest yes,
if you are somebody
who is seeking to conceive.
I'm not somebody who is going
to stop using my smartphone.
I don't expect anyone's going
to stop using their smartphone.
The question is, should you
carry it in your front pocket
if you're a male?
I think, to be on the
safe side, the answer
is probably avoid doing
that too much of the time.
Ideally, don't do it at all.
Then people will say, well,
what if I turn off the Wi-Fi
or I turn off the
cellular access?
Then is it still a problem?
Well, it's a problem due to
the heat-related effects.
And then people say,
well, I don't actually
feel the heat of the phone.
It doesn't get that warm.
But the temperature effects
of the phone, it turns out,
are enough, even under
conditions in which people
don't report it to be
uncomfortably warm, that it can
change the temperature
milieu of the testicle
in ways that can
diminish sperm quality.
How much and how that
relates to fertility
and healthy pregnancy,
not clear, but since we're
talking about things
to avoid, if your goal
is to have a healthy
fertilization and pregnancy,
well, then, by all means,
just don't carry it
in your front pocket.
Then people say, well,
what about back pocket
or what about backpack?
Look, it's very
clear that avoiding
being too close to the phone is
probably better for your sperm
quality than putting the phone
very close to your testicles
or anywhere else on your body.
But it's also the reality
that most people are going
to carry a phone nowadays.
It's just the reality.
I think the current estimates--
and it's discussed in this
paper-- that 90% of the human
population has a smartphone--
90%, which is incredible-- the
adult population, of course.
Although a lot of kids
have them, as well.
So this paper goes on to detail
a number of different studies
and outcomes from studies.
But basically what they find--
and here I'm paraphrasing--
is that the data indicate
that sperm quality declines
when people start
using a mobile phone.
So from the point they
start using a mobile phone,
regardless of the usage
time-- this is important.
It used to be thought that it
was four hours a day or more
of holding your phone or having
that phone close to your body
was going to diminish
sperm quality.
It turns out that it's
not related to usage time.
That's even the
title of the paper.
It's just the fact
that people are
using mobile phones is reducing
sperm count and quality.
That's the reality.
Is it entirely responsible for
all the reductions in sperm
quality and maybe
even the reductions
in testosterone levels that
we're observing from decade
to decade going forward?
I doubt that's the case.
Is it likely to be one
of the major players?
I've got my bet on the fact
that it is based on the data
that I've observed.
And so if any of you
would like to peruse
the data in this meta-analysis,
they're quite good.
This study looked at 18 studies
that include 4,280 samples.
They were able to
separate out the radio
frequency versus
the heat effects,
and they were able to eliminate
this time of usage variable,
that previously we thought
if you were exposed
to a lot of cell
phone contact, then
it was far worse than if you
were exposed to a little bit.
Turns out, if you're
exposed to any at all,
you're going to
diminish sperm quality.
What does that mean?
Does that mean
that no matter what
you do, if you own a
smartphone, that you're going
to diminish sperm quality?
I think the short answer is yes,
but that you can mitigate it.
What might you do?
Well, keeping your phone away
from your groin or as far
from your groin as
possible if you're
a male who's wishing to
conceive and maybe even a male
who's wishing to maximize his
testosterone levels because it
does appear that radiofrequency
waves and the heat
from the phone--
so both of those factors,
independently and together,
of course--
can disrupt the Leydig
cells of the testes
and the production
of testosterone,
and intratesticular
testosterone is
important for sperm production.
The exact biological variables
leading to all of these changes
isn't exactly clear.
But if you're like
me, you say, OK,
probably not a problem for most
males to carry their phone.
But probably best to not
carry it in the front pocket.
Maybe even avoid carrying it
in the back pocket as well.
Again, in the future,
we will have an episode
all about Bluetooth.
We'll talk about
various aspects of EMFs.
It's a super
interesting data set.
And it's a data set for which
there's a ton of controversy.
It's really
interesting, however,
and there are more and more
quality data coming out
all the time.
And I think, going
forward, we are
going to see that, indeed,
there are some negative effects
of smartphones related to
both the radio frequency
transmission and the fact
that they generate heat.
And in general, heat is not
good for biological tissues.
So any discussion
about heat and sperm
and how heat is
detrimental to sperm
has to raise this
issue of whether or not
cold is good for the testicle.
OK, well, now there's
a lot of data starting
to come out about
the positive effects,
the positive biological effects,
of deliberate cold exposure
on different aspects
of brain biology,
such as the release of
dopamine and norepinephrine,
and on the biology of the
body, to some extent metabolism
but more so the impact on
brown fat stores, which
are good for us, so-called
brown fat thermogenesis.
There's a lot related to
deliberate cold exposure,
and we've done entire episodes
on deliberate cold exposure.
Again, you can find
that at hubermanlab.com.
We did a guest
episode with an expert
on the use of cold for
health and performance
with my colleague Craig Heller
from Stanford Department
of Biology.
We also have a toolkit on how to
apply deliberate, cold exposure
for health for both
females and for males--
for sports performance,
cognitive performance, mood,
sleep, et cetera.
You can find all that,
again, at hubermanlab.com.
Totally zero cost.
Just go into the menu, go to
newsletter, and scroll down,
and you'll find those.
When thinking about
sperm quality,
we want remember that
excessive heat is bad.
Now, does that mean that
deliberate cold is good?
Well, it turns out that one
of the major causes of lowered
sperm count and overall
reduced sperm quality that's
quite common is the presence
of what's called a varicocele.
A varicocele is kind of like
varicose veins of the veins
that innervate the testicle.
And what it
essentially does is it
means that blood will pool
in the testicular region.
It can't circulate back to
the body quickly enough.
And therefore, the temperature
of that environment increases.
There are some other
things that varicoceles
do which can be obstructive
at the physical level.
So they're not just
temperature related.
It's pretty clear that using
deliberate cold exposure
can be healthy for the
sperm because of the ways
not that cold directly supports
testosterone or sperm quality
but rather because
cold reduces heat.
So you will find
available online--
I think they're
actually called--
forgive me, but that's
what they're called.
I didn't name them--
called snowballs.
These are-- they're sort of
like gel pack cold briefs
that you can buy and men will
wear for some period of time.
I don't think you
wear them all day.
You wear them for
some period of time.
A lot of people are now using
cold showers and ice baths
and circulating cold baths
or going into a cold ocean
or lake for any number
of different reasons
I talked about earlier.
I, myself, start every
day with either a one
to three-minute
cold shower or a one
immersion up to my neck
in a cold bath, cold
water, circulating water,
or a cold shower.
I do that mainly for the
psychological effects
related to the long
lasting increases
in dopamine and epinephrine.
But there are
other data starting
to come out showing that
that sort of approach
or similar approaches can
increase testosterone levels
and maybe even sperm
counts, can reduce
cortisol late in the evening if
the cold exposure is done early
in the day, so on and so forth.
So a lot of interesting data
coming out in really good
journals that are peer-reviewed
and so on-- in humans,
I should mention, those
studies are done in humans--
to support the use of
deliberate cold exposure.
But again, if you're going to
use deliberate cold exposure
to improve sperm
quality, can it work?
Yes, indeed, it can
work, either indirectly
by increasing
testosterone or directly
by improving sperm quality.
But both of those effects
are likely to be indirect
by virtue of reducing the
temperature of the testicle
overall, not because there's
any sort of magic effect of cold
on the testicle.
Now, I have to imagine
that a number of you,
in particular the females
listening to this,
are going to say, is
deliberate cold exposure--
and for that matter, is
deliberate heat exposure,
like sauna or hot tub--
good or bad for the ovary,
for eggs, and for fertility?
Now, there are fewer data
to look to, unfortunately.
But what we do know is that
deliberate cold exposure
done in the way that
I just described-- one
to three minutes a day,
ideally early in the day,
through cold shower or
immersion up to the neck--
doesn't have to be an ice bath.
It could be cold
circulating water or even
non-circulating cold water.
And people will
say, well, how cold?
I should have
mentioned that before.
How cold?
There is no way I can
tell you exactly how
cold the water should be,
because for some people,
60 degrees Fahrenheit
will be exceedingly cold.
For other people, 40 degrees is
going to be more appropriate.
How cold should you make it?
If you're going to embrace
these practices, you want--
according to the literature,
what you want to do
is make it
uncomfortably cold such
that you really want
to get out, but safe.
You don't want to go into
30-degree water immediately.
You can actually have a heart
attack and die if you do that.
So you want to progress
gradually into the cold.
So you don't want to shock
your system too much.
Although it is the adrenaline
evoked by that [GASPS],,
that quickening or
shortening or elimination
of the breath for a
short period of time
when you get into
uncomfortably cold water that
correlates with or is
actually the reflection of--
would be more accurate to
say-- the release of adrenaline
and then dopamine
and so forth, which
has been very well documented.
So uncomfortably cold,
but safe to stay in.
And I cannot tell you an exact
number that is uncomfortably
cold but safe for you.
It's going to differ
person by person.
You want to figure that out.
Just like I can't tell you how
much weight that you should
squat in order to achieve
some effective resistance
training for the
legs, it's going
to differ depending
on your strength
and your prior
experience and so forth.
So ease into it.
Be safe.
But it does appear
that both for men,
for reasons I talked about a
few minutes ago, and for women
that deliberate, cold
exposure can be beneficial
for fertility and for
hormone production,
but in particular for females
in terms of regulating cortisol
and for hormone production.
Now, you might say, OK,
getting into cold is stressful.
How can that be helpful
for regulating stress?
Well, it turns out, when
you get into the cold,
you get a big
surge in adrenaline
and then dopamine, which
is very long lasting,
provided that's done in
the early part of the day.
So I would say, not
too close to sleep.
Then what you do is you restrict
your maximum cortisol release
to a period earlier in
the day that buffers--
reduces, that is--
the likelihood
that you would have excessive
amounts of cortisol later
in the day, which not
only can disrupt sleep
but is correlated with a number
of other hormonal effects that
are not good for
us and therefore
not good for fertility.
So here what I'm
describing are positive
yet indirect effects of
a cold on hormone levels
both in males and in females.
So for men, we talked about
increased testosterone,
improved sperm quality
that was indirect.
You're reducing the
temperature of the testicle.
But it's not that cold
itself is positively
impacting those things.
Does that make sense?
Heat is bad.
Therefore, reducing
temperature is good.
Likewise, with females,
deliberate cold exposure
can be good for the
overall fertility process,
not because cold is good
for the ovary or being
cold is good for the ovary
or for luteinizing hormone
or for follicle-stimulating
hormone or anything
else like that, but rather that
using deliberate cold exposure
as a way to restrict
stress in a deliberate
way to a particular
time of day increases
the release of cortisol,
then, and indirectly reduces
the amount of cortisol
that's released
at other times along
the 24-hour cycle.
So these are positive
yet indirect effects.
So if you're a woman who really
is interested in exploring
deliberate cold exposure or
who enjoys it or is already
doing it and you're
wishing to conceive, great.
Explore it.
Do it safely, of
course, but explore it
and continue to do it.
However, if you're somebody
who just hates the cold
and doesn't want to
go anywhere near it,
there's no reason to think
that you absolutely need it,
provided that your stress,
your sleep, and other factors
are all being
carried out properly.
The next things that
we'll talk about
in terms of positive
things or things
that we can do in order
to maximize fertility
for both females and
males are the things
that you also generally
hear about elsewhere.
Right along with sleep and
avoiding alcohol and avoiding
nicotine and avoiding cannabis,
avoiding excessive heat
for the testicle,
avoiding excessive stress,
is that you want to try
to get enough exercise.
Why would exercise have
anything to do with any of this?
Well, exercise-- and that
is both a combination
of resistance training and
cardiovascular exercise--
is going to improve the
health of the mitochondria--
in particular,
cardiovascular exercise.
And I realize that for you
fitness experts out there,
any time someone says "cardio,"
people kind of roll their eyes,
like, what is that?
There's endurance training.
There's interval training.
There's HIIT training.
There's sprints.
There's all sorts
of different things.
Some of those overlap.
Some of them are separate.
Indeed, that's the case.
But we can use a general
rule of thumb here, which
is that, for most people,
getting anywhere from 30
and ideally 45 to 60
minutes of exercise per day
for six days per week,
maybe even seven--
but most people like to
take a day off or need
to take a complete
day off each week--
six to seven days
per week is going
to be good for mitochondrial
health and function.
It's also going to impact
all the other things,
like quality sleep,
mood, reducing stress,
and so on and so forth.
So exercise we can handle pretty
quickly by just saying everyone
should be doing it.
Now, when people are pregnant,
they might have to, of course,
change the amount of exercise
or the type of exercise
that they're doing.
There are varying
opinions on that,
but certainly the type of
exercise and the amount
can vary when
people are pregnant.
But if you're
seeking to conceive,
getting enough exercise
is good because it's
good for the mitochondria.
The mitochondria are present in
that mid region of the sperm.
And mitochondria are critical
for chromosomal segregation
and the spindle
and other aspects
of the formation of a
healthy egg, ovulation,
and fertilization in the female.
One thing that I
know a lot of people
are interested in nowadays is
so-called intermittent fasting
or time-restricted feeding.
I mean, let's be fair, everybody
is restricting their feeding
time because hopefully
everybody is sleeping
at some point in
the 24-hour cycle,
and nobody is eating
while they are sleeping.
That said, many
people are employing
a so-called eight-hour feeding
window or a 10-hour feeding
window or a 12-hour
feeding window.
And indeed, there are some data
to support the idea that that
can be a good thing for a number
of different biological and
health parameters.
However, there are
also a lot of data,
especially recently,
pointing to the fact
that your overall
number of calories
and the quality of
your food sources
is going to be the most
important variable.
And some people simply find
that time-restricted feeding--
intermittent fasting,
as it's also called--
is just a convenient
way to ensure
that your total
intake of calories
is not excessive
for what you need.
Now, with all that
said, there is evidence
that I've covered
in a solo episode
and will soon have
an expert guest
on showing that time-restricted
feeding can have
certain positive outcomes
for various aspects of organ,
cellular, and tissue health.
This is somewhat
controversial, but there
is growing evidence that,
by restricting your feeding
window to, say, 8 hours
or 10 hours or 12 hours,
that it is better than if
you were to eat over a longer
period of each 24-hour cycle.
But again, the data
are still incoming.
The reason we want to talk
about time-restricted feeding,
intermittent fasting
is that a lot of people
do use it because
they find it easier
to not eat at certain periods
of their 24-hour cycle
than to restrict calories.
But again, keep in mind, you
have to restrict calories
if your goal is to
maintain or lose
weight, a discussion
that we've covered
in that episode on
intermittent fasting
and in the episode
with Dr. Layne Norton
and that we will cover in
other episodes in the future.
So refer to those episodes
at hubermanlab.com
if you would like to learn more
about intermittent fasting,
per se.
For sake of this conversation,
a number of people
are probably asking, if
I restrict my feeding
to a certain window each
24 hours because that's
what's convenient or
because I'm excited
about the potential
positive effects
of intermittent
fasting, is that going
to disrupt the likelihood
of fertility and thereby
a healthy pregnancy?
And the short answer to
that is, if you are a female
and you are having regular
menstrual cycles that
is a fairly
consistent duration--
so maybe it's 21
days, maybe it's
35, or anywhere in
between, but it's
fairly consistent
from month to month--
and you are following
intermittent fasting,
time-restricted
feeding, well, then
chances are pretty
good that it's not
disrupting your fertility and
likelihood of fertilization
and a healthy pregnancy.
Of course, during pregnancy,
you need to talk to your doctor
and make sure that you're
eating in a way that's
supportive both of you and
of the developing fetus.
That's extremely important.
I am not aware of
data exploring,
in a regimented way,
time-restricted feeding
during pregnancy.
So please, please, please,
if you're pregnant,
do not jump on a
time-restricted feeding,
so-called intermittent
fasting diet.
Talk to your OB/GYN.
Talk to your doctor.
Talk to multiple
doctors, for that matter,
before doing anything like
that, because, of course,
you're now eating for two, or
if you have twins in there,
you're eating for three.
Very important.
If, however, you're
not yet pregnant
and you want to be fertile, get
pregnant, or simply maintain
a fertile potential
and biology and you're
following intermittent
fasting, it's
going to be the regularity of
those periods and regularity
of cycle length that will
tell you whether or not
that's a good idea or not.
Keeping in mind, of course,
that if your total number
of calories is too low,
your periods will cease.
That's a well-known effect.
But of course, stress
can also induce
cessation of menstruation.
And there are other factors
that can induce cessation
of menstruation as well.
Some of them start with changes
in the brain, literally,
in the hypothalamus.
Some occur in the pituitary.
Many lifestyle
factors can do that.
But most typically,
it's going to be
excessive caloric
restriction or it's
going to be a caloric
deficit brought on
by excess physical activity.
So even if someone's
eating a lot,
if they're not eating enough to
offset their physical activity
or they're not eating
enough of, in particular,
fats, the essential
fatty acids and protein,
but also carbohydrates, well,
then menstruation can cease.
And of course, if
menstruation is ceasing,
chances are, almost
with certainty,
that you're not getting
regular ovulations.
Now, in terms of males
and whether or not
intermittent fasting
is going to disrupt
spermatogenesis and
testosterone production,
there's essentially no
data we can look to.
But we can look to
the general logic
around the relationship
between body fat, testosterone,
and spermatogenesis.
And this was something
that was covered
in a discussion I had on
optimization of hormone
health for males that I
had with Dr. Kyle Gillette,
who's a medical doctor
and obesity specialist.
Again, you find that
episode at hubermanlab.com
if you want to learn all about
hormone optimization in males.
And essentially, the
story is as follows.
If a male is
excessively overweight,
he's carrying too much body
fat in particular, not too
much muscle--
although that can
be an issue too,
but too much body fat
is typically the issue--
so more than, say,
20% body fat--
well, then losing
body fat is going
to be the primary goal for
maximizing testosterone, sperm
health, and spermatogenesis.
If, however, a male is already
lean, well, then actually
increasing calories will
increase testosterone.
So it's a bit of a
complicated story,
although not so complicated that
none of us can understand it.
Basically, if you're
overweight, you
should focus on losing weight in
order to maximize sperm quality
and health.
If you are very lean, well,
then restricting your calories
to the point where you are
starting to lose weight
or you're dropping
even more body fat
is unlikely to increase
your testosterone further.
It doesn't necessarily
mean it's bad
or that you shouldn't
try and go, for instance,
from 15% to 10% body fat.
I'm not saying that
that's bad and that
will reduce your testosterone.
But in general,
if you're already
very lean-- so 10%
body fat, 5% body
fat-- and you start
restricting calories further,
your testosterone
levels will drop.
So in the context of
intermittent fasting,
it's really not an
issue of whether or not
your feeding window is
8 hours or 12 hours.
It's really an issue
of whether or not
you're getting enough calories
to offset the physical demands
and activities of your
life, whether or not
you're on a maintenance diet
to maintain your weight.
And of course, you have to
put all that in the context of
whether or not you're overweight
or lean to begin with.
The simple thing to
take away from this
is, if you're a
male who's using--
because you like it--
intermittent fasting,
so-called
time-restricted feeding,
and you're following an
eight hour or maybe even
a one meal per day
type approach--
although I don't
really recommend
that for a number of reasons
we could talk about separately.
If you're eating over the course
of 8 or 10 or 12 hours per day
because that's what works
for you and you are ingesting
enough calories to maintain
your weight if you're already
lean or you are
ingesting fewer calories
than you are burning in order
to lose weight because you are
already overweight and
you want to lose body fat,
you're probably optimizing
for all the things
that you need to do in order
to improve sperm quality
and testosterone levels.
Now, also in that
episode that I did
with Dr. Kyle Gillette on
optimizing hormones for males,
we talked about testosterone
replacement therapy.
It's not a topic I want to get
into in any detail right now.
But I will say this.
Remember earlier when we were
talking about spermatogenesis
and the fact that in order
for sperm to be generated
consistently every month
ongoing from the time of puberty
until essentially the
time that a man dies,
you need two things.
You need testosterone
production from the Leydig cells
of the testes, and you
need spermatogenesis
to be supported by that
androgen-binding protein
coming from the support
cells, from the Sertoli cells.
So you need
testosterone, and you
need androgen-binding protein,
and you need the Leydig cells
and the Sertoli cells active.
When men take exogenous,
meaning from outside the body,
testosterone, either by cream or
by patch or by pellets or more
typically by injection--
the most typical TRT
approach nowadays is
testosterone cypionate, which
is biologically identical
to the kind of testosterone
you would make.
Well, because of negative
feedback loops, which you also
learned about
earlier, the testicles
themselves shut down their
own testosterone production.
Why would that be?
OK, so you're taking
testosterone in by syringe
or by patch or any other method.
So the circulating testosterone
and the amount that
arrives at the testicle
is going to be hopefully
clinically appropriate,
not super physiological,
but it'll be somewhere in
the healthy reference range,
maybe a little bit higher.
Nowadays, some people are
going a little bit higher.
So we're not talking about
full blown, quote, unquote,
"anabolic steroid
use," keeping in mind,
of course, that
estrogen is a steroid.
Testosterone is a steroid.
But when we think
about steroids,
we mean like
performance-enhancing drugs, so
super physiological doses.
We're talking about
within physiological
or near physiological ranges.
So if someone's taking
their testosterone
in from an outside,
exogenous, source,
the levels of
circulating testosterone
will be sufficiently
high that the pituitary
will register that and will
stop making luteinizing hormone
and generally
follicle-stimulating hormone,
as well.
And as a consequence,
spermatogenesis
is vastly reduced or eliminated.
In other words, for men
who are on TRT or who
are taking testosterone
from an external source,
the number of sperm that
they're going to make
is going to be
dramatically reduced.
There are things that they
can do to offset that,
like taking hCG, human chorionic
gonadotropin, which is just
kind of a mimic for
luteinizing hormone
to stimulate the testes to
continue to make testosterone.
And some men will also--
or instead-- take FSH to
stimulate the Sertoli cells
to support spermatogenesis--
excuse me--
or both or some combination.
Some people take
clomiphene, Clomid.
There are any number
of different ways
to bypass or offset the
sperm-reducing effects
of taking exogenous
testosterone.
This is a conversation
that was covered
in a fair amount of detail in
that episode with Dr. Gillette.
But just keep in mind that if
you are taking testosterone
from an exogenous source, your
sperm counts will dramatically
be reduced, unless you do
something to offset it.
So if you are
wishing to conceive,
you need to think
about whether or not
you're going to offset the
testosterone replacement
therapy or whether or not you're
going to come off it entirely.
So you'll need to talk to
a urologist endocrinologist
about that.
And again, a number of these
different themes and ways
to go about tapering
off TRT were
covered in that episode
with Dr. Kyle Gillette.
So if you're on TRT or
you're considering taking it
and you're interested
in having children,
not just now but at
any point, you really
want to take these things
into consideration.
Now, I do want to point out
that, for the number of you
out there who are taking
supplements, some of which
we've talked about
on this podcast
and I've talked about in other
podcasts, such as tongkat ali--
it turns out that there
are a lot of men and women
taking tongkat ali to reduce
sex hormone binding globulin
levels, to increase testosterone
and estrogen, in some cases,
libido and so forth.
Those approaches, meaning
supplement-based approaches,
to increase testosterone
or free testosterone
or some related
hormones, are not
going to shut down your
own endogenous testosterone
production and reduce the
number of sperm that you make
or, at least as far as we
know, disrupt ovulation
in any kind of way,
provided that the dosages
are within normal ranges.
Again, supplementation
to support your hormones
should not disrupt
ovulation or spermatogenesis
or testosterone production.
Quite the opposite.
It should enhance it.
What I just described
around TRT as taking
exogenous testosterone,
that itself
is an entirely different beast.
Now, with all of
that said, there
are some supplements
out there that
include testosterone
as a ingredient that's
been snuck in to various
formulas that include
blends and things of that sort.
You want to be aware of that.
And we did an episode about
how to develop a rational guide
to supplementation.
I highly recommend
listening to that episode.
Again, it's timestamped,
available free
at hubermanlab.com
in all formats.
Because it talks about
which supplements
are likely to be
"clean," quote, unquote,
to contain the things that
you expect them to contain,
there's more and more
evidence coming out that
a lot of supplements,
including some--
for instance,
supplements that contain
testicle or the
extracts of testicles
can contain testosterone.
Whether or not they can shut
down your own endogenous
testosterone
production isn't clear.
No one's really
explored that in detail.
But based on everything we
just talked about with TRT,
it stands to reason that it
might either reduce it or shut
it down.
It's just never
been explored yet.
So by all means, make sure
that what you're taking
if you're taking supplements.
But again, the
major point here is
that, for both
females and males,
taking supplements to
support healthy hormone
production, including
things like tongkat ali,
is not the same as taking
hormones or bioidentical
hormones, which indeed can
shut down your own endogenous
production of
hormones and thereby
reduce both egg quality and
the chance of fertilization
and healthy pregnancy
and sperm quality
and the chance of fertilization
and healthy pregnancy.
Any time there's a discussion
about fertility and pregnancy,
there seems to also be
a parallel discussion
about sex determination.
That is, what factors can
influence whether or not
the child that's born
is male or female.
That is, whether or not it has
double X chromosomes-- so one X
chromosome from mom, one
X chromosome from dad
because the egg was
fertilized by a sperm that
had an X sex chromosome,
that 23rd chromosome--
or whether or not the offspring
is male, whether or not
it has the X chromosome from
mom, because it's always going
to be the X chromosome
in that egg,
and a Y chromosome
from the sperm that
fertilized that particular egg.
Now, of course, there
are instances out
there of people that have XXY
chromosomes or XYY chromosomes.
But the vast majority
of people out there
are going to have either
an XX chromosome-- so we
call that a female karyotype.
This is different than
genotype and phenotype,
but a female karyotype
would be XX--
or a male karyotype,
which would be XY.
Now, despite the fact that
it is the egg and the sperm
and the chromosomes
that they carry
that are going to
determine the chromosomes,
there's a lot of lore and
discussion about the factors
that can bias which sperm
will fertilize the egg
and thereby whether
or not you're
going to get an XX, female,
or an XY, male, chromosome
and therefore offspring.
Now, not only is the lore
around this whole issue of sex
determination rather prominent,
but it is also somewhat unusual
and perhaps even interesting.
So for instance,
Aristotle himself proposed
that if a man is thinking about
himself and his own pleasure
more than his partner
and her pleasure
at the point of
ejaculation, then
the offspring will be male.
Aristotle also asserted
that if a man is thinking
more about his partner
and her pleasure
at the point in which he
ejaculates, well, then
the offspring would be female.
And of course, we
have zero reason
to believe that there's any
truth to Aristotle's theory.
There are no data
to support that.
In fact, I'm not
even sure how you
would run that experiment
because you can't really
look at people's thoughts.
You'd have to rely on
honest self-report.
And even if people were
to faithfully report
what they were thinking about
at the moment of ejaculation,
this would involve, of
course, bringing people
into the laboratory and
somehow measuring or analyzing
their thoughts or
gathering their thoughts
during the sexual intercourse
at the point of ejaculation,
then figuring out which
biological sex was
the offspring, et cetera.
Just near impossible and
probably not the most important
experiment to invest
our time doing.
Nonetheless, there
continues to be
a lot of lore about
what determines
the sex of the offspring.
Most notably, there's a
lot of lore and discussion
and rumor about the idea that
particular sexual positions
at the point of ejaculation
during intercourse
can somehow bias the likelihood
that a pregnancy will
be either resulting in
male or female offspring.
Now, again, there are
zero data to support this,
and yet this whole notion
of sex determination
is a really interesting
one that people
seem to be somewhat obsessed
by, so much so that, again,
if you go online or
if you were to talk
to people in the sort of
let's call it holistic
or peripheral health spaces
related to fertility,
there is discussion
about, OK, well,
you take this sexual position
at the point of ejaculation
to get a boy and you
take that sexual position
at the point of
ejaculation to get a girl
or you do this in the
early part of the day
or the later part of the day.
Again, all for
which there is zero
data to support any kind
of systematic relationship
between what I just discussed
and the biological sex
of the offspring.
That said, there are
now emerging methods
that people are using in order
to separate out the sperm that
will indeed give rise
to a male offspring
versus a female offspring.
Now, this, of course,
is done in the context
of in-vitro fertilization.
We haven't talked too much
about in-vitro fertilization.
But in-vitro
fertilization involves,
as the name suggests, taking
an egg and taking a sperm,
pairing them in a dish.
This can be done a
number of different ways.
But just to briefly
describe the IVF procedure,
IVF involves
administering supra--
meaning greater than normal--
supraphysiological levels
of follicle-stimulating
hormone and luteinizing hormone
during the follicular
phase of a woman's cycle.
What that causes is the
maturation of not just one
egg that would be ovulated but
multiple follicles and eggs.
And then ovulation
itself is suppressed also
through the administration
of exogenous hormones.
And then, under
ultrasound guidance,
an OB/GYN goes in and collects
the mature eggs and follicles,
puts them in a
dish, and then sperm
are delivered to that dish,
and those could either
be sperm that were
frozen previously,
or more typically or ideally,
it would be live sperm collected
that day that are
washed through a very
straightforward procedure.
And then those sperm
either are allowed
to compete for those eggs
and fertilize those eggs
and allow them to advance
to very early embryo stage
before those embryos are
frozen and eventually implanted
into a woman in order to have
them be carried to full term,
ideally.
Or there's a procedure in which
specific sperm are selected
because they have the
best morphology, motility,
and so forth.
And in a process
called ICSI, I-C-S-I,
in which the sperm themselves
are literally forced
to fertilize that
particular egg.
Now, under those conditions,
typically a couple or a woman,
if she's doing this on her
own with a sperm donor,
will get multiple
fertilized embryos
that are carried to
a multicellular stage
so that it's clear that
they could grow into a child
if they were implanted
into a viable host--
sometimes the surrogate,
sometimes the woman
who wants the child herself.
And under those
conditions, it is
possible to look at
the genetic makeup,
including the karyotype,
of those early nascent
embryos, in which case
people really can select
the sex of their offspring.
That is, they will have
some embryos that are
XX, some embryos that are XY.
It's very likely,
also, that they
will have some embryos that have
karyotypes or genotypes which
are not ideal in that
they would potentially
lead to a miscarriage or
some other genetic defect.
And so, typically,
people do not select
to implant those embryos
if they have the option
to implant embryos that are
of either XX or XY karyotype
and the normal
chromosomal arrangements
for obvious reasons.
So the whole point here is
that sex selection is possible,
but only using
in-vitro fertilization.
The other thing that
is becoming clear to us
in more recent years is that
sex selection is actually
possible at the level
of the sperm even prior
to fertilization.
This is an emerging data
set, and this is largely
happening in clinics outside
of the United States.
But there are some clinics
that have figured out methods
in which they can
take a sperm sample
and they can spin that
sperm sample in a centrifuge
at a rate that separates
out the sperm into what
are called different fractions.
So for those of you who've
done a little bit of biology
with centrifuge, it's when
you spin any kind of substance
that includes multiple things
in it of different weights.
When you spin them, the
things of different weights
segregate out into
different fractions
along the depth of the tube.
And then you can take out
one fraction or the next
simply with a little pipette.
You take out the top
fraction, the middle fraction,
and so forth.
And what these clinics
have figured out
is that if they spin the sperm
sample at the correct spin rate
that the sperm
that will give rise
to male offspring and the
sperm that will give rise
to female offspring segregate
out into different fractions,
allowing them to take each
of those fractions separately
and to apply them to eggs, if
it's in-vitro fertilization,
and give rise very reliably,
certainly much more
than chance, to either
male or female embryos.
They also, of course,
can choose to do
this outside the context
of in-vitro fertilization.
So some people are now opting
to have their sperm samples spun
out in this way, separate
out the sperm that give rise
to male or female
offspring, and then
to only use the fraction
that they are interested in--
so if they want a boy,
they'll use one fraction.
If they want a girl, they'll
use different fraction--
and then to use those fractions
in the context of what's
called IUI, or intrauterine
insemination, which
is, as the name suggests, rather
than having the man deliver
the ejaculate with his penis
and the sperm with his penis,
they have a device.
The devices are now
commercially sold.
Believe it or not, they're
sold over-the-counter
and on the internet, so people
will even do this at home.
And so what they're doing
is they'll take the sperm,
and they'll do IUI in order
to bias the probability
that they're going to get a
male or a female offspring.
Again, this is something
that's now emerging.
It's not commonplace.
Most of the time, people simply
roll the dice, as it were,
by having either intercourse
and just hoping for or not
caring if they get a male
or a female offspring
or, in the instance
of IVF, selecting
male or female offspring,
sometimes largely
on the basis of the
chromosomal arrangements.
So of course, some
people might prefer
to have one or the
other biological sex
as their offspring.
But of course, the healthy
chromosomal arrangements
are going to be paramount
for getting a healthy child.
And as I mentioned before,
unhealthy chromosomal
arrangements or abnormal
chromosomal arrangements
often lead to miscarriage
and/or birth defects.
So selecting for healthy
chromosomal arrangements
is always paramount,
but some people
are selecting for
biological sex.
And indeed, some couples
who can conceive naturally
are opting for
IUI in order to be
able to select biological
sex because of this ability
to spin out the sperm samples
to different fractions
and select the male
or female sperm.
That is, the sperm
that would give rise
to a male or female offspring.
So this is a rapidly emerging
theme, believe it or not.
Who knew?
And of course, it has nothing to
do with Aristotle's assertions
about what people are
thinking about at the point
of ejaculation, nor
does it have anything
to do with body position at
the point of ejaculation.
But I do find it
rather interesting
that, even in this
day and age, people
seem to be continually
pursuing new and different ways
to understand why one
sperm or another sperm
happens to fertilize the egg.
And when that information
is not available,
because, frankly, it's
not available yet--
we don't know why
a sperm containing
a Y chromosome or a sperm
containing an X chromosome
is more likely to
fertilize an egg.
And there are some
ideas, for instance,
that older fathers tend to
have more daughters as opposed
to sons.
But when you really look at
the data, it's pretty mixed.
So if you've heard
that before, it
has a particular nickname
that I'm not going
to describe on the podcast.
You can look it up online.
But if any of you are aware
of any other kind of ideals
or lore, no matter how
ridiculous or crazy, please
put them in the comment
section on YouTube.
I'd be very curious to learn
about those, mostly out
of interest and curiosity.
But, look, sometimes
these outrageous stories,
such as notions of body
position and how they influence
biological sex, even though
they turn out not to be true,
turn out to be interesting
for other reasons.
And in fact, next,
we're going to talk
about how body position
during sexual intercourse
can, in fact, influence
fertility and pregnancy.
So another common theme
around fertility and pregnancy
that you'll hear about
is that, for couples
that are trying to get pregnant,
that during intercourse they
should do whatever it
is that works for them,
but then after
the man ejaculates
that the woman should
try and position
her ankles above her head
or somehow otherwise tilt
her pelvis back in order
to increase the rate and/or
probability that the
sperm swim toward the egg,
as opposed to the
other direction.
Now, I talked to a couple
of different OB/GYNs
and urologists that are focused
on fertility about this topic,
and it turns out you get
pretty mixed answers as to
whether or not there's
any validity to this idea
that the woman's body position
after the man ejaculates
inside of her can
somehow influence
the probability of pregnancy.
One group of experts
told me that there
is no reason for a woman
to need to continue
to lie down, elevate the
ankles, or in any way
tilt her pelvis back
in order to increase
the probability of
successful fertilization.
The other group suggested that
indeed there is a strong reason
to believe that tilting the
pelvis back, maybe even keeping
the ankles elevated,
and having a woman lie
on her back for about 15 minutes
with the pelvis positioned
at about 20 degrees back
is ideal for optimizing
fertilization.
I mean, they were
really specific
about the recommendations.
So I find this interesting that,
within the cohort of extremely
well trained MDs, OB/GYNs
and urology fertility docs,
and OB/GYNs, you see a split.
It has nothing to do
with whether or not
the physician was male or
female or their training
or their institution,
none of that.
There just seemed to be a sort
of even split between the two.
Now, granted, it wasn't
the largest sample size
that I could have obtained.
And yet I do find it
interesting that there's
this split in the
opinion about this.
One group, the group that said,
no, pelvic position doesn't
really matter, don't
worry about it,
it's not going to influence
the rates of fertilization,
argued that the sperm
swim very quickly
and that if they are
released near the cervix
they're going to swim very
quickly toward the egg
in order to fertilize it
regardless of pelvic position.
The other group said, well,
yes, sperm swim quickly
and even if they're
released right at the entry
to the cervix that the sperm
still have a long distance
to go.
Again, if you were to
scale this according
to the size of the sperm versus
the size of a human body,
an entire human body,
what you'd scale it to
is the distance between Los
Angeles and San Francisco.
And it needs to undergo that
basically within 24 hours
or so.
Although, as we
mentioned earlier,
sperm can survive
quite a while inside
of the woman's body-- maybe
three or five days at least.
So in both cases
they acknowledge
it's a long distance.
But on the one hand,
you have a group
of experts that are saying the
sperm more or less know what
to do and are going
to do it regardless
of the position of the woman
after ejaculation inside her
and the other group
saying, no, we
want to do everything
we can to bias
the likelihood that the
sperm will fertilize the egg.
Well, setting aside
the basic argument
that tilting back at the pelvis
and lying stationary or so
for about 15 minutes
after sexual intercourse
and ejaculation is not
an expensive endeavor,
although it requires
a little bit of time.
And it forces people to
remain motionless or close
to motionless, and they're not
up and around and moving about.
Aside from that, it's a
relatively low investment.
So one argument is,
well, if it could
bias the likelihood of
fertilization at all
and people want to get pregnant,
why wouldn't they do that?
So that's a reasonable argument.
But it doesn't really
point to the mechanism.
The arguments that point to a
potential mechanism are that--
if you recall what we were
talking about when we talked
about sperm quality,
sperm quality
involves a bunch of
different measures,
like concentration of sperm
per milliliter of semen,
morphology of those sperm,
how many are forward motile.
It turns out that in any
one ejaculate sample,
the total number of forward
motile and yet fast forward
motile sperm that are also of
the highest quality morphology
is actually quite low.
And so the idea here
is that you want
to get as many sperm
of the highest quality
swimming toward the egg because
those sperm stand the highest
probability of
fertilizing that egg.
And in fact, this relates to
some of the discussion we were
having earlier about behavioral
dos and don'ts for sake
of increasing the
probability of fertilization.
And the one that is most
important here is cannabis.
It turns out that
the data on cannabis
really do support the
idea that some of you
may have heard from
parents and teachers--
I don't know, I did hear this
from parents and teachers--
that cannabis can disrupt
the swimming styles of sperm
in ways that are not
supportive of fertilization,
that it can turn more of
the sperm into twitchers.
Although when I
learned about this,
I was not informed of
the word "twitchers."
What I was told is that,
if you use cannabis,
that the sperm don't know
which direction to go,
that they're confused,
almost implying
that the sperm themselves
are high on cannabis.
Well, that's certainly not the
argument that I'm making here.
But it does seem to be
the case that people
who use cannabis, even once,
the sperm that are generated
during that particular month
or two months during which
or after which they
use cannabis have
less forward motility and
possibly altered morphology,
as well.
I want to be very
clear, I did not
say that if you use cannabis
once you are forever
disrupting the motility and
morphology of your sperm.
I did not say that.
What I said is that if
you use cannabis once,
then the sperm that are
generated in the 60 days
after that cannabis
use are going
to have a higher incidence of
disrupted motility and perhaps
morphology as well.
Remember, sperm are continually
generated every 60 days or so.
And so if you use cannabis
once, you are not forever
disrupting your sperm.
But if you are using
cannabis and then you
are looking to conceive
in the next 60 days,
you are going to be reducing,
we think significantly so,
the number of quality
forwardly motile sperm.
So the simple takeaway from
this is avoid cannabis use.
Although if you are going
to use cannabis-- and again,
there are medical
uses of cannabis
and beneficial uses of cannabis
for certain populations.
It can be bad for
other populations.
We talked about that in
the Huberman Lab podcast
all about cannabis.
But if you're going
to use cannabis,
you should try and abstain
from cannabis in the two months
prior to the attempt to
fertilize and get pregnant.
Now, I'm not aware
of any data on how
cannabis use by the woman
can influence the likelihood
of fertilization and pregnancy.
And I want to couch this whole
discussion around cannabis
under the umbrella of something
that came up in the episode
that I did on cannabis,
which is that, for about half
of people out there,
male and female--
so here we're not distinguishing
by biological sex.
About half of people
that use cannabis
report it as an aphrodisiac.
It makes them want to have
sexual intercourse more than
if they don't use cannabis.
And for the other
half, it actually
has the opposite effect by way
of an influence on a hormone
called prolactin,
which suppresses
the dopamine system,
the testosterone,
and the estrogenic system.
And so this whole idea that
cannabis is an aphrodisiac
seems to be true for about half
of the human population and not
for the other half of
the human population.
So I mention that because
I know a number of people
use cannabis as an aphrodisiac.
They like to use cannabis
before intercourse.
It was actually very
surprising to me
to discover when I
researched that cannabis
episode that approximately
15% of women who are pregnant
continue to use cannabis
during pregnancy.
And that's a very
alarming statistic.
And everything we know is
that the use of cannabis
during pregnancy is detrimental
to the health and particularly
the brain development
of the fetus.
So that's a real concern.
I highly recommend women
abstain from cannabis use
during pregnancy.
Talk to your OB/GYN about
it if you're using it all
or considering using at all.
So based on what I told
you earlier about the fact
that cannabis use is not good
for egg quality and the fact
that cannabis use can
disrupt the motility of sperm
and therefore is not
good for sperm quality
and it can disrupt the patterns
of swimming in sperm in ways
that reduce the
likelihood of fertility,
I think the take-home message
is clear, which is that
whether or not you want
to be a cannabis user
or not, if you are going
to try and conceive
and certainly while
you're pregnant,
you're going to want to
avoid the use of cannabis.
And that is smoked cannabis
and vaped cannabis.
And during pregnancy,
the consumption
of cannabis even in edible
form or in tincture form
is also going to be detrimental
to the developing fetus.
But of course, we
started this conversation
in the context of body
position, in particular
at the point of
ejaculation, in determining
the sex of the offspring and/or
the likelihood of getting
a successful fertilization
in pregnancy.
And I think that given that the
tilting back of the pelvis--
so again, this is elevating the
pelvis by about 20 degrees--
I don't think it has
to be exact, exact--
but about 20 degrees for about
15 minutes post-ejaculation
inside of the
woman-- or I suppose
if people are using IUI,
intrauterine insemination.
Since that seems to be the
consensus among those experts
that believe that
pelvic tilt backward
can be beneficial for
increasing the probability
of fertilization and
given that it involves
no cost but a little bit
of time seems to me that,
if you want to get
pregnant, that that
would be the right thing to do.
And as far as I know,
there's no information
nor was I able to obtain any
recommendations from experts
about what the ideal
body position of the male
is after ejaculation
if the goal is
to increase the probability
of fertilization in pregnancy.
So we've been talking about
behavioral interventions,
some dos and some don'ts that
people can do to increase
their fertility, and the
likelihood that any fertilized
egg will be carried
to term successfully.
And soon we'll also
talk about things
that people can take to
improve their fertility.
Now, keep in mind that
this entire discussion
is about fertility.
But also remember,
as we discussed
at the beginning of
the episode, trying
to increase your fertility
is one of the best ways
to think about trying
to create and maintain
optimal physical health.
So for people that
are trying to conceive
and for people who are
not trying to conceive,
optimizing your fertility
status, whether or not
you're male or female,
is one of the best ways
to target those approaches.
And there are now a lot of
data supporting the idea
that acupuncture
of all things can
be very beneficial for improving
both female and male fertility
and, should a
woman get pregnant,
for improving the quality
of outcomes-- that
is, the likelihood
that there will
be a successful pregnancy
that is carried to term,
not premature, and
so on and so forth.
Now, for some of
you out there, you
might think, oh, of
course, acupuncture,
acupuncture has been known to
work for thousands of years.
And therefore,
it's not surprising
that it would assist with
fertility and pregnancy.
For many of you
out there, however,
probably thinking,
acupuncture, that
seems kind of like
fringe science.
But what I can assure
you is that there are now
quite a few clinical
trials funded
by government agencies, like the
National Institutes of Health,
showing that acupuncture is
a very effective treatment
for a number of
different things,
including fertility
and pregnancy,
but for hormone status,
for stress relief,
even for chronic illnesses
of different kinds,
including autoimmune illnesses.
So this is no longer
considered fringe science.
In fact, one of the
best laboratories
in the world working
on this is a laboratory
out of Harvard Medical School
run by a guy named Qiufu Fu.
Qiufu's lab has really been
exploring in a mechanistic way
how the different
stimulation sites that
are used in acupuncture--
so where the needles are
inserted-- tap into
neural pathways that
link the different
organs of the body.
So for instance, they've
found that stimulation
of a particular site
on the lower limb
can reduce inflammation
dramatically
throughout the body by
way of neural pathways
that originate in the
lower limb and extend
to areas such as the
kidney and the pancreas.
So all these, quote,
unquote, "ancient maps"
of the human body as they
relate to acupuncture
are now being parsed at the
level of mechanism, which
I think is wonderful because
it not only is showing us
that so much of what has
been purported and reported
in the landscape of
acupuncture actually
has an underlying
mechanistic basis,
and with additional mechanistic
understanding, of course,
always arrive new
and better practices.
That's the idea, to evolve
these fields of acupuncture,
to evolve the fields of
mechanistic understanding
of our biology and health.
And so the issue of whether
or not acupuncture can assist
in getting pregnant and in
carrying a child to term
and for that child to
be healthy are really
starting to emerge
in a major way.
And rather than go
into all those data
in detail, what I can
tell you is that there are
clinical trials and data
supporting the fact that
female fertility
itself can be supported
by acupuncture through several
mechanisms, one of which
is the balancing-- and I realize
that's a somewhat tricky term,
and I'll define it
better in a moment--
the balancing of hormones across
the ovulatory/menstrual cycle,
including regulating
levels of FSH
so that they're not
too high nor too low
and restricting the
FSH to the follicular
phase of the menstrual cycle,
as well as using acupuncture
to improve things
like blood flow
and the health of
the ovary itself
and other aspects of the
female reproductive axis.
So acupuncture can operate at
the chemical level, impacting
hormones.
It can act at the
mechanical level,
impacting the different tissues
through which the egg has
to pass and so on and so forth.
Likewise, on the male
side, acupuncture
has been shown to improve
semen volume, quality of sperm,
sperm motility, et
cetera, and in large part
through changes in the
neural pathways that
innervate the very tissues and
vascular input to the scrotum
and testicles, because,
as we learned earlier,
temperature regulation of
the scrotum and testicles
is so vital for
getting healthy sperm
and increasing sperm quality.
In addition, there are good
data to support the idea
that acupuncture can increase
levels of testosterone,
free testosterone, and
the sorts of hormones that
are going to support healthy
hormone production and sperm
production in males.
And this is distinct from
applying testosterone
from an exogenous source.
So when we're talking about
acupuncture and increasing
levels of testosterone, we're
talking about increasing levels
of endogenous testosterone.
So those Leydig cells can
support the Sertoli cells,
and the Sertoli cells can make
that androgen-binding protein,
and you get enhanced
spermatogenesis.
You can find evidence for all
of these different features,
both changes to the
chemical milieu-- that
is, the hormones-- and changes
to the mechanical milieu,
including, for instance,
improvement of the pathways
leading from the seminiferous
tubules to the epididymis
to the vas deferens, basically
clearing out the plumbing so
that more quality
ejaculate can be delivered,
which, of course, is going
to increase the probability
of fertilization.
So when you hear
that acupuncture
can improve the
likelihood of pregnancy,
that's an accurate statement for
which there are now increasing
amounts of mechanistic data.
If you want to learn more
about how acupuncture
can be used to contribute
to improved fertilization
and pregnancy,
there are a number
of different excellent
reviews on this,
both as it relates to females
and as it relates to males.
One of the best papers
that I happen to like
is one that we'll
provide a link to
in the references entitled
"Acupuncture and Herbal
Medicine for Female Fertility,
An Overview of Systematic
Review," so a review of reviews.
This was published
recently in 2021.
We'll provide a link to that.
And there's also going to
be a link to a review that
relates to acupuncture for
male fertility and hormone
augmentation.
I should just mention
briefly that if you're
going to look at
scientific papers,
one thing that you'll
want to consider
is also looking at the
references that they reference.
Now, of course, papers tend to
reference a ton of references,
in particular in reviews.
So what you'll
want to do is look
for the references
that are showing up
most often in the introduction.
Those references
often are going to be
the most prominent recent
reviews or the most important
findings in recent years.
That's not always the case,
but that's often the case.
So if you read the first couple
of paragraphs of these papers--
and these are openly available
as full text, by the way,
online if you go
to these links--
you'll be able to access the
best papers, the most relevant
papers, in the context
of acupuncture supporting
female and acupuncture
supporting male fertility
and hormone status.
Now, I'd like to discuss things
that both men and women can
take in order to
maximize their fertility.
And again and again, when
we're talking about fertility,
we're talking about people
who want to conceive and have
children, but also we're
talking about a basic measure
of overall health status.
So if you're somebody who does
not want to conceive children,
I still encourage you to
think about whether or not
you would want to
do certain things
or not do certain
things in order
to maximize your fertility as a
means to maximize your vitality
and longevity,
because that's really
what maximizing fertility is
about for a lot of people.
That said, I know
a lot of people
would like to conceive
children, perhaps not right away
but in the future.
And what I'm about
to describe are
some tools and
interventions that is things
that one can take in order to
improve their hormone status
but also, in particular,
the quality of their eggs
and the quality of their sperm
in the short and long term.
The first on the list of things
that people can take in order
to improve egg quality or
sperm quality is L-carnitine.
L-carnitine is present
in various foods,
in particular in red meats.
But again, it's going
to be very hard to get
sufficient levels of L-carnitine
to improve egg quality
and sperm quality, the
unless you're going
to take it in supplement form.
The typical recommendation,
based on peer-reviewed studies
that have shown significant
improvements in egg quality--
that is chromosomal
arrangements,
that is the likelihood of
fertility-- or pregnancy,
rather--
the likelihood of
sperm being forward
fast swimmers as opposed
to twitchers or immotile
and having proper morphology--
all those measures
has been demonstrated to
be significantly improved
by the ingestion of L-carnitine.
How much L-carnitine?
Well, that depends on how you're
obtaining the L-carnitine.
If you're obtaining
it in capsule form,
1 to 3 grams per day of
capsule form L-carnitine
is what's been suggested to
improve egg quality and sperm
quality.
Now, 1 to 3 grams per day
can be taken all at once
or spread out throughout
the 24-hour cycle.
It can be taken with
or without food.
It does not seem to matter.
And when taken for a
period of 30 to 60 days,
it does seem to
significantly improve
all the parameters that
have been discussed for egg
quality and sperm quality.
Now, the mechanism for that
effect is pretty clear.
L-carnitine is involved in the
processing of lipids, fats,
in terms of
mitochondrial function.
And as we talked about
before, mitochondria
are vital for the organization
and action of the spindle that
pulls apart the
chromosomes, taking
that cell within the female
from diploid to haploid,
which is essential.
You really want just the 23
individual chromosomal strands.
You don't want
chromosomal repeats.
It's also involved in the
actual fusion of the egg
as it exits the ovary and
enters the ovulation cycle.
Mitochondria are also important,
as we talked about before,
for the forward motility
of sperm because
of the enrichment
of mitochondria
in that mid region
just behind the head.
They cause the
whipping flagellation
of the tail, allowing
for forward movement,
as well as other aspects
of cellular morphology.
So it makes a lot of sense as to
why L-carnitine supplementation
would be beneficial.
Again, it's 1 to 3 grams per
day over a period of about 30
to 60 months.
If you're hoping to conceive
in the upcoming months,
recommend taking it for at
least 30 days prior to that.
Of course, based on the data
we talked about before--
cumulative probability,
fecundability,
et cetera-- there's
no reason to not
continue to try for
pregnancy before taking
L-carnitine, but L-carnitine is
going to improve egg and sperm
quality.
And so you might actually
take the stance that,
even if you don't have any
problem getting pregnant,
wouldn't you want to
maximize the quality
of the egg that gets fertilized
and the quality of the sperm
that fertilizes that egg?
So that's additional rationale
for taking L-carnitine.
One important note--
if you are going
to take L-carnitine in
oral form, in capsule form,
it can increase
something called TMAO.
TMAO can cause stiffening
of the arteries.
You don't want TMAO
levels to go too high.
One way to offset the
increases in TMAO caused
by oral L-carnitine is
to take 600 milligrams
of garlic per day.
I suppose you could
eat cloves of garlic.
That would work just as
well because garlic contains
something called
allicin, which can
offset the increase in TMAO.
But 600 milligram capsules
of garlic are going to be--
or garlic extract, rather--
is going to be the most probably
cost effective and simplest way
to do this.
And also, they are going to
create that garlic smell.
Some people like
the smell of garlic.
Some people don't.
So if you're going to
take oral L-carnitine,
I suggest also
taking 600 milligrams
a day of garlic extract.
And you can do that at any
time throughout the day.
It doesn't have to be
with the L-carnitine.
The next item on the list of
compounds that have been shown
to improve egg quality
and sperm quality--
and quite robustly so--
is coenzyme Q10.
Coenzyme Q10 is something
that you can actually measure
levels of in your blood.
Most physicians
will say that they
want to see your
levels of coenzyme Q10
to be somewhere
between 0.5 and 2.5.
It's going to
depend on the units.
Most people, I
realize, are not going
to run off and get
their CoQ10 measured.
It's not included in most
standard blood tests.
But if you were to
measure your CoQ10,
that's the range that
you want to look for.
That said, many people opt
to supplement with CoQ10.
And you'll find that many
fertility docs, OB/GYNs,
and urologists that are trying
to assist their male patients
with fertility
will suggest CoQ10
because, again, it supports
the health of mitochondria.
Mitochondria are so vital to so
many aspects of the formation
and fertilization of
the egg and sperm that,
of course, fertilizes the egg.
The coenzyme Q10 dosages
that are most often suggested
and that you'll observe in
the peer-reviewed research
literature-- on
humans, I should add--
is 100 to 400
milligrams per day.
And the coenzyme Q10
is taken generally
with a meal and ideally
a meal that contains fat.
And there's even some idea
that taking coenzyme Q10
with your dinner, assuming that
dinner includes some fat-- you
don't have to add
additional fat--
is going to be more advantageous
than taking coenzyme Q10 early
in the day, although
that's probably
a detail that's getting a little
too far down in the weeds.
So again, 100 to 400 milligrams
of coenzyme Q10 per day,
whether or not you're
a man or a woman,
for improving the
likelihood of fertility
by way of improving
egg and sperm quality.
And again, if you're somebody
who just doesn't have
any problem getting pregnant
or if you're already producing
many sperm of
quality morphology,
this is another case in which
you could take a step back
and say, well, why wouldn't
I want to further optimize
the quality of the
egg and the sperm,
because the quality of
the egg and the sperm
ultimately are
going to determine
not just whether or not you
have a successful pregnancy
but are going to determine,
admittedly in ways that will
forever remain cryptic
to you-- but nonetheless
are going to be
important in determining
the qualities of the
brain tissue and body
tissue of your offspring.
The third item on the list of
compounds which are commonly
suggested or prescribed
by fertility docs
nowadays for men
and women wishing
to conceive and/or
optimize their fertility
as a basis for general vitality
and health is inositol.
Now, inositol has many uses.
So you'll hear about
the use of inositol
for reducing anxiety
or improving mood
or even for the
treatment of depression.
We talked about inositol
in previous episodes
of this podcast.
For instance, I
talked about inositol
and in particular taking 900
milligrams of myo-inositol
prior to sleep, which
is something that I do,
along with the other supplements
that I take and recommend
for sleep, such as magnesium 3
and 8, apigenin, and theanine.
If you're curious
about those, you
can see our newsletter on sleep
or our "Perfect Your Sleep"
episode or the "Master
Your Sleep" episode.
It talks about behavioral and
supplementation-based tools
for improving sleep.
But myo-inositol is not just
suggested for or prescribed
for people that are
wishing to get pregnant
and for general health.
But myo-inositol is
often recommended
for people that want to improve
egg and sperm quality because
of the way that
it can positively
impact insulin sensitivity.
Insulin sensitivity might sound
like a bad thing to people
out there.
But it turns out that you
want to be insulin sensitive.
The last thing you want is
to be insulin insensitive.
Insulin insensitivity is
associated with type 2
diabetes, with obesity,
and even for people
who are not challenged
with obesity,
you want your cells to
be insulin sensitive.
You don't want a lot of insulin
floating around in your system
with your cells unable
to use that insulin.
That's really what insulin
insensitivity is about.
Myo-inositol, at dosages
of 1 to 5 grams per day--
that's pretty high,
1 to 5 grams per day,
keeping in mind that 1,000
milligrams is 1 gram--
has been suggested to improve
egg quality and sperm quality.
Now, one point of--
I wouldn't say
caution-- but of note
is that myo-inositol
can reduce anxiety,
and it can be a
slight sedative, which
is why some folks, including
myself, take almost a gram, 900
milligrams, prior to sleep.
If you're going to take
5 grams of myo-inositol,
you would want to restrict
that to the late evening
or second half of your day.
And I don't suggest
starting that high.
I would start with 1
or 2 grams and then
working your way
up, seeing what you
can tolerate in terms of
the level of anti-anxiety
and drowsiness that it produces.
1 to 5 grams per
day of myo-inositol
is what's suggested for both
men and women wishing to improve
egg health and sperm health.
But for women, it's also often
suggested to include also--
so to take myo-inositol, but
to also take D-chiro inositol.
D-chiro inositol
has elements in it
that can be both pro
and anti-androgenic.
Androgens are things like
testosterone and related
molecules.
There are a number of
different causes of infertility
and disruption to egg
quality, age being the most
significant factor.
But another significant
and very common
factor, even among young
women who are of fertile age,
is having too many androgens
and as it relates to something
called polycystic
ovarian syndrome.
We'll do an entire episode
about menopause and PCOS
and a number of
other things that
relate to fertility because
it's an entire and very
interesting other discussion
that we need to have.
But the recommendation
is that women
take 1 to 5 grams
of myo-inositol
but also D-chiro inositol
because of the ways
that it can balance
androgens and offset some
of the negative effects of
polycystic ovarian syndrome
or even for women who do
not have polycystic ovarian
syndrome because of the ways
that D-chiro inositol can
balance androgens in
ways that are beneficial.
The dosages of D-chiro
inositol that are recommended
tend to be 1/25 to 1/40
of the myo-inositol dose.
So you'll have to get
out your calculator.
Remember, 1,000
milligrams equals 1 gram.
So figure out, if you're
taking 1 gram of myo-inositol
per day or 2 grams,
you're going to want
to convert that to milligrams.
So let's say you're taking 2
grams of myo-inositol per day.
That's 2,000 milligrams.
Then you'd want to
divide that by 25.
And that's how many
milligrams of D-chiro inositol
you would want to take, as well.
Or you could go with the lower
end dose and divide it by 40
and take that number of
milligrams of D-chiro inositol
along with the inositol.
Again, probably taking it later
in the day is going to be good.
And it's not clear
at all that taking it
with food or without food makes
any difference whatsoever.
So I would suggest
you do either.
Keep in mind, as I'm discussing
these recommendations,
I may call them prescriptions.
But none of these are
prescription drugs.
And of course, you should
always discuss any supplements
that you're planning to take or
stop taking, for that matter,
with your physician.
I don't say that to protect me.
I say that to protect you.
Any time you're going
to add or change
something in your
overall health regimen,
you want to discuss that
with your trusted health care
professional, typically, I would
hope, a board-certified MD.
The fourth item in the list of
commonly suggested supplements
for men and women wishing to
optimize egg and sperm quality,
respectively, is
omega-3 fatty acids.
And now, here, we're
talking about something
that could be obtained from food
and can be obtained from food.
So if you're consuming
fatty ocean fish, things
like sardines, anchovies,
salmon with the skin,
chances are you're going to
get some quality omega-3s.
Omega-3s are also available
in plant-based sources.
It's also available in
krill, for that matter.
But most people find
it difficult to reach
the threshold required
for optimizing
mental health and
physical health
that is the threshold of the
EPA essential fatty acids.
And so for that
matter, I've suggested
before on this podcast--
and many fertility
docs will suggest--
that their patients take omega-3
fatty acids in supplement form.
It could be taken in liquid
form or in capsule form,
but enough of those that you're
getting at least 1 gram per day
of the EPA form of omega-3,
so at least 1 gram per day
and as high as 2 or even 3
grams per day of the EPA form.
So you'll need to
look at the packaging
because oftentimes it'll
say high potency omega-3.
It'll say 1,500
milligrams of omega-3s.
But that's not 1,500
milligrams of the EPA form.
You look on the back of
the label, and it'll say,
each serving contains
750 milligrams of EPA.
You want to get above
that 1 gram dosage per day
and as high as 3 grams
per day of the EPAs.
The most cost-effective
way to do
that is going to be
liquid-form omegas,
but that's a little bit
inconvenient for many people,
and some people
don't like the taste.
That's why they rely on
the capsule-form omegas.
And of course,
there are compounds
that can impact
fertility status, quality
of eggs, quality of sperm,
not by adjusting mitochondria
or insulin sensitivity
or creating
a general milieu of support
for the egg and the sperm
production and function, such
as the compounds that I just
listed off do, but
rather compounds
that influence the
hormones involved
in the generation of sperm and
the generation of the eggs,
involved in the ovulatory cycle
and the spermatogenesis cycle,
that is.
Now, these are going to
come in different forms.
And I want to just emphasize
that the supplements that
do this, that adjust
hormones in these ways that
can be beneficial, are
distinct from hormone therapy
or bioidentical hormones,
or bioidentical
hormones, because,
as we discussed
earlier, when you take
a hormone like testosterone or
even estrogen, for that matter,
from an exogenous,
an outside source,
you're going to disrupt
the feedback pathways
inside of your body, and
you're going to shut down
your own endogenous production.
The supplements I'm about
to describe do not do that
and yet can adjust levels of
hormones in more subtle ways
that can be beneficial for the
process of maximizing fertility
for males and for females.
The first of which on this
list that I'd like to discuss
has been discussed
in previous podcasts
as well, which is a
substance called tongkat ali.
Tongkat ali also
goes by other names.
But when taken at 400
milligrams per day,
sometimes separated
into two dosages
but typically taken as
once a day early in the day
because they can be a little
bit stimulating, although not
anxiety provoking--
I've never heard of that.
It can be a little
bit stimulating.
But 400 milligrams
a day of tongkat ali
has been shown to
increase free testosterone
by way of reducing something
called sex hormone binding
globulin.
It's also been shown to
increase luteinizing hormone,
the net effect of which
has been described
as a subtle but significant
increase in libido
and some of the other parameters
associated with increased
androgens, like free
testosterone in males
and females.
So a number of people out
there are taking tongkat ali
in this way--
400 milligrams per
day, restricted
to the early part of the
day, with or without food.
People always ask, do you
need to cycle tongkat ali?
I'm not aware of any need
to cycle tongkat ali.
In fact, it tends
to work better,
meaning the effects on libido
and some other hormone profiles
tend to increase over time.
Again, tongkat ali is an option.
Certainly, none of these
things are requirements.
We're simply
listing off options.
But many people, both
males and females,
seem to benefit from
and like tongkat ali,
even if they're not
seeking to conceive.
There's no reason to think
that tongkat ali directly
improves sperm quality.
Except in males, the increase in
androgen created by tongkat ali
supplementation can indeed lead
to improved spermatogenesis.
So there's a growing amount
of data in the research
literature on tongkat ali.
Many people find it beneficial.
And so it's something that
both men and women wishing
to conceive and/or optimize
their fertility just
as a general health parameter
might want to explore.
The other supplement that's
been shown to improve both egg
quality and sperm quality--
and there I'm
referring to a number
of different parameters related
to egg quality and sperm
quality--
as well as to increase
libido fairly substantially
is a substance called Shilajit.
Shilajit, spelled
S-H-I-L-A-G-I-T--
Shilajit is actually
a compound that's
used in ayurvedic
medicine, but there
are some really good
research studies exploring
the supplementation with
Shilajit at about 250
milligrams twice per day.
And this has been looked
at in males and in females.
And it does seem to
significantly increase
two hormones.
One is testosterone,
and the other
is follicle-stimulating hormone.
And for that reason, Shilajit
is often considered a tonic
that people use both as an
aphrodisiac to increase libido
as well as to
increase fertility.
Now, one note of caution,
if you're a woman
and you're considering
taking Shilajit in order
to increase testosterone and
follicle-stimulating hormone,
keep in mind that
the ovulatory cycle
is this very tightly
regulated cycle in which you
want low but elevated levels
of follicle-stimulating hormone
early in the
follicular phase, then
it peaks right before
ovulation, and then low levels
of follicle-stimulating
hormone in the second half
of your cycle.
For that reason, using
Shilajit chronically
around the entire course
of your ovulatory cycle
could be a little
bit risky, and I'd
recommend that you talk to
your OB/GYN prior to doing that
or if doing that at all.
For males, it's a little
bit less of an issue,
because, as I mentioned
earlier, sperm are constantly
being generated, and
the presence of FSH
is going to increase
spermatogenesis.
Now, Shilajit is not FSH itself.
Shilajit stimulates
the release of FSH.
And it stimulates the
release of testosterone.
So again, there's
no reason to think
that it would shut down your
endogenous testosterone or FSH
production.
Although there are limited
amount of data that really
explore that in detail.
Many people use
Shilajit in order
to increase their
testosterone, FSH,
their libido, and various
aspects of sperm health.
Again, the dosages of Shilajit
are about 250 milligrams,
two times per day.
One issue with
Shilajit is it often
comes as a tar, which is a
little hard to measure out
the dosages.
Yes, a tar.
It's this kind of
thick, gummy substance
that you're supposed
to dissolve in water.
And the recommendations
are you take a little bead
and dissolve it in water.
It is available in
capsule form where
the ability to
control the dosage
is made a little bit easier.
But of course, as
with any supplement,
I recommend starting with
the lowest possible dosage.
So you might want to start with
a very small bead of Shilajit
dissolved in water,
taken once per day,
and then increase
the dosage as needed
in order to obtain the
effects that you want.
Things like Shilajit
start to bring us
into the realm of
what can only be
described as a little
bit unwieldy, right?
Here we're saying you can't
really control the dosage.
Now you're talking
about hormones
that need to be tightly
regulated, at least for females
across the ovarian cycle.
For males, yes,
it has been shown
to increase
testosterone and FSH,
improve sperm motility and sperm
count pretty significantly.
No reason to think that you
couldn't do that chronically
with Shilajit.
And yet, I do want to
acknowledge that Shilajit,
as this black tar
substance, contains
a lot of different things.
In fact, it comes
from a mineral pitch.
What is that?
It comes from literally
the dirt and plants
that have been compressed
by rocks in the Himalayas.
So that's pretty esoteric
stuff when it really
comes down to it.
But the biological
effects of Shilajit,
in both males and females,
seem to be related to the fact
that it is highly enriched in
something called folic acid,
and folic acid is
involved in a lot
of different cellular processes,
not the least of which,
at least in this context, is
the transport of molecules
across cell membranes.
And for hormones to
have their effect,
they need to cross cell
membranes on the outside
and the inside of the cell.
So maybe that's how
it's having its effect.
Again, the mechanisms of
exactly how Shilajit increases
testosterone and FSH and
thereby libido, egg quality,
and sperm quality
aren't entirely clear.
But for the more
adventurous of you out there
who want to experiment
with Shilajit,
whether or not you're
trying to conceive or not,
it might be something
to consider.
But of course, do talk
to your physician.
The next compound that I
want to discuss is zinc.
And this discussion
mainly pertains to males,
although I, of course,
should point out
that females should get the
recommended daily allowance
of zinc each day.
Males, on the other
hand, seem to benefit
from having additionally
high levels of zinc intake.
Now, that can be
obtained through foods.
You often hear, oh, oysters
are enriched in zinc,
and oysters are an aphrodisiac.
I don't know who's doing
the marketing for oysters,
but it's really terrific.
I think that seems
to have persisted.
And maybe it's true.
Oysters are enriched in zinc.
What does zinc do for fertility?
Well, in males, we know,
based on a really nice set
of studies, that
zinc dosages that
are pretty high of
about 120 milligrams
taken twice per day--
that's quite a lot-- with
meals can significantly
increase testosterone
and dihydrotestosterone.
And this probably shouldn't
come as a surprise to us.
It turns out that zinc is
highly enriched in human testes
and in the testes
of other animals,
including fish
and other mammals.
And it was actually in 1921
that it was observed in fish
that zinc levels skyrocket
in the testes of fish
during their breeding season.
So zinc is correlated with
increases in breeding,
but you never know
which direction
that correlation is running.
It turns out that
zinc in both animals,
including fish, other mammals,
and in humans, strongly
impacts the enzymatic
functions in the testes,
including the function of
androgen-binding protein.
So it seems that
high levels of zinc
can increase spermatogenesis
and testosterone
levels very significantly.
This was explored in
a really nice study
that I'll provide
a reference to.
It's an older study.
But I really like.
It's called "Effect
of Zinc Administration
on Plasma Testosterone,
Dihydrotestosterone,
and Sperm Count."
This is but just one
study among many now.
This dates back to 1981,
but there have been studies
subsequently that point to
the fact that supplementation
with zinc at those
high levels can really
be helpful in
terms of increasing
sperm count,
testosterone, and even
testicular size, of all things.
So one important
point about taking
zinc-- this 120 milligrams
of zinc two times daily
definitely needs to
be done with meals.
If you've ever taken
zinc on an empty stomach,
even if you just take 15
or 30 milligrams of zinc,
you can feel very nauseous,
not well, for a few hours.
So make sure that you're
taking zinc with full meals.
So this would mean that
you're taking in at least
two full meals per day.
I should also mention that
zinc supplementation did not
appear to impact
gonadotropin-releasing hormone
or prolactin.
So it seems to be a
fairly targeted effect
on the testosterone and
related pathways in males.
As far as I know, there have
not been systematic explorations
of the effects of high levels of
zinc administration on females.
I would hope that those
studies would soon be done.
But meanwhile, if
you're a male and you're
interested in
improving sperm quality
and your testosterone levels
overall for whatever reason,
zinc likely is a good candidate.
And that pretty much
summarizes the compounds
that men and women
should take in order
to maximize egg quality,
sperm quality, and fertility.
And then, of course,
we start to enter
the landscape of other things
that men and women can take
in order to improve fertility,
and those other things
generally are
prescription drugs.
And so I just want to mention
what a few of those are.
But of course, these are things
that you would absolutely
have to obtain prescriptions
for from your MD,
and your MD, without
question, would
want to take blood tests prior
to prescribing these things.
So for instance,
if men have been
taking exogenous
testosterone through the use
of anabolic steroids, like
performance-enhancing drugs
or even testosterone
replacement therapy,
their endogenous
testosterone levels
are going to be very low,
and their sperm counts
unless, for instance, they
are prescribed and
taking something
like hCG, human chorionic
gonadotropin, which
mimics LH and would stimulate
the testes to produce
testosterone and through
some indirect pathways rescue
spermatogenesis, although
not to the same degree
as if people are not
taking exogenous sources
of testosterone.
Some men, even if they've
never touched TRT or exogenous
testosterone of any
kind, will be prescribed
to take hCG because
of its ability
to stimulate the
testes to produce
more testosterone and sperm.
So they're just
taking hCG alone.
Other men will take--
or will be prescribed, rather--
FSH in order to stimulate
spermatogenesis, or hCG
and FSH, or clomiphene,
which can regulate
all sorts of things in
the both testosterone and
estrogen-related pathways at
the level of brain and pituitary
and gonad, testes.
Likewise, for women,
if they're low in FSH,
they might be prescribed FSH.
If they are low in
luteinizing hormone,
they might be prescribed hCG.
If they're low in
testosterone, they might even
be prescribed testosterone.
And if their
testosterone is too high
and they're dealing
with PCOS, they
might be prescribed
anti-androgens and androgen
blockers and on and on and on.
There are so many
different hormones that
can impact the different
aspects of the ovulatory
and the spermatogenesis
cycle that the OB/GYNs
and the urologists focused on
male fertility nowadays really
have an excellent handle
on which levers and buttons
and threads to pull and
push and so forth in order
to set in motion
a proper ovulatory
cycle and a proper
spermatogenesis cycle.
Everything we talked
about up until now
and in the early
phase of this episode,
especially, about how
the brain commands
the pituitary and the pituitary
commands the gonads and then
the gonads, the
ovary, or the testes
send feedback signals
to the pituitary
to then influence
the pituitary, all
of that incredible
orchestra, that dance,
is so tightly regulated in
a way that really provides
the OB/GYNs and
the fertility docs
concerned with male fertility
exceptional tools to,
for instance, figure out if a
man is not producing any sperm
but his testosterone levels
are well within normal range,
well, then there are some very
clear sets of explorations
and potential treatments.
Some of which are
mechanical, making sure
the epididymis and vas
deferens are clear,
allowing the sperm to
enter the ejaculate
and the ejaculate
to enter the urethra
and obviously to enter
the female, as well
as for a woman
who's not ovulating
to adjust her levels of FSH or
maybe even to apply acupuncture
in conjunction with
supplementation
and various prescription
hormone therapies to adjust
fertility and ovulation
and the probability
of successful pregnancy.
So there's a vast landscape
of prescription drugs
and surgical interventions
of varying degrees
of invasiveness.
And some are, for instance,
outpatient procedures.
Some require general
anesthesia, et cetera,
in order to maximize male
and female fertility.
What I've tried to do
today is to provide you
with a deep dive understanding
of the ovulatory and menstrual
cycle.
We talked about the brain,
the pituitary, the ovary,
the Fallopian
tubes, and, in fact,
the whole female
reproductive axis
as it relates to
fertility and reproduction
I also describe the male
reproductive axis as it relates
to the brain, the pituitary,
the gonad, the testes,
and the various
ducts, the pathways,
out of the testes that allow
the sperm to be enriched
within the semen and then
the semen and the ejaculate
to exit through the urethra.
I did all that as a way
to frame the various tools
and interventions
that can really
assist in increasing fertility,
egg quality, and sperm quality.
So when we discuss
mitochondria in the context
of the development of an egg
or the development of sperm
and its ability to
swim quickly forward,
now it should make
sense as to why
give an intervention,
whether or not
it's L-carnitine
or whether or not
it's exercise or whether or
not it's getting enough sleep
and limiting stress, why all
that should matter and why,
in fact, mechanistically
those interventions can work.
Because, indeed, there
are many interventions
that we can all do and use
to support our fertility.
And again, as a more
general theme today,
I really wanted to,
A, teach you about
the human reproductive axis--
I do find the biology of the
ovulatory and menstrual cycle
and spermatogenesis to be
absolutely fascinating to me.
And again, if you're somebody
who's interested in conceiving
or if you've already
conceived children
and even if you don't
want more children,
this is really the
aspect of our biology
that allowed us to be here.
It's the aspect of our biology
that determined whether or not
we are male or female.
It's the aspect of our biology
that determines so, so much,
and yet I think that most
of us generally are not
taught this in school or
at least not at the depth
that we discussed it today.
So hopefully that information
was in and of itself
interesting and
perhaps useful as well.
And I do think that
even if people are not
wishing to conceive more
children that the information
related to fertility and
optimizing egg and sperm health
is of value in the sense that
can be used as a proxy for
optimizing our body and brain
health generally.
In other words-- and here I'm
admittedly taking words out
of the mouths of the
various wonderful doctors,
the OB/GYNs and neurologists
that helped inform me
in anticipation of this
episode-- what is good
for the woman is
good for the egg
and for fertility
and for pregnancy.
And what's good for the
man is good for the quality
and production of sperm and
for fertility and pregnancy.
Put differently, whether or
not we are male or female,
the things that we can do
to optimize our fertility
are the exact same
things that we should all
be doing to optimize our
vitality and our longevity.
And I realize today's episode
was so much the deep dive
and fairly broad, as well,
that it ended up being
fairly long and extensive.
And yet we still
have not touched
on any of the important themes
that I know a number of people
want to know about-- so,
for instance, menopause,
andropause, PCOS,
and other themes
related to hormones and
reproductive function
and biology.
And I promise that we will have
episodes, both solo episodes
and episodes with expert
guests, in the future
to cover all of those
topics in detail.
Meanwhile, the information
discussed in today's episode
should serve as a
basic foundation
for those discussions
going forward
and hopefully were of interest
to you in their own right.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to
our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific,
zero-cost way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify
and Apple, you
can leave us up to
a five star review.
If you have
questions or comments
about the podcast
or guests that you'd
like me to bring on the
Huberman Lab podcast,
please put those
questions and suggestions
in the comment
section on YouTube.
I do read all the comments.
In addition, please
check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
During today's episode and
on many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
we discussed supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them
for things like sleep,
hormone augmentation, focus,
and much more.
The Huberman Lab
podcast is now partnered
with Momentous Supplements
because, as I mentioned
at the beginning
of today's episode,
Momentous Supplements are
of the very highest quality,
they ship
internationally, and they
have single-ingredient
formulations
that allow you to
develop the most
biologically-effective and
cost-effective supplement
regimen for you.
If you'd like to see the
supplements discussed
on today's and other
Huberman Lab podcasts,
please go to livemomentous--
spelled O-U-S--
so livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you're not already
following us on social media,
please do so.
We are Huberman Lab on
Instagram, Twitter, Facebook,
and LinkedIn.
And at all of those
places, I discuss
science and science-related
tools, some of which
overlap with the contents
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
but much of which is
distinct from the content
of the Huberman Lab podcast.
So again, it's Huberman Lab
on all social media platforms.
And if you haven't already
subscribed to our newsletter,
we have a zero-cost newsletter.
It is called the Neural
Network Newsletter.
And each month, it includes
things like podcast summaries
and toolkits for
things like sleep,
focus, dopamine optimization,
fitness, and so on.
You can sign up for
the newsletter-- again,
completely zero cost-- by
going to hubermanlab.com.
Go to the menu.
Go to the newsletter.
You provide your email, and
we do not share your email.
And again, the newsletter
is completely zero cost.
Thank you, once
again, for joining me
for today's discussion all
about the biology surrounding
this incredible thing that
we call fertility, including
the ovulatory cycle,
spermatogenesis, fertilization
itself, and all the events
leading up to pregnancy.
And last but
certainly not least,
thank you for your
interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]